GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US AND
I APOLOGIZE THAT WE'RE STARTING
A BIT LATE.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE.
WITH ACTIVATED TAKE CARE OF SOME
HOUSEKEEPING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
UNTIL WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON CONSENT
TODAY THAT'S ITEM SIXTEEN SB.
SIX THIRTY SEVEN ITEM EIGHT SP
TWO FORTY ONE HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA [inaudible]
ITEM.
SIX ITEM SIX WHICH IS SB ONE
EIGHTY TWO CENTER JACKSON WILL
BE UNABLE TO PRESENT TODAY.
I'LL BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
AND WITNESSES HAVE A HEART OUT.
JUST PRIOR TO LIVE IN AM SO
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE A PRESENT
THAT BILL ROUND TEN FIFTEEN TEN
THIRTY ISHE.
ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH THIS
COMMITTEE HAS THIRTY ONE BILLS
IN FRONT OF IT.
ON MAY FIRST FIFTEEN BILLS.
AND IF WE GO PAST ONE O'CLOCK OR
HEAD ON OVER TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY UNLESS MSS LANE CHESTER'S
READY TO GO RIGHT MASLEN CHESTER
--
SHE'S REAL.
AND NOT ONE I'D TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE TEAM.
THERE ARE SEVERAL BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATED TODAY AND I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HIM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK.
THEY GENERALLY GET RIGHT INTO IT
ON SB THIRTEEN CENTER AYE CASKET
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
SENATOR FOR ALL OF HIS WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE ON
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS.
THROUGH A CASKET THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND I APOLOGIZE WE HAVE
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT'S ALL RIGHT --
SB THE AYE THIRTEEN HAS BEEN
SLIMMED DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY FROM
LAST YEAR'S SB. EIGHT THREE ONE
WE FREE MOVED TO REQUIREMENTS
PERTAINING TO FLOOR AREA RATIO
--
SETBACKS AND TO LOT SIZES TOO SO
EVERYBODY'S CLEAR ABOUT THIS
I'VE AGREED TO REMOVE THESE I
IT'S NOT THAT IT'S IT'S IN THAT
MISSION BY ME THAT THESE ARE NOT
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT THEY NOW
REMAIN BARRIERS.
BUT IN THE SPIRIT OF NEGOTIATION
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES THAT EIGHT
THREE ONE FACE LAST YEAR'S AND
MAKING THAT MOVE.
HOWEVER THIS THIS BILL STILL
PRODUCES DEVELOPER IMPACT FEES
ELIMINATES HOMEOWNERSHIP
REQUIREMENTS -- ADDRESSING WHAT
THAT -- H. C. D..
THE HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT -- THE AGENCY SAID
IN A RECENT SPECIAL LEGISLATIVE
EIGHTY YOU HEARING WITH THE TOP
TWO ISSUES THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESS.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT STUDIES FROM
PLACES SUCH AS THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ AND UC BERKELEY THAT HAVE
SHOWN THAT DEVELOPER IMPACT FEES
ARE EXCESSIVELY HIGH FOR EIGHTY
USE. FOR INSTANCE THE UC
BERKELEY FOUND THAT SOME WILL
KILL THESE ARE CHARGING AS MUCH
AS FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
UNIT AND THAT NUMBER DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE IMPACT FEES CHARGED
BY UTILITY DISTRICTS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AND AND OTHER DISTRICTS IT'S A
WONDER WERE WE HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ON PERMITTED
EIGHTY USE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MANY HOMEOWNERS THAT WANT TO
BUILD EIGHTY USE ARE STOPPED IN
THEIR TRACKS WHEN THEY'RE HANDED
THESE FEES EIGHTY USER BUILT ON
LOTSA ALREADY HAVE PAID
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES HE SAID
IT AGAIN THEY'VE ALREADY PAID
THE DEVELOPMENT AND FOR IMPACT
FEES.
HOMEOWNER SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY
THEM AGAIN ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT THE
HOMEOWNER CAN EXPAND THEIR HOME
FOR A BEDROOM OF THE KITCHEN A
BATHROOM.
WHERE THEY PAY -- ZERO DEVELOPER
IMPACT FEES I THINK I TESTIFIED
LAST YEAR MISTER CHAIR THAT --
MY WIFE SEE WHEN I BUILT A FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY SQUARE FOOT
ADDITION WE ADDED THE BATHROOM
WE EXPANDED.
THE BEDROOM AND WE ADDED THE
SECOND STOVE AND WE PAID NOTHING
GOES A MINISTERIAL ONE DAY
EVENT.
SB -- THIRTEEN PROHIBITS HOME
OCCUPANCY ORDINANCES WHICH
REQUIRED THE OWNER TO LIVE AND
EITHER THE EIGHTY YOU ARE THE
PRIMARY UNIT WE DON'T DO THIS
AND DUPLEXES TRI PLEX IS. FOR
PLEXUS.
APARTMENTS THERE'S AN UNFOUNDED
FEAR THAT INVESTORS ARE BUYING
UP THESE HOUSES AND JUST TO
BUILD EIGHTY USED TO RENT THEM
OUT.
IN REALITY STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THE MAJORITY OF A THE USER
BUILT BY HOMEOWNERS THE HOUSE
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
THE CITY OF PORTLAND IN THE
STUDY AND THEY FOUND OUT THAT OF
TWELVE HUNDRED EIGHTY USE ONLY
10% WERE BUILT BY IN.
THAT STIRS I WOULD SUBMIT MISTER
CHAIR IT'S A RED HERRING -- MOON
OWNER OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS
LIVE LIMIT THE MARKETABILITY OF
EIGHTY USE AND PREVENT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THEM I HAVE I
KNOW THAT THE STAFF TO ITS IS TO
NOT ACCEPT -- BACKGROUND I HAVE
LETTERS FROM BANKS TO SAYING
THEY WILL NOT LAN TO TO TO
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO MOVE INTO POSITION IN FACT IF
THERE'S A FORECLOSURE THAT THEY
HAVE TO TAKE OCCUPANCY OF THE
HOUSE.
THERE'S NO COINCIDENCE THAT THE
FOUR LARGEST CITIES IN NORTH
AMERICA WITH THE GREATEST GROWTH
AND EIGHTY USE OUR CITIES THAT
PROHIBIT OWNER OCCUPANCY.
IF WE DO NOT ADDRESS THESE
BARRIERS WE DO AND WE'RE DOING
TWO THINGS WE'RE RATHER
DISCOURAGING HOME OWNERS FROM
ASSISTING US IN HELPING HOUSING
CRISIS OVER IN COURAGE AND
PEOPLE TO BUILD THESE UNITS
WITHOUT A PERMIT.
WITH ME TODAY IS -- TAMARA
CISNEROS WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
MRS HARRIS WE WELCOME YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THE MORNING SEE WHAT IS CENTERS
WITH BERRY COUNCIL A NONPROFIT
PUBLIC PROBABLY POLICY
ORGANIZATION.
ADVOCATING FOR VARIOUS ISSUES
FIRST OUR ECONOMY AND A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR EVERYONE WHO
LIVES HERE -- AS A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF MOSTLY HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE BECAUSE HE THE COALITION
AS SEE WHY COALITION FOR THOSE
ADVOCATING FOR EXCESS RETELLING
UNITS.
OUR HOUSING SHORTAGE CONTINUES
TO DRIVE OF HOUSING CRISIS
ADDRESSING A SHORTFALL OF THREE
AND A HALF MILLION HOMES WITHIN
SEVEN YEARS SOUNDS DON TEEN.
BUT IF ANYTHING THIS REQUIRES US
TO TAKE AMBITIOUS BOLD ACTION.
YES SEVERAL BARRIERS T OVERCOME
BUT WE SHOULDN'T UNDERESTIMATE
EIGHTY USE AND SB THIRTEEN TO
PROVIDE A VIABLE SOLUTION TO OUR
WHERE AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. FOR
EXAMPLE EIGHTY USE OUR FOR WILL
BY DESIGN THE COST LESS TO BUILD
AND RAN FOR LESS.
ACCORDING TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TURNER CENTER REPORT ALMOST 60%
OF EIGHTY YOU OWNERS RIGHT TO
THEIR UNITS AT BELOW MARKET
RATES.
AND THE ENTRY TO MARKET IS AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY.
THE MAJORITY OF HOMES AND
CALIFORNIA ARE SINGLE FAMILY
RESEARCH FROM UC BERKELEY SHOWED
THAT 31% OF BAY AREA HOME OWNERS
--
WOULD BUILDING EIGHTY YOU IF IT
WAS FEASIBLE.
AND THE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT NINE MILLION IF
JUST 10% OF THOSE NINE MILLION
HOMES WERE TO BUILDING EIGHTY
YOU THAT WOULD DELIVER.
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW
HOUSING TO OUR STOCK.
NO OTHER HOUSING SOLUTION OUT
THERE.
HAS THIS LEVEL OF SCALABILITY
AND ONLY SCALE CAN SOLVE THIS
CRISIS.
ALTHOUGH WE MADE SOME PROGRESS
IN LOWERING AT RESTRICTIONS WITH
PASSAGE OF SB TEN SIXTY NINE
WHICH WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR SB
THIRTEEN BUILT ON THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
SOLUTIONS.
AND TAXIS ARE MAJOR BURDEN FOR
THE TYPICAL HOMEOWNER AND ARE
DESIGNED FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION
THAT TRIGGER INCREASE SERVICES
AND UTILITIES.
THAT 25% CHARGE FOR EIGHTY USE
OVER CENTER FIFTY SQUARE FEET
IT'S A FAIR COMPROMISE FOR BOTH
AGENCIES AND HOMEOWNER.
AND I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT 25% OF NOTHING IS NOTHING
SO IF WE PUT THE IMPACT FEE TOO
HIGH THEN IT'S JUST GOING TO
ENCOURAGE A BLACK MARKET. THIRTY
SECONDS.
OKAY.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
GOOD POINT ABOUT ON OCCUPANCY
BEING ON AND NECESSARY --
DETERRENT THERE'S A SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES TWO MILLION OF
THOSE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES ARE --
RENTER OCCUPIED.
THIS WILL LEGISLACIóN WILL ADD
THOUSANDS OF NEW HOMES TO
CALIFORNIA'S HOW THE STARK. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MORE WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT SB.
THIRTY THANK YOU SO MUCH MISSUS
S. WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO OPEN UP TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
THE WELCOMING COMMITTEE FOR SOME
LASSEN ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M ERIN EVENTS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA A AND B.
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SEVENTH GIVE OUR BEST TO THE
CENTER PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MORNING DENISE
PINKSTON ON BEHALF OF THE CASITA
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SENATOR CASKEY FOR YOUR LEADERS.
THANK YOU.
SELECT A LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
SUPPORTED TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
COULD PLEASE COME FOR DIFFERENT
TWO SEATS.
WE'LL HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS.
AS WELL AS A SECONDARY WITNESS.
WHO'S GONNA LEADER'S OFFICE OUR
PRIMARY WITNESS INDIVIDUAL HAS
FIVE MINUTES SECONDARIES TWO
MINUTES WHO'D LIKE TO ITALY TO
SOFT.
LADIES FIRST HATED SO TAKE FIVE
MINUTES THAT'S ALL THAT WE
WELCOME IF YOU COULD PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THANK YOU I'M
LAWRENCE EVELYN SEAT
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
AND WE DO HAVE OPPOSE UNLESS
SUBMIT AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL I WANT TO
START OUT BY THANKING US SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE KEY FOR SLIMMING
DOWN.
ON WHAT WAS INTRODUCED THIS YEAR
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT --
AND ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT AP
CALIFORNIA IS NOT OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY USE WE I DO SUPPORT AT IS
ON A REALLY PLEASED TO SEE THE
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS -- BUT WE DO. FOR
TODAY I'LL FOCUS ON OWNER
OCCUPANCY WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE REMOVAL OF ON OUR
OCCUPANCY WRIST RAT RESTRICTIONS
THAT CAN BE APPLIED -- NOT
BECAUSE WE WANT THEM TO BE A
BARRIER TO EIGHTY USE BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE ONE OF THE
TOOLS THAT CAN HELP ENCOURAGE
AFFORDABILITY FOR EIGHTIES.
I'M CURRENTLY AN EXISTING OTHERS
NOTHING THAT REQUIRES EIGHTY
USED TO BE AFFORDABLE HOWEVER AS
I SAID I THINK HONOR OCCUPANCY
CAN BE ONE TOOL THAT
JURISDICTION'S CAN USE TO HELP
ENCOURAGE THAT.
THE HOMEOWNER IS LIKELY MORE
LIKELY TO RENT OUT THERE AT YOU
AT AN AFFORDABLE RENT -- AND
REMOVING -- OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENTS -- DOES CONCERN APA
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS THE
POTENTIAL FOR INSTITUTIONAL
INVESTORS AND OTHERS TO COME IN
AND POTENTIALLY RENT TODD -- TO
EXCUSE ME BY A PROPERTY AT AN
EIGHTY YOU UP BY A PROPERTY WITH
AN EIGHTY YOU AND RENT OUT BILLS
FOR WHATEVER THE MARKET WERE
WELL THERE AND WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED -- THAT THAT COULD
HAPPEN WITH THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENTS REMOVED -- ON TOP
OF THAT OWNER OCCUPANCY OR THE
EIGHTY USE DO NOT -- HAVE MANY
OF THE OTHER DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS THAT -- DUPLEXES TRI
PLEX IS AND ALL OF THOSE UNITS
TO HAVE -- AND THEN POTENTIALLY
IF THEY HAVE REDUCED OR NO
IMPACT FEES THERE'S REALLY A BIG
--
INCENTIVE FOR DEVELOPERS TO COME
IN AND DO THIS -- AND WE ALSO AS
I MENTIONED KNOW THAT SOME
JURISDICTIONS DO USE -- OWNER
OCCUPANCY AS WAY TO ENCOURAGE --
AFFORDABILITY FOR EXAMPLE SANTA
ROSA WAVES OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENTS IF THERE'S A DEED
RESTRICTION FOR A ABILITY ON THE
UNIT.
SO -- WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE CONCERNS WITH THE FINANCIAL
--
ISSUES THAT HAVE COME IN PLACE
WITH OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE DON'T WANT
THAT TO BE THE BERRIER -- FOR
HOMEOWNERS TO BE ABLE TO ADD AN
EIGHTY YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO TRY TO COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION THAT WOULD STILL
ALLOW SOME PARAMETERS AROUND ON
YOUR OCCUPANCY WITHOUT
COMPLETELY REMOVING THEM -- BUT
FOR THOSE REASONS RIGHT NOW WE
DO REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US WHY THE WHOLE THERE
WE WALKING A LITTLE LEAGUE
HELPING CITIES YES THANK YOU SIR
--
MEMBERS CHAIRED JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE CERTAINLY
SHARE THE CONCERNS ON THE EPA'S
MENTIONED -- BUT WE DO.
YOU KNOW APPRECIATE THE SENATOR
--
SCALING HIS BILL BACK AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE CENTER FOR
YEARS NOW ON THIS ISSUE ON THE
LEAGUE CERTAINLY IS NOT OPPOSED
EIGHTY USING THESE ARE IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR MANY OF OUR CITIES TO
INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY.
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY OBJECTIONS
TO THE BILL THAT IS IN PRINT
BEFORE YOU NOW AND REALLY IT'S
THE IMPACT FEE PIECE IT IS A IS
A MAJOR HURDLE FOR US -- WE
ALWAYS GONNA BE MINDFUL THAT
THESE IMPACT FEES ARE CHARGED
THEY HAVE TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
MITIGATION FEE ACT I'M WHICH
HIGHLY REGULATE HOW CITIES
CHARGES FEES ARE SB NEXUS STUDY
WE CAN ONLY CHARGE FOR THE THE
SERVICE ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
DELIVER.
CITIES CANNOT MAKE MONEY ON
THESE FEES THEY DON'T GO TO OUR
GENERAL FUND THEY DON'T YOU KNOW
HELP WITH OTHER SERVICES OTHER
THAN THE SERVICE THAT WE'RE
DELIVERING BASED ON THE IMPACT
OUR COMMUNITY.
AND IT'S IT WE CAN'T HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS IF PEOPLE ARE MOVING
INTO OUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE THIS
IS AN AFFORDABLE OPTION THEN WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CHARGE IS
IMPACT FEES BECAUSE THEY'RE TO
DEMAND A SERVICE -- SO THE FEES
ISSUES IS A MAJOR CONCERN AT A
MINIMUM WE WOULD HOPE THAT MAYBE
WE GET POSITIVE CASH ON FEES
UNTIL THE REPORT COMES OUT JULY.
ONE MACD IS GONNA ISSUED A
REPORT ON FEES MITIGATION FEE
ACT AND WE'LL SEE A WHOLE HOST I
BELIEVE OF OPTIONS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THIS BODY I'M
TO PERHAPS CHANGE THE MITIGATION
FEE ACT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE ANY
CHANGES BE DONE IN THE ACT
ITSELF.
AND NOT A PIECEMEAL BASIS FOR
EIGHTY USE PARTICULARLY.
THE LAST THING I'D LIKE TO SAY
IS THE PROHIBITION ON
REPLACEMENT PARKING RIGHT NOW WE
CANNOT IMPOSE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS ON ANY DO YOU IF
YOU'RE WITH A HALF MILE OF
TRANSIT.
THIS TAKES AN ADDITIONAL STEP IN
SAYS IF YOU CONVERT A GARAGE.
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO PLACE THOSE
PARKING SPOTS SO WE'VE YOU THIS
IS ESSENTIALLY DOUBLING DOWN ON
NO PARKING ON WITHOUT
NECESSARILY HAVE ANY ACCESS TO
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND FOR THAT WE
REMAIN OPPOSED MUST AMENDED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TRYING WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE A WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
TO COULD PLEASE COME MIKE FROM
FIRST LASSEN ORGANIZATION GOOD
MORNING.
MORNING CRINGE ROSSI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION ALSO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR.
IN THE LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
OPPOSE IT COULD PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME WE WELCOME ALL THOSE
WHO OPPOSE LAST CALL.
CURRENCY NUMBER LIKE BETTER
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR IN THE
UNABLE TO BE A VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LACK OF CORM
UNINSURED OVER CENTER BALLOT
ADEQUATE COMING.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SENATOR
LIKE HOUSE KEY IN THE OTHERS
RESPOND TO THE MITIGATION ACT.
AND THE STUDY.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THESE FEES FOR ISSUES. FOR
THREE YEARS NOW [inaudible]
SO -- YOU KNOW I LIKE TO MAKE
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW ME I'M KIND OF
IN PATIENT IN MY JOB HERE I LIKE
TO MAKE DECISIONS AND MOVE ON SO
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THERE'S A STUDY
COMING UP I'M SERVE LIKE
SKEPTICAL.
OKAY.
SO CAN YOU CAN YOU RESPOND.
TO WE I ASKED MY STAFF TO CALL
EACH CD THIS MONTH TO FIND OUT
ABOUT THE STUDY AND HOW IT WAS
GOING IN H. C. D. SURPRISINGLY
SAYS THAT. EIGHTY USE WERE NOT
IN THE SCOPE OF THE SURVEY THE
THE TIM GRAYSON BILL THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT IS JUST
LOOKING AN IMPACT FEES ARE BRAND
NEW CONSTRUCTION AND WHETHER THE
IMPACT FEES THAT THEY THEY SAY
THERE'S A NEXUS BETWEEN THE
RECREATION.
DEVELOPMENT IN THE PARKS AND ALL
THE DIFFERENT FEES AND THEY SAY
THEY'RE NOT EXPECTED TO HAVE.
A RECOMMENDATION AND EIGHTY USE
IN THE THE STUDY THAT'S COMING
OUT IN JUNE SO WE'VE BEEN.
I HEARD THAT LAST YEAR WITH
EIGHT THREE ONE AND HERE IN IT
THIS YEAR AND NOBODY'S CALLED UP
EIGHT CD AND SAID A SECOND BE
INCLUDED SO THEY'RE NOT GETTING
CLUED.
THE IMPACT FEES WE DO KNOW THAT
THE TURNER CENTER IS DOING SOME
WORK FOR EIGHT CD ON THIS
THEY'RE DOING A LARGE LARGE
PORTION OF THE STUDY AND AND
TURNER CENTER HAS INDOORS.
SB THIRTEEN THEY'VE THEY SAY
THAT THEY'RE SIGNIFICANT STUDIES
THAT THEY PUT OUT THAT THE
DEVELOPER IMPACT FEES ARE
EXCESSIVE WITH THE EIGHTY YEAR
NOW THAT AGAIN.
WE'RE NOT GONNA SEE THAT IN THE
IN THE IN THE STUDY.
OKAY OF THE WHY WAIT.
SO SO THE THE THE YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN DEBATING ISSUE FOR AWHILE
YOU KNOW -- HAS THERE BEEN ANY
FURTHER STUDIES ON LIKE LIKE I
THINK I TOLD YOU THE LAST
HEARING WE HAD ON YOUR BILL LAST
TIME.
OF IN SAN JOSE ESSENTIALLY WITH
THE WAY WE VIEW IT IS THERE'S A
LOT OF AID YOU IS ALREADY OUT
THERE.
EXCEPT THEIR SHOCKS GARAGES
CONVERTED.
ALL THE ILLEGAL WIRE RAN ILLEGAL
CONSTRUCTION ON NOT REGULATED --
THE WHOLE CITIES FOR THE SO
CALLED EIGHTY USE IF YOU WANT TO
CALL THAT BUT THEY'RE JUST.
OVERCROWDED HOUSING THAT.
HAS BEEN BUILT AND WITHOUT ANY
PERMITS.
WHICH BECOME FIRE HAZARDS AND SO
FORTH -- HAVE YOU IS ANYBODY --
LOOKED AT THAT ANGLE BECAUSE I
TAKE ONE OF THE PURPOSES OF THE
BILL WOULD BE. TO TO GO THROUGH
A PROCESS OF LEGALIZING SUMMER
pALREADY OUT THERE THAT WE CAN
CONFORM TO THE LAW AND MAYBE.
INSPECTIONS COULD CLEAR UP SOME
OF THE WIRING DEFICIENCIES
THROUGH THROUGH THE CHAIR YES.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT.
THE DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES AND
HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT THE THIRD
PRONG ISN'T THE AMNESTY PROGRAM
AND IT'S A HIT SAID PRICE WITH
PRECISELY THIS WE WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE.
NONE PERMITTED UNITS FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS THE WORKING
NUMBER THE PEOPLE USING
THROUGHOUT THE CITY SO
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO THERE.
IS SOME OF THOSE ARE
UNINHABITABLE AND WE GET THAT
AFTER FIRE DANGER OR THREAT BUT
SOME OF THEM ARE JUST TO NOT
MAKE.
BUILDING CODES BUT THEY WERE
WHEN THEY WERE BUILT THEY WERE
WORSE WORKERS SETS WERE SENDING
UP THIS TEN YEAR PROGRAM WE CAN
WE CAN GO THROUGH AND ALLOW
PEOPLE. TO TO LEGALIZE AND THERE
IS ANOTHER LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD SET WOULD INSTRUCT --
STANDARDS TO BE MADE FOR EIGHTY
USE IN PARTICULAR AND I ARE
SEPARATELY IN PART OF THAT HAS
TO DO WITH CHILD -- TWENTY FOUR
WITH THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY IT'S
IT'S IT BECOMES IMPOSSIBLE TO
BUILD BUT THE THE REAL BAD STUFF
IS GOING TO BE LET THE CITIES IN
THE HOMEOWNERS WORK WITH IT. TO
TO GET HIM UP -- TO
MARKETABILITY.
WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL
--
WE USE -- COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
BLOCK GRANT FEDERAL MONEY. TO TO
DO SOME CODE ENFORCEMENT
BUILDING REAL BILL.
OF ACTIVITIES LIKE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND PROPOSITION ONE THAT JUST
PASSED BY THE VOTERS -- ALLOWS
THAT KIND OF FUNDING.
OF FOR CITIES TO COME IN AND AND
USE -- PROP ONE PROCEEDS FOR
REHABILITATION.
CODE COMPLIANCE.
THE MORE CO COMPLIANCE WE CAN
GET TO SAY FOR COMMUNITIES HAVE
OUT WILL BE CALM I THINK THAT'S
SO IN TERMS OF LIKE EIGHTY USE
IF THERE.
IS A SENSE THAT THERE IS -- IN
IN CITIES LIKE SAN JOSE I KNOW
IT'S TRUE I ASSUME IT MIGHT BE
TRUE IN OTHER CITIES -- A LOT OF
THESE ILLEGAL STRUCTURES THAT WE
WANT TO BRING IN.
AND TURN INTO LEGAL STRUCTURES.
OF MAYBE THE CITIES AND THE
PLANNERS CAN COMMENT ON THAT
BECAUSE I THINK EIGHTY YOU LAW.
WOULD FACILITATE.
CO COMPLIANCE AND BUILDING
APPLICATIONS TO REHAB SOME AND
AND AND FIX UP SOME OF THESE.
STRUCTURES THAT ARE ALREADY OUT
THERE AND THAT'S A GOOD THING.
SO CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE SURE ABSOLUTELY
DECENTLY CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
WE'RE ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT OF
PROGRAMS LIKE YOU MENTIONED
WHERE THERE YOU KNOW AND AND
PROP ONE WE'RE GONNA SEE DOLLARS
--
TO HELP A FOLKS COME AT YOU KNOW
OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND ACTUALLY
GET THEIR THEIR UNITS PERMITTED
--
THAT'S SOMETHING WE WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING WE'VE SUPPORTED ON
BILLS IN THE PAST THAT HAVE THAT
HAVE DONE THAT -- SO YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYTHING MORE WE CAN DO
ON THAT WE CERTAINLY WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF FIGURING OUT HOW
TO GET THESE -- YOU KNOW THESE
UNITS UPDATED AND CODE COMPLIANT
AND YOU KNOW BUT WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THAT EFFORT ON THE
BUTTONS OF PLANNERS HAVE
SLIGHTLY FOR THE A. B. AS WELL
IT WAS MORE THAN A PERSONAL.
IF YOU IF YOU SUPPORT THAT MAYBE
MAYBE THE IDEA OF FOR A LOT OF
US STATE YOU DO WE LOOK AT IT AS
AN ARGUMENT [inaudible]
FOR THE BILL.
YOU KNOW OF GOING TO THE CITIES
COMING FROM A FORMER.
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS AND SALAS A YOU SHOULD BE.
FOR SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
HELP COPE COMPLIANCE.
AND REDUCING THE ILLEGAL WIRING
ESPECIALLY THE FIRE HAZARDS YOU
KNOW.
VERY DANGEROUS SITUATION OUT
THERE AND WHEN THE FEES ARE SO
HIGH PEOPLE JUST GO AHEAD AND DO
THESE ILLEGAL -- THAT'S THAT'S A
COMMON WAY THAT PEOPLE DO
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES IS THEY FEEL
THAT.
WHY BOTHER GOING TO GET IT?
YEAH THEY DON'T WANT TO PAY THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR
A LITTLE.
ADDITION THEY WANT TO HAVE SO.
SOME MEMBER OF THE FAMILY
DOESN'T HAVE TO DRIVE SEVENTY
MILES TO GET TO THEIR JOBS SO
THEY THE BILL THE LITTLE.
THING IN THE BACKYARD OR YOU
KNOW IT IT IT TURNS OUT IS
ILLEGAL AND LATER ON SOME
HAPPENS THERE'S A FIRE AND
SOMEBODY.
SO.
I I'M JUST ARGUING -- IN A SENSE
SAID THE BILL IS ACTUALLY MORE
OF A COLD COMPLIANCE.
KIND OF THING FOR FOR ME AND
THEREFORE.
HAS A PUBLIC GOODS AND IF IT HAS
A PUBLIC GOOD MAYBE THE THE
SHOULD BE -- AT SOME POINT LOWER
THAN.
IN A JUST A NORMAL CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS.
THANKS IN ABOUT MAKE SOME GOOD
POINTS REGARD TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
HOW MANY UNITS HAVE BEEN
ILLEGALLY CONVERTED AND HOW THAT
PUTS THE PUBLIC SAFETY -- AT
RISK.
IN HAVING THAT AND THIS YOU'D
BETTER BRING THEM IN.
AND BEING ABLE TO BUILD LEGALLY
THERE ARE REGULATED MARKET IN
THE FUTURE.
SENATE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VERY GRATEFUL IN.
REALLY GOOD POINTS.
I'M LIKELY TO SEE IF CENTER
NIELSEN HAVE ANY ITEMS ON THIS
ITEM THE ONLY ITEM I WILL SAY IS
THAT -- WHEN I APPRECIATE?
THE GOOD SENATOR FOR FREE MINDS
WORK ON THIS ISSUE HE'S BEEN A
CHAMPION ON THIS -- AND HAS BEEN
LEADING THE SENATE ON ALL ISSUES
OF EXCESS OR DWELLING UNITS IN
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT'LL
BRING.
WE HAD A AN ABILITY TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT FEES IN THIS
COMMITTEE INTENTIONALLY IS NOT.
COMMENTING ON FEES WITHIN THE
ANALYSIS BECAUSE IT ALLOWS A
SENATOR WHO KNOWS WHO'S GONNA
HAVE TO BE ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ISSUE FEES HERE.
IN THE MONTHS TO COME IN ONE OF
THE ORDER LEAVE HIM ROOM TO BE A
TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT ALL SIDES
ARE EVENTUALLY NEEDED TO COME
TOGETHER.
I JUST WANNA SAY HOW GRATEFUL I
AM TO SEE MY CASKET FOR HIS WORK
ON THIS WAS A THINKING THE
OPPOSITION FOR BEING HERE AND
FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
IN A CAST WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE THE
LOOK.
AT ESTABLISH A QUORUM I WOULD
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
VERY GRATEFUL THANK YOU CENTER
THIS IS SERRA THANKS FOR BEING
HERE AS WELL VERY GRATEFUL.
MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IS SB ONE SIXTY TWO
THIS IS A TEAM EFFORT BETWEEN
CENTER GALGIANI IN OUR STATE
TREASURER GRATEFUL FOR BOTH OF
THEM.
OUT FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD WORK.
THIS IS IN REGARDS TO THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATE ENERGY IN
ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
AUTHORITY AS WELL AS THEIR I SEE
THE TAX CREDITS ARE BEING
ADVANCE TODAY.
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME CENTER
GALGIANI CENTER GALGIANI HAVE
UNLIMITED TIME.
OF THE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
WHAT TWO MINUTES EACH.
THANK GALGIANI THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME ALSO ALONG WITH
THE SENATOR OR TO THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO MEET WITH US IN THE
COMMITTEE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SB ONE SIXTY TWO EXTENDS
TO SUNSET FOR THE SALES AND TAX
EXCLUSION.
PORTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY ADVANCED
TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
AUTHORITY. TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY THIRTY HOUSED UNDER THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE ENERGY IN
ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
AUTHORITY.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAVE.
PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO LEVERAGE
PRIVATE CAPITAL AND THE GREEN
ECONOMY.
THIS PROGRAM HELPS TO
COMMERCIALIZE ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING RECYCLING GREEN
TECHNOLOGIES EVERY NOBLE BIO
ENERGY REDUCE AIR POLLUTION AND
PROMOTE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
JOBS.
WITH NO CHANGES TO THE LAW THE
SALES AND TAX EXCLUSION PORTION
OF CAVE THAT WILL SUNSET ON
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SB ONE SIXTY
TWO EXTENSIVE SUNSET AND TELL
TWENTY THIRTY SO THAT THESE
STRATEGIC TAX INCENTIVES CAN
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE ECONOMIC
GROWTH IN ADDITION TO
SUPPORTING.
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
OF EXPANDING THE GREEN ECONOMY
AND REDUCING WASTE WITH ME TODAY
RKC O'CONNOR AND DEANNA CARRILLO
FROM THE TREASURER'S OFFICE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE BETTER
CENTER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK WILL TURN IT OVER TO
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
FOR SURE YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
THANKS FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND CENTERS ON THE
COMMITTEE I'M CASEY O'CONNOR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR STATE
TREASURER FIONA MA.
THE TREASURE IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
US BE ONE SIXTY TWO AND THANKS
THE AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS EFFORT.
THE SALES TAXES COLLUSION
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED UNDER
KATE FOR IN OUR OFFICE IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN CREATING A NEXUS
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
ECONOMIC INCENTIVES.
AND I'VE WATER POLICY GOALS TO
GROW THE GREEN ECONOMY AS A
DEEPER INCENTIVE TO ENCOURAGE
OUR ATTENTION AND TRACTION OF
GREEN MANUFACTURING.
SINCE THEN THE PROGRAM IS BUT
IT'S EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING AND
RECYCLING TO INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
CRUCIAL TO OUR REGIONAL ECONOMIC
SUCCESS.
THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THAT THE TAX BENEFITS
PROVIDED TO COMPANIES THAT WILL
PRODUCE A NET BENEFIT TO THE
STATE.
THAT ANTICIPATED FISCAL COST
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OUTWEIGH
THE COSTS IN OUR OPINION WHICH
WE DO THROUGH CONSERVATIVE
APPROACH BASED ON RESEARCH BY
THE FEDERAL RESERVE BANK.
AND OUR EXACT ADDRESS TO THE
PROGRAM CAN TOUCH MORE ON THAT
WHEN SHE ANSWERS ANY QUESTIONS.
AND JUST AT THE END OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN KATE Và HAD APPROVED A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED ONE PROJECT
APPLICATIONS HELPING PURCHASE
OVER EIGHT POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN EQUIPMENT AND
MACHINERY. NINETY SIX OF THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE NINETY SIX OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS ARE ACTIVE SIXTY
THREE ARE COMPLETE AND FORTY TWO
ARE NOT MOVING FORWARD.
THESE PROJECTS ARE LOCATED
ACROSS THIRTY THREE COUNTIES ARE
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN THE
RETENTION CREATION.
OF 450-003-0070 THREE JOBS WITH
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO JOBS ATTRIBUTABLE TO OUR
PROGRAM DIRECTLY -- WE JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL AND ALL RIGHT WITH
ME TODAY'S DINO CARILLO THESE
ACTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PROGRAM.
AND SHE CAN LET TYLER BUT WHAT'S
IN YOUR FOLDERS AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CREO YOU HAVE A TO TWO MINUTES
THIS WILL BE OUR FINAL SECONDARY
WITNESS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO MOVE THE MICROPHONE OVER AND
THEN -- THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD MORNING THANKS FOR YOUR
WORK COMMITTEE MEMBERS I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THE IN YOUR
POCKET TODAY WE'VE PUT A LIST OF
THE TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED WITH IN YOUR DISTRICT
JUST TO MAKE IT A LITTLE MORE --
TANGIBLE OF WHAT THIS PROGRAM
DOES AS WELL AS A LIST OF THE
PROJECTS AND THOSE OF ALL THE
PROJECT WOULD HELP -- OVERTIME
AND I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS GRIOT -- MA'AM CENTER
WERE VERY DISAPPOINTED COCOA IS
NOT HERE TODAY THANK YOU -- IN
AND YOU NEED TO BE BRING HER TO
COMMITTEE AS WELL SO -- ALL
RIGHT.
MY DAY ALL RIGHT WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO OPEN IT UP TO
ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS FIRST
AND LAST NAME AS WELL AS
ORGANIZATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SIR YOUR MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING ALL OF IRAQ RIGHT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT THE BIOTECH COMMUNITY.
MANY OF THE MEDICINES ARE
MANUFACTURED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL QUALIFY FOR THIS
CREDIT SO WHICH BEING STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD TO SEE YOU GOOD
MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN
HIGGINS REPRESENTING VIA
COMMENTS OR ONE THOUSAND LIFE
SCIENCES MEMBER COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT GOING THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD MORNING.
I GOOD MORNING ERIN OVER ON
BEHALF OF BURYING ALL HIGH AND
WE WERE ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
RECIPIENTS OF THE PROGRAM AND WE
WERE ABLE.
TO DO EXPANSION ON OUR FREMONT
MANUFACTURING FACILITY AND
INCREASE OUR HEAD COUNT BY BY
DOUBLE.
THE WERE VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANKS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS GOOD MORNING MISTER
SHARON NUMBERS WERE IN JENSEN LE
TECHNION SPORT THE COMMISSION
SAID GOOD MORNING.
DRAW COULD FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANKS SO
MUCH MISS COOK GOOD MORNING.
DAN CHAU TUSSLE WERE VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE PROGRAM --
ALLOWED US TO PURCHASE THE NEW
ME FACTORY IN -- TWENTY TEN WHEN
--
GM AND AND TELL YOU TO ABANDON
IT -- PROUD -- TO HAVE HIRED
MANY OF THOSE WORKERS BACKGROUND
THE COMPANY TO THAT THE STATE'S
LARGEST MANUFACTURING EMPLOYER
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT LAST CALL.
WE NOW LIKELY TO WELCOME ANYONE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO PRIMARY WITNESSES WHO
ARE OPPOSED.
WITH THIS CARE CAN CATHOLIC
CITIES MAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND
IS HERE TODAY.
I HE'S GONNA HAVE FIVE MINUTES
AND WE WILL WELCOME A SECONDARY
WITNESS AT TWO MINUTES IF YOU
CARED FOR AS YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES SIR GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID
TANK YOU'RE GONNA BE HELPFUL TO
GET CALIFORNIA CITIES WITH
CONCERNS AT THIS POINT -- OUR
POLICY COMMITTEE DID LOOK AT
THIS BILL AND HAS A OPPOSE
RECOMMENDATION.
BUT IT HAS NOT YET BEEN
FINALIZED WERE ABOARD.
WE APPRECIATE MEETING WITH NOT
ONLY THE AUTHOR STUFF BUT ALSO
--
REPRESENTS FROM THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE -- THE WE WE ARE HERE TO
TO TALK ABOUT THE MERITS OF THE
PROGRAM -- THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THEIR SAID THAT IN ALICE'S SO
TOUCHES ON NOT -- WE'RE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THE FINANCIAL IMPACT
OF THE PROGRAM ESPECIALLY ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- ON THE FIRST
PAGE OF THE ANALYSIS IT KIND OF
BREAKS DOWN HOW THE SALES TAXES
IS DIVVIED UP IN THE STATE.
AND IF YOU LOOK EVERYTHING BELOW
THE FIRST LINE IS IS OF FUNDS
THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED EITHER
THERE THE BRADLEY BURNS AGO TO
CITIES -- OR WHICH ALSO NOT
MISSING WHAT'S MISSING ON THIS
LIST IS THE TRANSACTION USE
TAXES APPROVED BY LOCAL VOTERS
AT ALSO -- OR COLLECTED LOCALLY
BUT THE STATE HAS -- ALLOCATED A
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO
COUNTIES FOR REALIGNMENT FROM
THE SALES TAX -- INSULT AS WELL
AS LOCALS THIS IS A CUTE REVENUE
SOURCE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S ARE
HAS A READ A REPORT IN DECEMBER.
THAT POINTED OUT THE OUT OF
BECAUSE THE STATE HAS.
CONTINUE THE MANUFACTURERS OF
THE PARTIAL MANUFACTURERS
EXEMPTION MANY OF THESE SAME
COMPANIES COULD CAN NOW ALL OF
THAT THAT.
THAT EXEMPTION WASN'T HERE AT
THE TIME THE THIS PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED MANY OF THESE
MANUFACTURERS THAT BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROGRAM COULD.
COULD SORT OF SIMPLY BENEFIT
FROM THE STATE'S PROGRAM.
AND SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS IF
THIS PROGRAM IS IS EXTENDED AND
IT'S A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR -- FOR FOR TEN YEARS.
SO ABOUT POTENTIALLY AT AT FULL
BUILD OUT FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF IMPACT IS
REALLY GONNA BE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
ARE IN AND SO ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES OF TRYING TO ANALYZE
THIS PROGRAM IN TERMS OF A
AFFECTS ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
THERE'S NOT A REAL NEXUS IN THIS
--
IN THIS -- INCENTIVE BETWEEN THE
BENEFITING COMMUNITY AND THOSE
THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING BYE BYE --
FORFEITING THEIR THEIR SALES
TAXES IN OTHER WORDS IF YOU'RE
THE CITY OF FREMONT -- AND YOU
FELT OF TESTS Là AND THEY
RECEIVE LOTS OF BENEFITS ARE
CERTAINLY A LOT OF JOBS AND
OTHER THINGS -- IN IN THAT
COMMUNITY THAT YOU COULD SAY ARE
CERTAINLY OFFSETTING WHATEVER
WHATEVER FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTION
BUT THE WAY THE PROGRAM IS SET
UP THERE THERE ISN'T REALLY A
NEXUS BETWEEN THE THE COMMUNITY
THAT'S GETTING THAT ADDITIONAL
MANUFACTURING THE JOBS.
AND THOSE WHERE THE EQUIPMENT IS
COMING FROM -- IN SO WE'D LIKE
TO CONTINUE TO TRY TO WORK ON
THIS BILL TO SEE IF WITH THERE'S
A WAY TO TO TIGHTEN UP THE NEXUS
BETWEEN -- THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THAT THAT ARE BENEFITING FROM
THIS -- IS A AND AND AND AND THE
PROGRAM -- FOR THAT YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S OVER HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS OF IMPACT ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK THAT WE SHOULD A
SLOW DOWN AND TAKE A LOOK AT
WHEN THIS PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY
WENT THROUGH WENT THROUGH.
IT WAS - VERY WENT WENT VERY
QUICKLY THERE WASN'T MUCH IN THE
WAY OF HEARINGS AND AND THE THE
IMPACTS OF OF THIS ON LOCAL BUT
WE'RE NEVER REALLY ANALYZED SO
--
THIS TIME AROUND I THINK IT
WOULD GIVEN THE THE THAT THE LA
OWES -- ANALYSIS INDICATES THAT
THE IT'S REALLY GOING TO BE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT'S GOING TO
SHOULDER THE THE THE FINANCIAL
WAY TO THIS PROGRAM -- IT'S
WORTH A TAKEN OUT TAKE A LOOK AT
SO WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE SPONSORS AND THE
AUTHOR.
ON THESE ISSUES AS THE BILL
MOVES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE OKAY IF YOU WANNA HANG
THERE WITH US IN CASE WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE THAT WILL GIVE THE
SENATOR IN THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE TIME TO RESPOND.
LIKELY TO SEE IF WE HAVE A
SECONDARY WITNESS ON THIS ISSUE
THERE'S A SECONDARY WITNESS AN
INDIVIDUAL OF TWO MINUTES -- AS
FAR AS THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION.
WELCOME AID -- ARE YOU HERE FOR
OPPOSITION MA'AM NO ALL RIGHT TO
SWITCHING OUT ALRIGHT HERE WE GO
--
NOW WE'D LIKE TO GET TO GO TO
ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
ASKING ANYONE ELSE PLEASE STAND
FIRST AND LAST NAME IN
ORGANIZATION.
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
THIS IS GONNA BE LAST CALL WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WITH THAT WOULD OPEN
IT UP FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR BELL.
IF YOU TAKE THE TOTAL -- SALES
TAX WHAT'S THE COST IS ANYBODY
FIGURE THAT OUT.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY.
IS A QUESTION -- HOW MUCH SALES
TAX HAS BEEN EXCLUDED OVER TIME
YEAH WHAT WEALTHY PASSES FOR THE
AND THAT'S A LOOK IF WE PASS
THIS BILL WHAT WOULD BE THOUGH?
AND THAT THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT THAT
THE PROGRAM IS A LIMITED TO IS A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES
TAX EXCLUSION TO AWARD EACH
YEAR.
OF THAT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IT PROBABLY GETS -- USE SO IT'S
NOT FUNDS THAT WE'RE GIVING AWAY
IT'S JUST FUNDS WERE NOT
COLLECTING.
SO IT'S THAT SPENDS IT ON A
QUICK MATT THAT'S PURCHASED OVER
THREE TO FIVE YEARS -- AND NOT
ALTHOUGH NOT ALL OF THOSE
COMPANIES WILL USE ALL OF THEIR
WORDS AND BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM
IS THERE TO AND CENTS NASCENT
TECHNOLOGIES AND NEW COMPANIES.
SOME AWARDS DON'T END UP BEING
USE SO THERE IS A LIMIT OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND AND
SALES AND USE TAXES LOSING EACH
YEAR I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT
SENT TO THE ST IMPACT YOUR THAT
IS A COMBINED STATE AND LOCAL.
THE AVERAGE IS ABOUT EIGHT POINT
42% -- ON AVERAGE STATEWIDE OF
STATE AND LOCAL BECAUSE
DIFFERENT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE DIFFERENT TAX RATES OKAY
IMAGES AND IF IT'S OKAY IF WE
CAN HAVE MISTER CURSING FROM LA
AS OFFICE PLEASE COME FOR
EXITING THERE'S ALSO BEEN SOME
INDEPENDENT HOUSES ON THAT AS
WELL IF THAT'S OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
IT'S CRISTINA I KNOW I'M GIVING
US -- YOUR LAST NAME HE DOES
INTERVIEWS YOURSELF IN YOUR OLD
L. A. L. A. AND ADDRESSING
REBELS A COMMON QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS A SET CHRISTINE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SO -- SO AS AS A KID FOR
REPRESENTATIVE NOTED THERE IS A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL.
CAP ON THE AMOUNT THAT CAN BE.
THE AMOUNT OF EXCLUSIONS THAT
CAN BE AWARDED IN ANY GIVENYEAR
--
AS WE DESCRIBE IN OUR ANALYSIS
IN OUR IN IN A REPORT FROM
DECEMBER -- US QUITE A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THAT
LIKELY WOULD BE -- CLAIMED
ANYWAY THROUGH DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS TO REALLY THE NET --
REVENUE A FAX FROM A STATE
GENERAL FUND STANDPOINT LIKELY
IS.
IS FAIRLY SMALL AND AND REALLY
IT'S IT'S IT'S MOSTLY WE WE
WOULD MOSTLY HIGHLIGHT A SORT OF
ON THE REVENUE FOREGONE REVENUE
SIDE -- THE FOR GONE LOCAL SALES
TAX REVENUES THAT THAT -- THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES REPRESENTATIVE
REFERENCE THAT WOULD BE SORT OF
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD IN TOTAL OF
UP.
TO ABOUT FIFTY FIVE MILLION A
YEAR THAT ASSUMES.
THAT WOULD ASSUME FOR FULL
UTILIZATION WHICH IS PROBABLY.
UNREALISTIC SO PROBABLY IT WOULD
BE SOMEWHAT LESS THAN THAT
PERHAPS SOMEWHERE IN THE IN THE
MADE TENS OF OF MILLIONS PER
YEAR.
WHAT'S YOUR NUMBER FOR THE STATE
GENERAL FUND.
ON IT'S SO WE DIDN'T HAVE DATA
THAT WERE ABLE TO QUANTIFY THE
X. FULL EXTENT OF THE OERLAP
BETWEEN THE PARTIAL EXEMPTION IN
THE IN THE CASE FOR EXCLUSION --
BASED ON THE INFORMATION WE
GATHERED WE THINK IT'S QUITE
LARGE SO YOU COULD REASONABLY
ASSUME THE GENERAL FUND IMPACT
IS IN THE MILLIONS TO MAYBE.
IT JUST JUST PROBABLY MAYBE
SEVERAL MILLION TO PERHAPS TEN
MILLION A YEAR.
IF I CAN CLARIFY ONE THING IN
OUR AFTER THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS TO CLARIFY -- BUT WE HAVE
WORKED WITH BOTH DâN AND SAT IN
THEIR ANALYSIS AND AND CONCERNS
OVER THE PROGRAM -- I WOULD
THINK IN IN LIGHT OF THE LA OWES
REPORT -- THE SIMPLIFICATION
THAT THE TWO PROGRAMS ARE
SIMILAR -- I WOULD SAY IS AN
OVERSIMPLIFICATION I'M SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN IN THE STATE WIDE
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED HE WAS
ACTUALLY HAVE FULLY AWARDED.
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS EACH
CALENDAR YEAR THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE EXPECTED WE
EXPECTED THAT WHEN THERE WAS A
PURE ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
PROVIDED AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
NOT ONE THAT REQUIRED A NET
BENEFIT NOT.
AS I'VE BEEN TOLD A RIGOROUS
EVALUATION THAT REQUIRES FEES IN
PROACTIVE NESS -- THAT WE WOULD
STILL BE ACTIVE AND THERE'S TO
BE A DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM WHAT
WE ARE FINDING IS THAT THE
VOLATILITY IN THE INDUSTRY AND
SOME OF THOSE NASCENT
TECHNOLOGIES.
AS THEY COME IN THAT DEEPER AND
SIGN UP FOR BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL -- DOES HAVE A BIG
IMPACT I THINK WHAT WE ARE ALSO
FINDING IS IN THE WAY THAT THE
CAPE A CONSERVATIVELY ESTIMATES
THE POSITIVE FISCAL BENEFIT OF
THESE PROJECT.
THERE ARE IS A CARRY OVER TO
BOTH NOT ONLY THOSE THE LOCATION
WHERE THE PROJECTS ARE LOCATED
BUT WERE COMPANIES ARE ALSO
BUYING SUPPLIES IN THEIR
FEEDSTOCK FROM IN STATE.
AND SO WE ARE ABLE TO SHOW HOW
WE'RE SUPPORTING THOSE INDUSTRY
CLUSTERS IN THE REGIONAL
ECONOMIES WITH AN OVERALL --
PUBLIC BENEFIT WILL THAT WASN'T
MY QUESTION.
YOU KNOW I WHAT I WANT TO KNOW
IS.
IS THERE A WAY A THE WE CONTRACT
MORE CLOSELY [inaudible]
N..
IN A PROCESS TO GET THE ANSWER
THE QUESTION.
OF WHAT THE GENERAL FUND FISCAL
IMPACT IS.
IS THERE A WAY TO DO THAT.
THAT'S THAT'S THE QUESTION I
WANT TO KNOW I LIKE TO HAVE I
DON'T LIKE.
FUZZINESS IN THE NUMBERS I JUST.
THAT THAT KIND OF DISTURBS ME IN
OTHER YOU KIND HER YOU KNOW
NOBODY CAN TELL ME.
SO IT'S KIND OF A FAIR QUESTION
I MEAN YOU KNOW I'M I'M -- I'M
BUDGETING FOR THE BUDGET AND
DIFFERENT THINGS AND YOU KNOW I
WANT TO FUND EDUCATION I WANT TO
FUND OTHER THINGS.
AND YOU KNOW I WHEN A BILL COMES
UP I KIND OF WANT TO KNOW.
HOW MUCH IS IT COSTING THE
GENERAL FUND HOW MUCH IS ACROSS
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I MEAN?
THAT'S A THAT'S A LEGITIMATE
QUESTION SO WE KIND OF IS THERE
A WAY OF CAN WE DO A BETTER JOB
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT.
STATE JUST REAL QUICK I'M SORRY
IT'S SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO BE TO
DO IS THAT -- GETTING TO WHERE
SENATOR ABOUT WOULD LIKE TO BE
AGO I LIKE TO BE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMENT DIRECTLY TO THE IMPACT
OF THE GENERAL FUND.
AND I COULD ADDRESS IT IN TWO
WAYS IF THERE IS NOT ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE HIM AN EXACT
NUMBER TODAY THANK US TO BE ABLE
TO SAY THAT NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER TWO IF THERE IS AN
ABILITY HERE IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS TO BE A TO GIVE THEM A
GREATER -- MORE PRECISE NUMBER
AND LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADD HERE
THAT AND THEN WE'RE GONNA BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH REST THE
COMMITTEE.
SO START WITH HIS CREEL THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE BETTER DRESS
THAT A QUESTION DIRECTLY AND
THEN IF YOU'RE UNABLE TO BE AN
ADDRESS IT DIRECTLY HERE DID
TODAY -- HERE IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS WE HAD TO GET THE
INFORMATION TO COMMITTEE AND
I'LL TURN OVER MISCREANT INTO
THE LA.
OKAY I HAVE TWO ANSWERS AND I'M
NOT TRYING TO BE FUZZY WHAT I
HEARD AND LA -- SAY IS THAT
THERE'S NO IMPACT TO THE GENERAL
FUND BECAUSE OF THE EXISTING
STATEWIDE ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
THAT'S OPERATED OR CD TFA SO
THIS PROGRAM WHAT I HEARD LA --
SAY WAS THAT THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL EMPIRE IN FACT I MAY
HAVE MISSED HEARD.
I GUESS MY BICYCLE CALL AND WHAT
ON YOUR ON YOUR TABLE WHAT IS
THIS THE STATE SALES TAX. NINE
EIGHT SEVEN OR A SEVEN AND A
QUARTER IS THE STATE RATE THAT
AND BUILD LOCAL AVERAGE RATE IS
IN THERE CAPE ESTIMATES I
BELIEVE. 9%.
OKAY LA OUT -- ASKED THANK YOU
SAID CHRISTINE LA -- THAT SAID
--
SENATOR BELL SIR ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THE THAT THE ANSWER
IS FUZZY IS SO THIS IS CERTAINLY
A QUESTION THAT WAS OF GREAT
INTEREST TO US AS WELL.
DISCUSSED IT WITH VARIOUS
ENTITIES WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT SERVES TO
HAS TO DO WITH THE WAY.
THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ADMINISTERED THAT THERE'S NOT --
DATA THAT COULD JUST SORT OF
READILY IDENTIFY IT SORT OF A
VERY FINE LEVEL OF PRECISION --
THEY COULD AT LEAST THAT WAS
AVAILABLE TO US THAT COULD.
SEE SORT OF ENABLE SORT OF A
SIDE BY SIDE COMPARISON OF
EXACTLY WHAT PURCHASES WERE
BEING USED -- IN EACH PROGRAM
THAT WOULD ENABLE THAT TYPE OF
ESTIMATES I THINK I'M NOT SURE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
MAKE MORE PRECISE N A QUICK
TIMETABLE I THINK.
FRANKLY IT MIGHT REQUIRE SOME
CHANGES TO SERVE TAX
ADMINISTRATION PRACTICES PERHAPS
EVEN A CHANGES IN STATURE TO
THAT EFFECT TO REALLY GET A VERY
PRECISE ESTIMATE.
WITH WITH S. SAID ABOUT WHAT I'D
LIKE TO BE A TO DO IS A
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO GET HIM OUR BEST
ESTIMATE.
IF IT'S NOT HERE TODAY.
BY LATE THIS WEEK AT FIRST THING
NEXT BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT QUESTION AT THE CENTER
IS ASKING AND WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO GET THAT -- THROUGH GOT IN
FIVE STAFF YES PLEASE -- MY AND
COOK WITH VARYING YOU'RE
INCLINED PHARMACEUTICALS WE WERE
AND AWARD.
JUST TO CLARIFY SOME OF THIS I
THINK THERE.
YOUR UNDER THIS PRESUMPTION
YOU'RE SAYING THAT EVERYTHING WE
PURCHASED IS GOING TO BE LOCAL
AND THAT'S NOT THE CASE -- WERE
A BIO PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANY IN
FREMONT BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
MANUFACTURING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT.
GENERALLY PURCHASE THINGS EVEN
WITHIN THE STATE WITH IN ANOTHER
STATE OR GOES TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
SO THE SALES TAX WAS ISN'T GOING
TO TAKE PLACE HERE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT EQUIPPED WITH MAKING
WHAT WE NEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
KERRIGAN ELECTED TO TURN IT BACK
TO THE GOOD CENTER FRANCE HAS A
MISCARRIAGE.
STRUCTURE ALL ON THAT POINT.
SHE IS SO THEY EVEN THOUGH THE
IF IF THE IF THEY BALK OF THE
PURCHASES ARE EITHER OUT OF
STATE OR OUT OF THE COUNTRY THEN
CLEARLY TO THE EXTENT THAT HERE
IS A LOCAL REVENUE LOSS THAT YOU
THAT'S NOT IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
IS BENEFITING.
IT THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT WHAT
WHAT IS THE BENEFIT TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT ARE
CONTRIBUTING -- BUT THE SO SO
THIS IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED OUT ON MY
CLEARLY IF THERE WERE SOME
BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIA JOBS OR
SOMETHING -- YOU KNOW MAYBE
THERE'S A BROADER ARGUMENT TO
MAKE BUT THAT'S ANOTHER LEVEL OF
OUR CONCERN IS IF A LOT OF THIS
EQUIPMENTS COMING FROM
ELSEWHERE.
AND WE ARE POTENTIALLY AGAIN I I
KNOW THAT THIS PROGRAM COULD BE
UP BUT IF THE AUTHORITY IS TO UP
TO A BILLION THE END AND OUR
CONTRIBUTION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
IS.
A HALF A BILLION IT'S JUST
WORTH.
MAKING SURE WE KNOW WHAT THE THE
BENEFITS ARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GONNA TURN
OVER TO CENTER BELL TO SEE IF HE
HAS ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I DO SEE MISS CARILLO.
WOULD LIKELY RESPOND BUT I'D
LIKE TO TURN OVER TO CENTER
ABOUT FIRST OR TO GO.
I GOT MY ANSWER THERE'S NO WAY
OF FIGURING OUT AND WHAT WE DO
JUST DOES A PRACTICE.
IF WE DO BILLS LIKE THIS WE
SHOULD KNOW WHAT THE NUMBERS
ARE.
AND I WOULD PREFER TO HAVE.
SOME WAY THE TAX CODE OR THE TAX
REGULATIONS.
TO CLARIFY FOR US WITHIN A
REASONABLE ESTIMATE.
WHAT EXACTLY THE IMPACT ON THE
THE STATE GENERAL FUND IN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT?
THIS SPECIAL FUNDS.
OF TRANSPORTATION PARTICULARLY
IN MY CASE -- WHAT DOES IMPACTS
ARE AND I THINK THAT'S A FAIR
QUESTION THE US OF?
GENERAL'S GENERALLY ALL THESE --
KINDS OF EXCLUSIONS CREDITS I
MEAN IT'S A FAIR QUESTION I MEAN
--
SO I TAKE -- MISTER CHAIRMAN.
PERHAPS THE COMMITTEE COULD.
ASSET QUESTION WHEN.
UP WHEN LEGISLATION COMES BEFORE
US.
ACTUALLY NO THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY
IT IS MORE THAN FAIR I TO BE
ABLE TO ASK A QUESTION.
I CENTER BELT THAT WORKS FOR YOU
SIR WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL
FOLLOW UP WITH BOTH.
OF THE SENATORS OFFICES WAS THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE TO TRY
TO BE TO GET YOU AN ESTIMATE.
IN AS WE GO -- FORWARD -- TEAM
WILL BE ASKING -- THAT ESTIMATE
POTENTIALLY OF THIS STATE
GENERAL FUND AND I DO THINK IT
IS FAIR WE'RE GONNA -- TURNED
OVER TO MISS CARILLO TO BE ABLE
--
TO ANSWER QUICKLY THEN WE'D LIKE
TO IN TURN OVER CENTER GALGIANI
FOR ANY CLOSING COMMENTS IN A
POTENTIAL CLOSE RIGHT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE SOMETIME TO
ADD SOME CLARIFICATION SO  JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES US TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A NET BENEFIT TO THE
STATE.
AND SO WE GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF ASKING -- WHAT JOBS ARE BEING
RETAINED WHAT NEW JOBS ARE BEING
CREATED TO ASSESS THAT THERE
ACTUALLY IS A NET BENEFIT TO THE
STATE SO THE FISCAL BENEFITS ARE
DERIVED FROM THE PROJECTED SALES
TAXES OF THE WIDGETS?
PERSONAL INCOME TAX CORPORATE
TAXES ON THE PROFITS PROPERTY
TAXES FROM IMPROVEMENTS AND
OTHER INDIRECT FISCAL BENEFITS
--
WE'RE HAVING A BIG IMPACT ON
MITIGATING FOSSIL FUELS WITHIN
THOSE PROJECT LOCATIONS AND
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS ARE
QUANTIFIED.
I'M AT THE DOLLAR VALUE OF THOSE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS.
THAT WELL I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION OF OF THE LOS N
IMPACT -- WE TOOK THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY UPON PROGRAM DESIGN
AND HAVE A CONSERVATIVE APPROACH
TO ASSESS THAT.
CENTER GALGIANI WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE PLEASE.
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AND I
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL TIME
TO RESPOND AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR -- AS WELL AS STATE
TREASURES TEAM UP FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
ON THIS THANK YOU TO THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL MISTER LA
OKAY -- IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE EXACT LA L. BUT I SAID GREAT
JOB AS ALWAYS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
AT YOUR GUIDANCE.
BUT WE ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
GALGIANI WILL BE FOLLOWING UP.
WE'LL BE TAKING A VOTE -- AS
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHO HAS TWO BILLS AND
FROM THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A TWO MINUTE RECESS THERE'S
A QUICK.
ITEM THAT LIKE TO BE A TO
DISCUSS ANOTHER BILL -- THAT WE
HAVE A TIME CERTAIN WAS CENTER
PORTANTINO -- IF YOU CAN GIVE US
A TWO MINUTE RECESS WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
[inaudible]
ONE INTERESTING.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ON IT
[inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
HEALTH AND 1000%
[inaudible]
HIGHER [inaudible]
RIGHT
[inaudible]
THOSE [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALRIGHT WE'RE BACK.
LADIES THE GERMAN I APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THE DELAY WERE WORKING OUT
SOME HOUSEKEEPING.
AS I SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE HEARING CENTER JACKSON IS
UNABLE TO BE WITH HIS HERE
TODAY.
HER WITNESSES TURN INTO PUMPKINS
AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK.
IN WE HAVE -- WE HAVE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE HER BILL.
SHE WAS ORIGINALLY SUPPOSED TO
LEAD US OFF TODAY.
SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE A TO DO
AND I WANT TO SEND A PUBLIC
APOLOGY TO A CENTER PORTANTINO
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
THE PRESENTATION OF SB.
ONE EIGHT TWO SB.
ONE EIGHT TWO AND THEN WE'D LIKE
TO BETTER TURN IT OVER TO CENTER
PORTANTINO WHO IS TO BILLS.
IN FRONT OF COMMITTEE.
SENATE TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO AS
CENTER NIELSEN TO BE A CHAIR AND
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR JACKSON
WILL BE PRESENTING SENATE BILL.
ONE EIGHT TWO THERE NIELSEN.
WE WILL LEAD NEW SB.
ONE EIGHTY TWO PRESENTED BY THE
CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
WORK.
THANKS TO HELP COVER NOISE.
WHEN?
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
--
I WILL BE QUICK MEMBERS AND
ESPECIALLY THROUGH THE CHAIR.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN WHAT OUR STATE IS
EXPERIENCE A LARGEST MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE SEASONS.
IN OUR HISTORY A COMBINATION.
TO DROUGHT FEELS ACCUMULATION
CLIMATE CHANGE DO SEVERE WEATHER
RESULT IN AWHILE FIRES OF ON
PRESENT PRESIDENT DECIDES IN
INTENSITY.
BUT IT KILLED OVER ONE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIANS DESTROYED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES AND BURNED
WELL OVER A MILLION ACRES.
THIS PERSISTENT THREAT OF
WILDFIRE PROSE IS A SIGNIFICANT
REST TO HOMES AND BUSINESSES IN
EVERY CORNER OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE MUCH IS BEING DONE TO
BETTER MANAGER FORCE.
THERE MUST BE MORE DONE TO BE
ABLE TO HARDEN OUR EXISTING
HOMES TO MAKE THEM MORE
RESILIENT.
AND RESISTANT A WILDFIRE IN
IMPROVE LAND USE DECISIONS AND
MINIMIZE THIS THREAT.
IN THIS BILL THIS BILL DOES JUST
THAT.
IT FOCUSES ON NEW COMMUNITIES
INCREASINGLY BUILT IN WILD IN
AREAS IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ISMS.
AT ARE MORE A AT THE MARCH
THIRTEENTH HEARING THAT THE
CENTER JACKSON HELD IT FOCUSED
ON THE DEVELOPMENT IN FIRE PRONE
REGIONS -- AND AS YOU ALL KNOW
THIS COMMITTEE ALONG WITH
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
RECOMMENDED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ACTION TO BOLSTER LOCAL
PLANNING EFFORTS DESIGN MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
CONDITION DEVELOPMENT APPROVALS
TO ENSURE THAT STRUCTURES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED FROM FIRE OR ENCOURAGE
DEVELOPMENT OUT OF HARM'S WAY.
AND THIS BILL THIS BILL IS
GROUND BREAKING IT DOES
PRECISELY THAT.
NUMBER ONE IT CONDITIONS NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND IDENTIFIED WE
AREAS UPON CITIES AND COUNTIES
MEETING SPECIFIED WILDFIRE RISK
EDUCTION STANDARDS.
REQUIRES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
VERIFY ON GOING COMPLIANCE WITH
DEFENSE DISPENSE WILSON
DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT AND LOCAL
FIRE PLAN WHILE FIRE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANES INCLUDING
INCLUDING DOCUMENT COMPLIANCE
FOR EACH IMPACT PROPERTY AT
LEAST EVERY THREE YEARS.
A DIRECT COUNTIES IN TANDEM WITH
UPDATING THEIR GENERAL PLAN
SAFETY ELEMENTS TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE RECTOR FOR ITS
STRATEGY. FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
VULNERABLE TO WILDFIRE WITHIN
ITS JURISDICTION IN INCLUDES
PROCESSES FOR IDENTIFIED
IMPACTED INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS
AND MILESTONES FOR COMPLETING
RETROFIT WORK.
IN ADDED TO IDENTIFYING
POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES IN
FINANCING STRATEGIES.
MANY AMENDMENTS AS YOU ALL KNOW
REQUIRES ALL DEVELOPMENT IN WHAT
WE ARE IS TO MEET.
SPECIFIED FIRE RESPONSE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN IGNITION
REDUCTION STANDARDS INSTEAD OF
ONLY DEVELOPMENTS OF ELEVEN OR
MORE STRUCTURES.
THE LAST MAN IN PARTICULAR
DIRECTING THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
TO UNDERTAKE A NOTICE AND
COMMENT RULEMAKING TO ESTABLISH
NEW WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
STANDARDS THAT ACCOUNT MORE MORE
PRECISELY FOR CLIENT
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE.
WEATHER IN DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS.
SHOULD HELP REDUCE THE
UNCERTAINTY AND POTENTIAL LACK
OF UNIFORMITY IN RISK REDUCTION
SANDERS RAISES A CONCERN
POTENTIALLY BY THE OPPOSITION
THAT WE'RE HERE TODAY.
CENTER JACKSON HAS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO OUR
WITNESSES WHO HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY COLLABORATIVE OVER THE
PAST MANY MONTHS IN WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE MOST APPROPRIATE TIME.
MISTER CHAIR.
IF WE HAVE WITNESSES IN FAVOR
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT.
THE MORNING TRACY WRI WROTE
COUNTY REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIA
--
IN SUPPORT.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOCUSED PRIMARILY
ON VEGETATION FUEL MANAGEMENT --
THROUGH SB NINE A ONE SB -- ONE
EIGHTY TWO THIS YEAR FOCUSES ON
THE OTHER TWO PRONGS OF
MITIGATING FIRE RISK -- TO LIFE
AND PROPERTY AND THAT'S CREATING
MORE FIRE SAFE COMMUNITIES AND
ALSO FINDING A MECHANISM TO
ENFORCE COMMUNITY AND INDIVIDUAL
HOME FIRE SAFETY -- TO CREATE
MORE FIRE SAFETY FOR FIRE SAFE
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL REQUIRES
SPECIFIC WILD WILD FIRE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS FOR ALL
DEVELOPMENTS -- AS THE SENATOR
SAID THROUGH NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION STANDARDS AND ALSO
THROUGH REGULATIONS BY THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL -- SB ONE A TWO
ALSO REQUIRES -- SITE SPECIFIC
DEVELOPMENT -- PLANNING -- SO TO
CONSIDER HOW TO CREATE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT HAVING.
THE WAY THAT THE LAY OUT OF THE
DEVELOPMENT IS CREATING SAFE
AREAS -- FOR EVACUATION IN
CREATING OPEN SPACE FOR FIRE
BREAKS.
SB WHEN A TO ALSO ALSO CREATES A
STRUCTURE -- FOR COMMUNITY AND
HOMEOWNER LAND MANAGEMENT -- BY
REQUIRING -- THAT THERE'S
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO CHECK IT ENSURE THAT
DEFENSE WILL SPACES MAINTAINED
IT ALSO CREATES -- AN ASSESSMENT
FOR THE COMMUNITY MUCH LIKE
THROUGH AN H. AWAY OR OR SOME
OTHER STRUCTURE -- TO FIND THIS
DEFENSIBLE SPACE MAINTENANCE
WHICH CONTINUES TO BE AN ISSUE.
BUT AS YOU WANTED TO PROVE ITS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM APPROVING
ANY KIND OF DEVELOPMENT -- AND
LESS THE PROJECT AND ALL THE
STRUCTURES ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE WILD FIRE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS OUTLINED IN
THE BILL.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL REALLY
CREATES A BALANCE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- REALIZES IT
RECOGNIZES THAT WE NEED TO COME
TO THE TABLE AND LOOKING HOW --
THESE DEVELOPMENTS ARE -- PLACED
IN FIRE PRONE AREAS AND WE
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS DONE AND THE
AUTHORS OFFICE IN WORKING WITH
US IN CREATING -- A SPACE FOR US
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BRING
THIS PROGRAM UP -- BUT TO ALSO
CREATE SOME.
ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WITH THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE -- I HAVE -- EITHER WAY
LEAN RC RC GENERAL COUNSEL HERE
FOR ANY KIND OF DETAILED
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
AS YOU PROCEED LET ME ENCOURAGE
YOU.
TO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO MEET A
TEST OF COMFORT FOR SOMEBODY
LIKE ME THAT'S REPRESENTED
NINETEEN DIFFERENT COUNTIES MANY
OF WHICH A RURAL.
THIS COULD BE LOOKED AT IS KIND
OF DISCRIMINATORY TOWARDS --
DISCOURAGING.
ANY EXPANSION OR LOCATION IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
A HIGHER STANDARD IF YOU WILL.
AND IN IN A IN A PEDIMENT SO I'M
GONNA HAVE TO BE CONVINCED AT
LEAST ME SO KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
YOU DISCUSS.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS PAUL MASON WITH CIVIC
FOREST TRUST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
MORNING.
I REALLY WANT TO SEND MY
APPRECIATION TO BOTH SENATOR
JACKSON BUT ALSO PARTICULARLY TO
THE RURAL COUNTIES FOR COMING TO
THE TABLE.
AND PUTTING SO MUCH TIME AND
ENERGY INTO COMING UP WITH WHAT
THEY SEE AS A WORKABLE WAY
FORWARD TO DEAL WITH A DIFFICULT
THORNY PROBLEM.
I MEAN.
NEARLY EVERYBODY AGREES THAT.
WELCOME IN THIS CONDITION WHERE
WE'RE SEEING MORE EXTREME FIRE
BEHAVIOR -- YOU KNOW THAT
PROBLEMS ONLY GET WORSE WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE WE NEED TO STOP
MAKING OUR CHALLENGE OF
DEFENDING HOMES THAT ARE OUT IN.
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS WORSE THIS
IS A REASONABLE STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION AGAIN SOMETHING WHERE
THE COUNTIES HAVE COME TO THE
TABLE AND SAID WE THINK THIS
WORKS SO.
I THINK THE WITH THE ENTITIES
THE YOU SEE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS EFFORT REALLY SPEAK FAR
MORE THAN -- I CAN DESCRIBE IN
TWO MINUTES IN TERMS OF THE
MERITS OF THIS -- YOU KNOW FROM
A FOR THE PERSPECTIVE OF NOT
MAKING UP OUR CHALLENGES WORSE I
THINK THAT -- IT IS A IN THE
ENTIRELY.
MODEST APPROACH WITH THOSE THAT
COME FORWARD AND SAY THAT WE
SHOULD NOT -- PROHIBIT BUILDING
ANYWHERE AND THAT'S JUST SIMPLY
NOT A PRACTICAL WAY -- TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF HARM'S WAY AND THE
KEEPER FIREFIGHTERS OUT OF
HARM'S WAY THAT'S JUST AND
OURSELVES UP.
FOR ADDITIONAL LOSSES AND WE
NEED TO BE MORE CAREFUL THERE --
I SHOULD KNOW THAT THERE IS ONE
PROVISION AT THE END OF THE BILL
--
THE TALKS ABOUT -- PROPOSES
FUNDING SOME OF THESE ADDITIONAL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE --
PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES
EVACUATION ROUTES ETCETERA ALL
VERY MERITORIOUS THINGS PROPOSED
TO FUND THEM FROM THE FOREST
HEALTH -- ALLOCATION IN THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND WE
THINK WE SHOULD FIND A DIFFERENT
WAY TO PAY FOR SOME OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND NOT BE DIVERTING
THE FOURTH HEALTH MONEY -- BUT
WE'RE VERY SUPPORT OF THE BILL
OR DRIES OUT.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRAY THANK YOU
KAREN MARTIN'S AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES I'LL BE BRIEF
BECAUSE MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
ROLE COUNTIES REALLY I'M MADE
ALL OUR SALIENT POINTS ALL JUST
NOTE THAT AFTER THE DEVASTATION
OF THE FIRES OVER THE PAST.
SEVERAL YEARS COUNTIES HAVE COME
TO THE TABLE AND WE REALIZE WE
HAVE TO DO MORE WE HAVE TO DO
MORE IN A VERY DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION.
BALANCING BOTH THE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR EXISTING COMMUNITIES
IN RURAL AND URBANIZED AREAS BUT
ALSO PUT INTO PLACE SOME CHECKS
AND BALANCES FOR FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT IN THESE AREAS BUT
ALSO RECOGNIZING THE CHALLENGES
AND PRESSURES.
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES FACE WITH
HOUSING NEEDS AND AND OTHER
ISSUES THAT THEY FACE -- WE DO
HAVE A SUPPORT IN CONCEPT --
POSITION ON THE BILL AND THINK
THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF
TREMENDOUSLY FOR WORKING WITH US
--
AND WE SUPPORTER AND MOVING THIS
BEFORE TODAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANKS.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS AREN'T ABLE ANSWER
REPRESENT AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO HAVE AN
OFFICIALLY TAKEN A SUPPORT
POSITION BUT WE'RE PRETTY MUCH
THERE WERE REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS AND REALLY SUPPORT
THE UNDERLYING.
I'M INTENT OF THE BILL AND AS US
THE SECOND TICKET AT THIS IS A
TOUGH CONVERSATION BUT A REALLY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
SAFEGUARDING OUR COMMUNITY IS TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN -- AND
REALLY APPRECIATE SENATOR
JACKSON AND EVERYBODY WHO HAS AN
RC RC AND EVERYBODY WHO'S BEEN
INVOLVED IN THESE DISCUSSIONS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS THANK YOU.
THE MINISTER MEMBERS CHASE RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT WE DON'T
KNOW FROM POSITION YET --
HOWEVER -- BUT WE ARE VERY
SUPPORT OF HIS CONVERSATION WE
NEED TO HAVE IT ON THEIR TWO
THINGS WITH A VERY BRIEFLY
MENTION THOUGH -- ONE PERHAPS
YOU MIGHT NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME -- IN ORDER FOR US TO
APPEAR PLANS RIGHT NOW IT SAYS
UPON THE NEXT HOUSING ELEMENT --
AMENDMENT OR YOU KNOW TWENTY
TWENTY SOBRE SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE IN THESE
AREAS MIGHT NEED A LITTLE EXTRA
HELP PERHAPS SOME MONEY I'M SORE
THANKFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
MONEY IN HIS BUDGET FOR PLANNING
WHICH CERTAINLY CAN ASSIST --
WITH THIS THE OTHER THING I
WOULD LIKE TO REMIND FOLKS IS
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT
EASY EITHER OFF LIMITS TO
BUILDING THERE IS WHICH IS NOT
THE INTENT IS BILL OR MORE
DIFFICULT OR COSTLY TO BUILDINGS
FIRE PRONE AREAS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A RECOGNITION
THAT OUR CITIES PROBABLY NEED TO
HAVE A LOWER OBLIGATION FOR
PLANNING. FOR HOUSING IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES IT CAN'T BE BOTH WE
CAN HAVE A REALLY HIGH READ A
NUMBER AND THEN ALSO THEN NOT BE
ABLE TO GET THOSE UNITS
CONSTRUCTING THE AREA.
BECAUSE THERE ARE REAL PENALTIES
NOW BEING ASSOCIATED WITH NON
COMPLIANCE WITH ARENA SO WITH
THAT WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THE THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND IT'S OUR HOPE TO WILL
GET TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THAT'S A BILL THAT DOUBLE HAD
STORED AND NOW WE HAVE A THREAD
OF TAKING AWAY THE GAS FUEL
MONEY.
THE COMMUNITIES A DON'T DO
CERTAIN THINGS THAT THE STATE
WOULD MANDATE AND THE I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT DIRECTION
PLEASE.
WIENER SERRANO IF THERE'S
ANYMORE ARE YOU SUPPORT BETWEEN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
TWENTY I DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKS.
YES HELLO GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY LIKE MANY
OTHERS SINCE HE DOESN'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
WE DO APPRECIATE SENATOR JACKSON
ENGAGING US WITH US VERY EARLY
ON IN THE PROCESS.
WE RECOGNIZE THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS THAT WILDFIRES HAVE HAD
IN THE STATE AND WE THINK THAT
WE FUNDAMENTALLY NEED TO RE
EVALUATE LAND USE POLICIES THAT
HAVE LED TO PEOPLE BEING PUT IN
HARM'S WAY -- TO THAT EXTENT WE
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH SB
WHEN HE TO ALTHOUGH IT IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTIONS WE ARE
CONCERNED.
ABOUT USING G. JR **** --
HEALTHY HOMES HEALTHY FORCED
FUNDS EXCLUSIVELY -- FOR SORRY
EXCLUSIVELY FOR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND WE FEEL THAT WE
NEED TO FIND BOTH.
OF FORCE RESTORATION AND
COMMUNITY PROTECTION
SPECIFICALLY PRIORITIZING PUBLIC
SAFETY THROUGH A WAY THAT IS --
HAS FOR STRATEGY MANAGEMENT --
IN MIND BUT ALSO WILL COVER
LARGE AREAS OF LAND SO WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
SENATOR AND LOOK FOR TO THAT
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT THANK YOU.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY DISCUSSION
WITH THE REGIONAL COUNCIL RURAL
COUNTIES OF GOOD OPPOSITION RC
RC AND THEY'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS.
THE PREVENTION OKAY THAT WAS
THAT WAS YEARS.
CAN OPPOSITION YEAH OKAY.
JUST AS LONG AS THERE'S BEEN
SOME DISCUSSION.
AGAIN I RETAIN SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPACT.
AND ALSO THE CONCOMITANT NEED TO
HAVE SOME.
PLANNING RESTRICTIONS ON MORE
URBANIZED COMMUNITIES IT
ENCROACH ON THE URBAN INTERFACE
AREA.
IT ISN'T JUST THE RURAL AREAS
THAT HAVE CREATED PROBLEMS IT IS
LARGER COMMUNITIES BUILDING OUT.
IN EXPANDING INTO THE THRESHOLD.
REACHABLE BY LARGER FIRES IT WE
NOW INDOOR.
AND WE CANNOT NOT TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THAT ASPECT.
AND THERE MAY BE A NEED I THINK
THERE IS A NEED FOR SOME
REQUIREMENTS ON LARGER
COMMUNITIES RELATED THE INTER
URBAN FACE.
URBAN INTERFACE YET SOMETHING
SIR.
IF YOU CALL THE OPPOSITION YEAH
A LITTLE EARLY.
I'M AFRAID OF LIFE.
MAYBE OF THE A GOOD MORNING THIS
[inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR. TEN MEMBERS -- THE
CAMERA ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED THIS BILL AS A
HOUSING KILLER -- I PREFER.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
THIS BILL IS A HOUSING KILLER
AND YOU SAW SOME REFERENCES TO
THAT CONCERN.
I THINK WHEN THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES CAME UP AND MENTION THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT -- I WANT TO SAY THAT
--
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION IF WE HAD BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS.
EARLIER ON PERHAPS WE WOULDN'T
BE HERE TODAY BUT HAVING SAID
THAT OUR APPROACH TO AND AN
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL IS A TASK.
TO FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS WHERE
DOES IT APPLY AND WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO IN THOSE AREAS.
SO YOU HER REFERENCE TO WHOOPIE
THAT MEANS THAT IT'S VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY SONS WERE
FAMILIAR WITH THOSE THOSE ARE
POSTED ON THE INTERNET WE CAN
LOOK AT HOSE MAPS AND FIND OUT
WHETHER OR NOT ARE PROJECTS.
ARE GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO THIS
REGULATORY REGIME.
IT ALSO APPLIES TO AREAS OUTSIDE
OF THAT ONE OF THOSE AREAS.
ANY AREA WERE STRUCTURE
INTERMINGLED WITH VEGETATION.
THINK ABOUT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO.
IS SACRAMENTO WE ARE KNOWN FOR
AND DESIRABLE FOR THE THE LARGE
NUMBER OF TREES WE HAVE IN
DOWNTOWN MADE TOWN AND IN THE
SUBURBS.
THAT'S VEGETATION.
THAT.
ALONG WITH CAPITOL PARK WE HAVE
MCKINLEY PARK LAND PARK THAT NOW
BECOMES A PROBLEM FOR OUR
PROJECTS AS WERE BUILDING
HOUSING IN THESE AREAS THAT ARE
DANCE.
MULTI FAMILY PROJECTS -- THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF PROJECTS THE
STATE WANTS US TO BUILD THAT
BECOMES AN OBSTACLE.
THAT IS OVERBROAD AND MAKES THE
BILL UNWORKABLE.
I WANT TO IT UNDERSCORE THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL ALONG WITH MANY
OTHERS THAT HAVE.
PRECEDED.
HAVE TAKEN THE APPROACH.
THAT DOESN'T ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE'S NO PERFECT PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA TO BUILD.
AND THIS BILL IT'S WILDFIRES IN
OTHERS IT'S SEISMIC IN OTHERS
IT'S DISPLACEMENT GENTRIFICATION
AG LAND PRESERVATION HABITAT
CONSERVATION WETLANDS TOXICS.
YOU NAME IT EVERYBODY'S GOT AN
ISSUE.
SO IN LESS WE STOP FOCUSING
SOLELY ON ONE SIDE OF THE
EQUATION AND GIVE SUFFICIENT
BALANCE THE CREATION OF MORE
HOUSING. FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
NEED SHELTER WE'RE ONLY GOING TO
PROLIFERATE THE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT HAS LESS TO A DEFICIT OF
THREE AND A HALF MILLION HOMES.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IN THESE
AREAS?
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING LAND USE
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW FOR TWENTY SIX
YEARS I READ THE BILL MULTIPLE
TIMES I CAN'T FIGURE OUT FROM
THE BILL WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IN
THOSE AREAS.
THERE'S LOTS OF CROSS REFERENCES
TO VARIOUS NON REGULATORY
REGIMES THE EITHER AND DON'T
EXIST AT ALL OR ONLY EXIST IN A
FEW PLACES.%
THAT MAKES THIS BILL SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN'T DETERMINE HOW TO
PLAN DESIGN OR CONSTRUCT A
PROJECT IN WHATEVER AREA IT
APPLIES.
TO THAT TURNS IT INTO SIMPLY A
GAME OF GOTCHA.
THAT'LL DISRUPT PROJECTS THAT
ALREADY HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
APPROVAL AND PLAN FOR HOUSING.
YOU PROBABLY THINK IN.
WHO IS THIS INSENSITIVE JERK
THAT'S COMING UP HERE AND SAYING
YOU KNOW DON'T YOU UNDERSTAND
WILDFIRES ARE IMPORTANT?
I WANT YOU TO KNOW MY DAUGHTER
WAS CAUGHT IN THE THOMAS FIRE.
FOUR NIGHTS WE DIDN'T SLEEP
WONDERING IF SHE ALIVE IS SHE
NOT ALIVE SHE LOST THERE THE LOS
CELL PHONE TOWERS THEY LOST
POWER.
AND SHE IS STATE WITH THE
CLOTHES ON HER BACK IN AFTER
BEING EVACUATED THREE TIMES
EVENTUALLY CAME HOME.
HOW CAN I ARGUE FOR HOUSING
HAVING HAD THAT EXPERIENCE I
ALSO WANT A PLACE FOR HER TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA?
AND I THINK WE NEED TO ALWAYS.
KEEP IN MIND WE NEED A PATHWAY
FORWARD FOR HOUSING.
WE NEED A PLACE FOR HOUSING.
IF YOU SAY NO ONE ONE AREA YOU
NEED TO REMOVE OBSTACLES IN
ANOTHER.
WE'VE DONE THE ANALYSIS IN THE
DATA.
OF THE DATA FROM THESE FIRES
YOU'LL NOTE.
THAT THE HOMES THAT WERE BURNED
OR ONES THAT WEREN'T COMPLIANCE
WITH EXISTING THE RIGHT EXISTING
REGULATORY REGIME.
THAT IS THEY WERE EITHER NOT IN
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITIES
OWNS OR WEREN'T BUILT AT A TIME
WHEN THE LATEST CODES APPLIED.
SO WE'VE DONE THAT ANALYSIS YOU
CAN DO IT JUST BY LOOKING ON THE
INTERNET THIS IS A BILL THAT
FOCUSES ALMOST ENTIRELY.
ON NEW DEVELOPMENT.
THAT'S THE NATURE OF PLANNING
AND LAND USE LAW.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DON'T GO BACK
TO EXISTING RESIDENTS. FOR THE
MOST PART THERE IS SOME
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ENFORCEMENT
HERE WHICH HAS BEEN A PROBLEM
AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
HAVING SAID THAT AS IT STANDS WE
FIND THE BILL TO BE UNWORKABLE
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
WELL YOU RAISE SOME LEGITIMATE
POINTS.
MAY I ASK PROPONENTS WHAT ABOUT
A PARADISE COMMUNITY THAT NOW
HAS TO REBUILD ALMOST FROM
SCRATCH.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION APPLY TO
THEM AS A SIDE.
TO REESTABLISH THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
--
I'LL TURN IT OVER HEIGHT TO THE
RC RC TURNING ON THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTION BUT I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO JUST ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ITEMS.
THAT YOU BROUGHT FORWARD -- IS
WELL AS WELL AS WHITE -- THE
REPRESENTATIVE AND APPRECIATE
HIS COMMENTS FROM C. B. I A
NUMBER ONE ON BEHALF OF CENTER
JACKSON WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE MINUTES IN -- EIGHT
YOU HAVE HER COMMITMENT TO BE A
TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
TWO WE TALK ABOUT READING THE
BILL.
THE STANDARDS ARE SPELLED OUT IN
THE BILL.
AND WHERE THE SUPPLIES.
SO OVER READING THE BILL.
THE STANDARDS ARE SPELLED OUT.
THE NAME IS FOR SHARED WITH THE
OPPOSITION YESTERDAY.
THAT ALSO SPELLS OUT A PUBLIC
PROCESS AND HOW THE STANDARDS
WOULD BE ADOPTED.
IS A VERY SPECIFIC PUBLIC
PROCESS.
THAT WOULD BE -- ADVANCED.
THAT THE PUBLIC IN ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES WOULD BE ABLE
TO FOCUS IN ON TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK OF CRITICISMS.
THIS IS NOT APPLY TO DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO.
CHICO OR DOWNTOWN LAKE PORT IS
SUPPLIES TO THE WILL BE.
IN HIGH FIRE HAS A SEVERITY
ZONES.
IT'S IN THE BILL.
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO WOULD NEVER
BE IN THIS BILL -- NOTHING IN
THIS BILL FOCUSES ON THE ON THE
DOWNTOWN CORE -- I WOULD NOT
HAVE SUPPORTED THIS BILL.
IF IT WAS GOING TO BE AN UNFAIR
BURDEN ON RURAL -- I'M ONE OF
THE FEW DEMOCRATS IN THIS SENATE
THE REPRESENTS A RULE DISTRICT
AND UNFORTUNATELY LIKE CENTER
NIELSEN HAVE SEEN.
GOD AWFUL FIRES OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS.
THIS BILL IS REASONABLE AND
PROVIDES A FIVE YEAR ON RAMP FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH NEW REGULATIONS MAY
BE.
A FIVE YEAR ON RAMP.
THE SAME STANDARDS THAT WOULD
IMPACT LA.
MALIBU AND THE GOOD A BEACH.
WOULD BE APPLIED TO CHICO CLEAR
LAKE IN THE SHOP.
WITHIN THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
POTENTIAL DWELLINGS WITHIN THE
WILLIE.
AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU LA
COUNTY.
HAS SOME OF THE LARGEST --
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE ZONES
IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR ENDED HERE AND TURN IT
OVER TO THE R. C. R. C. TURNING
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR WORK.
THERE IS ALSO THREE TIERS ARE
SPELLED OUT IN THIS BILL.
VERY CLEARLY SAYING TO
HOMEOWNERS THAT YOU CAN BUILD
BUT FOR EXAMPLE IN TIER ONE YOU
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE HARDER
BUILDING STANDARDS YOU HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO PUT DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
IN TIER -- TWO IN YET NINE UNITS
OR ABOVE YOU HAVE TO HAVE FIRE
PROTECTION PLANS RESPONSE TIME
PLANS -- AND WHAT TO DO IF WE DO
HAVE A FIRE BREAK OUT HERE THREE
ONE HUNDRED UNITS ARE ABOVE YOU
HAVE TO ACCEPT THE OPR BEST
STANDARDS BY THE WAY THAT ARE
ALREADY OUT THERE.
IN ALL THIS INDEED YOU'RE
INJURED OVER MISTER CHAIR TO THE
RCA RCR ATTORNEY IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT BUILDING WE BUILD HOMES IN
THE WILL WE BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT
EVACUATING -- AND WHAT I KNOW
ANDWHAT YOU KNOW IS THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS WORLD THAT IS
GOING TO STOP THE TYPE OF FIRE
THE DISTASTE HIS UNFORTUNATELY
SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
AND SO WE HAVE TO START PUTTING
IN HAND STANDARDS ON PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC.
IN IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT HARDENING
BECAUSE WE CAN PARDON HOME ALL
WE WANT.
BUT I'VE SEEN A FULL CEMENT
HOME.
COMPLETELY GUTTED.
AND THE WALL STILL STAND.
IT IS ALSO ABOUT ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE.
ADEQUATE.
EVACUATION PLANS IN PLACE WHICH
THIS BILL WILL ALSO DO INTO THE
CHAIR IF IT'S OKAY ALL TURNED
OVER THERE ARE SEARS YOU TURN.
SOMEBODY'S PROCEED AND TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE EVACUATION
PLANS I'M FAMILIAR WITH THAT I
WAS HELPING THE COUNTY SHERIFF
THE LONG TIME AGO.
CHANGE OF AN EVACUATION PLAN
ACTUALLY IS THE EVACUATIONS IN
PLACE WELL.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR NELSON AND LET ME
ACTUALLY TRY TO ANSWER TO OF
YOUR QUESTIONS AT ONCE IF I CAN.
ONE IS THE IMPACT OF THIS BILL
ON RULES AND WHETHER THAT'S AN
UNFAIR IMPACT -- AND THE SECOND
IS THE IMPACT OF THIS BILL ON
THE REBUILDING OF PARADISE
BECAUSE THOSE TOUCH ON ISSUES
THAT -- WE CERTAINLY IS RURAL
COUNTIES ARE VERY SENSITIVE TO
ON I WILL SAY THAT MYSELF S THE
FORMER COUNTY COUNCIL FOR TO HIM
A COUNTY -- IN YOUR DISTRICT AND
ALSO VERY SENSITIVE TO A AND WE
DEFINITELY DID NOT AS WE WERE
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
BUILD THIS BILL ARE WE WERE VERY
STE WE WERE ON VERY CAREFUL TO
TRY TO AVOID THAT.
SO ALSO COME IN TERMS OF
PROJECTS IN SOME COMMUNITIES
THAT WOULD BE IMPACTED THAT ARE.
PERMITTED IN PART.
THAT AND PROCESS.
THAT.
TO AFFECT THEM -- SO THE SHORT
ANSWER IS.
YES WITH THE CAVEAT AND THE
CABBIE OUT IS AS SOME TO REQUIRE
VERY A VERY CLEARLY AND
CORRECTLY NOTED THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF MAJOR.
ARM BUT I WILL SAVE MEDICAID
ORDERS FOR THOSE OF US IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES THOSE OF US -- TO
THINKING ABOUT PARADISE AND
THOSE OF US WHO ARE THINKING
ABOUT PROJECTS THAT ARE ALREADY
IN THE PIPELINE.
THAT I THINK MAKES THIS BILL
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
REASONABLE AND VERY WORKABLE.
SO WITH REGARD TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES WHICH FOR TO
PARADISE IN PARTICULAR ONE OF
THINGS WE WERE SENSITIVE TO OUR
HOW DEVELOPMENTS ACTUALLY
HAPPENED YOU KNOW INTO HIM A
COUNTIES I'M FAMILIAR WITH AND
WHAT THE REBUILDING PROCESS IN
PARADISE IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE
--
GENERALLY SPEAKING MOST
DEVELOPMENTS AGAIN YOU'REUNDER
CORPORATE AREA TO HIM A COUNTY
WHICH I WAS VERY FAMILIAR WITH
AND IN THE REBUILD OF PARADISE
OUT THERE NOT CAN BE A HUNDRED
PLUS UNIT RANGE THEY'RE GOING TO
BE HOUSE BY HOUSE.
STREET BY STREET WE WERE
COGNIZANT OF THAT WHEN THE TWIN
THE TEARING WAS BUILT THE YOUR
TIER ONE ASCENDER MCGUIRE
INDICATED.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT ARE FOR
THE MOST PART VERY CLEARLY CAN
VERY -- CLEARLY EITHER WITH AN
EXISTING STANDARDS OR ARE A VERY
MODEST EXPANSION OF EXISTING
STANDARDS OR SOMETHING THAT --
SORRY I'LL TRY TO ROCK TO MAKE
YOUR LITTLE THAT.
OUGHT IN THE HALLWAY OF SO WE'LL
HAVE TO TALK OVERTURE OKAY NOW
NOW DO TRIED TO DO MY BEST.
SO THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE
THINK ARE ON THERE YOU CHIEF
BORN ALTERNATELY COST EFFECTIVE
FOR THE TYPES OF DEVELOPMENTS
THAT WE FREQUENTLY DO SEE
ENROLLING CORPORATE AREAS THE
END FOR THE TYPES OF DEVELOPMENT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE AS PART
OF THE PARADISE REBUILD WE WERE
VERY VERY.
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
WITH REGARD TO DEVELOPMENTS THAT
ARE IN THE PIPELINE ALL THIS
THIS IS A PROJECT THAT HAS
ALREADY RECEIVED IF IT HAS A
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENT HAS
ALREADY GOTTEN ITS DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENT IF AS A SUB DIVISION
IS ALREADY GONE THROUGH THE
SUBDIVISION PROCESS.
AND ALL THAT'S LEFT TO DO WERE
BUILD HOMES IT'S GOING TO GETS
GOING TO HAVE THOSE TIER ONE
STANDARDS AS THE HOMES GO
FORWARD IT'S ONLY BE GET NEW
DEVELOPMENTS THINGS THAT HAVE
NOT GOTTEN TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY'VE GOTTEN THEIR
DISCRETIONARY APPROVALS.
YEAH THAT ARE YOU KNOW OR THAT
ARE INVOLVING MULTIPLE UNITS A
LARGE NUMBER OF UNITS AT ONE
TIME THERE ARE POTENTIALLY
LOOKING AT THE HIGHER STANDARDS.
THE OTHER POINT TO KEEP IN MIND
IS A SOME OF THEM REQUIRE
REFERENCED ON THE ON RAMPS AGAIN
PROJECTS THAT ARE A PROJECTS
THAT ARE IN PROCESS AND THEY'RE
LOOKING AT GETTING COMPLETED
BEFORE THE YOU KNOW AS THE THE
ON RAMP RAMPS UP.
ON THERE'S GOING TO BE SOMEBODY
GATORS THERE FOR THEM AS WELL SO
WE WE TRIED TO BUILD IT AGAIN
WITH A BALANCE BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT AND INDEED THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'LL BUT WE WERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT YOU RAISED
WE TRIED TO BUILD IN A WAY TO
MAKE IT BOTH EFFECTIVE BUT
REASONABLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OF FOR THE FOR
THE COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION SIR.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE AUDIENCE WHO WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE.
TENDER BELLY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
--
FOR MY DISTRICT DISTRICT --
SENATE-DISTRICT FIFTEEN WE HAVE
--
LARGE AREAS UP IN -- HILLS UP
ABOVE -- THE URBANIZED AREAS
SANTA CLARA COUNTY THEY HAVE
LARGE IN THE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE.
AND WE ALSO -- ON THE CAL FIRE
MAPS THERE.
HI FIRE AREAS OF OF LOS GATOS
SIR TOLD -- CUPERTINO -- AND
THEN IN THE EAST WITH THOSE AS
WELL -- POPULATIONS IN THE HUNT
IN THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE --
THESE HIGH FIRE AREAS -- HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS YOU KNOW THERE LONG.
OLD DEVELOPMENTS THAT OCCURRED
--
AND A LOT OF THE IBM'S WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THE THE GENERAL PLAN
OF THE TONY.
AND THE GENERAL FAN OF LOS GATOS
AND THE OTHER CITIES IS.
BECAUSE THEY WERE DEVELOP SO
LONG AGO THERE'S A LOT OF
CIRCULATION.
US ST CIRCULATION PROBLEMS.
OF DEAD END STREETS WITH LARGE
HOW NUMBERS OF HOMES ON ON YOU
KNOW YOU GO DOWN -- THE STREET
AND BE A LOT OF HOMES AT THE END
BUT TO BE IN THE MIDDLE OF FIRE
AREA.
SO -- THE PUBLIC SAFETY PLAN OF
THE TWO CARS IN THE JOURNAL
PLAN.
IS -- A REDUCE.
IS A RISK REDUCTION.
STE YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE A
RISK REDUCTION STRATEGY THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF A THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ELEMENT OF A JOURNAL
PLANNED SO.
SO -- I THINK THE THE ONE OF THE
AREAS OF PROBABLY NEEDS A LITTLE
WORK OR ARTICULATION THIS BILL.
IS THE BECAUSE I'M SHERMAN OF
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE I
LOOKED AT THIS.
IS THE TRANSPORTATION AND
CIRCULATION.
PROBLEMS IN HEART AND FIRE.
HI FIRE AREAS.
OF THE DEAD END STREETS ISSUES
ONE YOU SHOULD UP TWO POINTS OF
ACCESS -- ANOTHER -- ONE BASED
ON OUR EXPERIENCE IN OUR AREA IS
--
IT ACTUALLY IS IS A PROBLEM IN
GETTING AMONG THE REDWOOD TREES
AND ALL THE BIG TREES OF PEOPLE
LOVE TO LIVE UP THERE.
AMONG THOSE TREES BUT WHAT THE
TREES DO IS THEY BECAUSE
DIFFICULTY IN GETTING FIRE
EQUIPMENT UP THERE SO OUR OUR
FIRE TEAMS HAVE TO HAVE.
SMALL FIRE ENGINES THAT CAN
MANEUVER THROUGH THE SMALL
STREETS.
AND THE MUTUAL AID.
FIRE TRUCKS A LOT OF ROOM CAN'T
GET UP INTO THOSE AREAS.
SO -- JUST THE CIRCULATION --
EVALUATIONS AND HARM REDUCTION.
LOOK AT THE CIRCULATION AND HOW
YOU CAN REDUCE.
HARM AND REAL US WITH.
A BETTER.
CIRCULATION IN THE IN THOSE HIGH
FIRE HI HI.
RHYS FIRE AREAS SO -- I THINK
MAYBE THAT THAT COULD BE -- IN
ADDITION TO THE BILL IT'S NOT
COMING TO MY COMMITTEE -- I LOOK
AT THIS BILL BECAUSE I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT IT WE HAD A
PUBLIC MEETING.
IN MY AREA IN LOS GATOS WERE.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE THAT
THE MEETING WAS LED BY CAL FIRE
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY FIRE
CHIEFS.
THEY ALL CAME DOWN TO THE
MEETING AND WE THIS WAS THE
TYPES ISSUES WE DISCUSS WE ALSO
DISCUSS -- COPE COMPLIANCE.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF STRUCTURES IN THE HIGH FIRE
AREA THAT DON'T CONFORM.
AND LOOKING AT CO COMPLIANCE IN
A MORE SEVERE WAY POSSIBLY.
SO WE CAN -- GO UP DO
INSPECTIONS SO.
FIND -- HOUSING.
THE FIRE MARSHALS WERE STRONGLY
RECOMMENDING THIS CALL
COMPLIANCE IS A NOTHER HARM HARM
REDUCTION STRATEGY THAT WE NEED
TO TO DO.
I THINK THE BILL COULD ADDRESS
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE POSSIBLY.
A LITTLE BETTER CLEARER SO SO
THOSE ARE MY SUGGESTIONS AS A
BILL GOES THROUGH -- I STRONGLY
SUPPORT -- THIS -- LAND USE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING STRATEGY
AND I HOPE THAT -- WE WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL IN WORKING OF SOME OF
THESE ISSUES OUT.
OF THAT I BRING UP OF THROUGH
THE NEXT SEVERAL.
COMMITTEES IN PROCESS AS WE GET
SO I WANT I WANT TO KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY RESPONSE THE WORMS AND
TO THE TO THE CHASE THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS CHAIR SO -- IN THIS BILL
--
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE CENTER
BELLS FOCUS ON THIS AND THAT
THAT HAS BEEN A FOCUS FOR
SENATOR JACKSON'S WELL OF OF
UPDATING THE GENERAL PLAN OF
ACCESS POINTS IN AN OUT.
SERVICE FOR WILD FIRE EQUIPMENT.
CENTER NIELSEN WILL ALSO BE
BRINGING FOR THE BILL SENATE
BILL -- NINETY NINE AND THAT
WILL BE FOCUSING ON GETTING
FOLKS IN GETTING FOLKS OUT --
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT IT'S VERY
COMPLIMENTARY OF THE WORK THAT
CENTER JACKSON -- IN THIS TEAM
HAS BEEN DOING -- AND IT IS AN
ABSOLUTE PRIORITY AND YOU YOU'VE
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD I HAVE
THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE IS NOT
JUST ABOUT BUILDING HOUSING BUT
IT'S ALSO ABOUT GETTING FOLKS.
OUT WHEN THERE IS A JAZZ FREE ON
THEIR DOORSTEP AND THIS BILL
WILL BE A FOCUS IN ON THAT AND
THEN THERE WILL BE A SECONDARY
BILL THAT THE SOON YOU'LL SINCE
BEEN WORKING ON FROM HIS.
THAT AWFUL EXPERIENCE IN IN
PARADISE IS LOOKING AT HAVING
OUR FIRE TEAMS GO UP INTO LAW.
HOUSE BY HOUSE [inaudible]
JUST THE YES I USED TO BE
INSPECTION I CALLED I CALLED
SOFT INSPECTIONS YEAH SERVER
LIKE A COMMUNITY RELATIONS TYPE
INSPECTION WHEN YOU GO AND TALK
TO THE HOMEOWNER OR THE DOCUMENT
AND MAKE SOME SUGGESTIONS ABOUT.
WHAT THEY CAN DO THAT MAKE THEIR
HOME FIRE SAFE SO THE FIRE --
TEAMS ARE GOING TO GO UP AND DO
THAT BUT THEN FOLLOWING UP ON
THAT AFTER.
WORKING WITH THE HOMEOWNER A
MORE DELIBERATE INSPECTION
THAT'S MORE FORMAL.
THAT WOULD -- TELL HIM HEY YOU
GOT TO DEAL WITH THIS PROBLEM.
WITH THE MORE SERIOUS ISSUES
THANK YOU OF CODE ENFORCEMENT --
SO I THINK I THINK SOME -- HARM
REDUCTION STRATEGIES LIKE CODE
ENFORCEMENT -- VERY IMPORTANT --
YOU KNOW TO LAW WE HAVE LAWS ON
THAT THEY SHOULD YOU KNOW WE
SHOULD HAVE ILLEGAL.
OR VIOLATIONS WE CAN REDUCE
THOSE VIOLATIONS -- QUITE A BIT.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES I THINK THERE
COULD BE A STRONG FOCUS.
OF THE LEGISLATION THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO MAYBE SUPPLEMENTS
THOSE.
FIRE TEAMS THAT WANT TO DO THIS
TIME A CODE ENFORCEMENT.
YOU KNOW WE COULD LOOK AT HOW WE
HELP.
INCREASE THE NUMBER OUT OF
LITTLE WHAT I CALL.
SOFT THE MORE THE COMMUNITY
RELATIONS TYPE OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT YOU DO WHEN YOU GO
OUT. TO SIR TALK TO THE
HOMEOWNER AND TRY TO HELP THEM
WITH -- WITH THAT WITH THAT KIND
OF INFORMATION I THINK THESE ARE
THE SUGGESTIONS THAT CAME OUT OF
OUR OUR WE HAD LIKE OVER THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE ATTEND THE
SERVICE PROBABLY.
YOU KNOW I WAS TOLD THAT.
YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE.
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE
ANOTHER MEETING THAT PROBABLY
WILL HAVE THREE FOUR FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE.
I MEAN I MADE WERE IT'S
OBVIOUSLY IN A LOT OF OUR
DISTRICTS A VERY.
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR PUBLIC
DISCUSSION.
AND WE'RE GONNA TRY TO DO OUR
BEST -- IN -- HELPING -- THESE
THESE PEOPLE LIVING UP IN THOSE
HILLS WERE.
THERE IN THE RED ZONE SERVICE
MAPS IS.
ABSOLUTE OFFICER OUT THERE THEY
SEE THE NOW I SHOWED EVERYBODY
THE MAP RIGHT I SAID THIS.
THIS FIRE ZONE GOES ALMOST INTO
THE CENTER OF THE TOWN OF LOS
GATOS FOR EXAMPLE.
SO OF THINGS LIKE WHAT HAPPENED
UP IN SONOMA COULD HAPPEN IN OUR
IN OUR COMMUNITY -- IF WE'RE NOT
CAREFUL WE HAD A CERTAIN TYPE OF
INCIDENT OCCURS SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF THE
SENATE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU.
WHAT'S YOUR ALL WELL TAKEN THIS
IS A ISSUE WITH MANY FACETS.
AND IT WOULD APPEAR THAT THIS
BILL IS IN PROCESS AND THAT I'M
COMFORTABLE -- BUT THERE ARE
RESERVATIONS FOR EXAMPLE.
ACCESS ROADS THAT IS GOING TO BE
AN ISSUE.
BUT PAYING.
FOR UPGRADING THOSE ROADS OR IN
FACT PUTTING THE MEN.
IS GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE AND
WHAT WILL BE IMPACT ON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO DO THAT A LOT OF
THESE COMMUNITIES DO NOT HAVE A
SUSTAINING ECONOMIC BASE OF ANY
CONSEQUENCE AND COMMITTEES LIKE.
PARADISE DON'T ALMOST HAVE ANY
RIGHT NOW SO.
IT IS IN PROCESS AND IT'S A
NOBLE ATTEMPT AND IT IT DOES FIT
INTO THE OVERALL PICTURE OF
SEVERAL OF US WORKING TOGETHER.
OF FOR SOLUTIONS FOR THE FUTURE.
OF DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
MISSING -- PRESENTATION OF SOCK
PRESENTING A BILL IN THE SENATE
ENERGY COMMITTEE -- SO -- BUT I
DID WANT TO MAKE SURE TO MAKE
SOME COMMENTS HERE TODAY -- I
PPRECIATE RESULTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN -- FOR
PRESENTING FOR US CENTER JACKSON
AND I APPRECIATE THE CENTER
JACKSON IS -- REALLY -- HELPING
TO INITIATE THE PROCESS OF
DEALING WITH HOW HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THE NEW.
THE NEW ABNORMAL OR WHATEVER
GOVERNOR BROWN REFERRED TO IT AS
AN THE EXTREME DANGERS IN THESE
ARE WILD FIRES OWNS -- AND HOW
DO WE ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF OF
NEW DEVELOPMENT A NEW HOUSING IN
THESE AREAS SO I APPRECIATE THAT
AND IT'S IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
HOWEVER WE HAVE TO HANDLE THIS
ISSUE VERY CAREFULLY AND AND AND
AND THE THE THE CHALLENGES -- WE
MAY SAY WE WANT LOS DEVELOPMENT
AND WILD FIRES OWNS -- BUT THAT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED HOUSING IT
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
WITH HOUSING.
DOESN'T CHANGE THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN WHO WERE LIVING IN CARS
--
IT DOESN'T CHANGE ON THE NUMBER
OF FAMILIES WHO ARE BEING PUSHED
OUT OF OUR STATE BECAUSE WE HAVE
--
ABYSMALLY FAILED -- TO PRODUCE
AN OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA -- AND
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
WE ARE POTENTIALLY RESTRICTING.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN ONE AREA
THAT WE'RE NOT SUCH LOPPING OFF
ABOUT HOUSING -- AND THERE IS
LANGUAGE IT WAS AMENDED INTO
THIS -- BUILD THAT COULD BE READ
AS POTENTIALLY REDUCING RENO
OBLIGATIONS OF CITIES IF THEY
HAVE PARTS OF THE CITY THAT ARE
WILD FIRES OWNS -- AND SO THIS
BILL IS NOW COMING TO THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE MAX WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
ONLINE -- ONE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
CRYSTAL CLEAR -- DIED NOTHING IN
THIS BILL -- WILL REDUCE ANY
CITIES RINA OBLIGATIONS AND THAT
IF YOU ARE SAYING WE'RE NOT
BUILDING IN THIS PART OF OUR
CITY -- BECAUSE IT IS A WILD
FIRE RISK.
THAT MEANS THAT THAT THAT
HOUSING NEEDS TO BE BUILT
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND NOT COULD
MEAN.
INCREASED DENSITY FOR EXAMPLE
AND THE URBANIZED NON WILD FIRES
OWN AREAS -- SO I WILL VOTE FOR
THE BILL TODAY IF THIS WERE IF
THIS WERE IT THE FINAL FROM THE
BILL I WOULD NOT BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL -- I WILL VOTE FOR IT
TODAY TO MOVE FORWARD
UNDERSTANDING WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR -- IN
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW WITH
LET'S SAY THAT WE NOW HAVE
ENOUGH TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SECTOR WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM THEN
WE CAN TAKE AN ACTION ON THE
BILL [inaudible] ONE LAW.
THEY'LL THEY'LL PRESENT --
ALTHOUGH THEY'LL SEND THEIR
PRESENCE WIENER PRESENT.
WE HAVE LOST AT LEAST A QUORUM.
AND THE CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH THE ART THANKS FOR
YOU HELPING OUT TO OUR CENTER TO
JACKSON PRESENTING THIS BILL ON
HER BEHALF IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THIS.
BILL AND AND AND YOU'RE A LEADER
IN THE EFFORT OVERALL ANYWAY.
MOST QUALIFIED TO COMMENT NOW.
I WANNA TAKE MOMENT SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR HIS
INCREDIBLE WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
ON ALL ISSUES A WILDFIRE
RESPONSE IN PREVENTION --
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS BILL.
ENTER JACKSON UNDERSTANDS THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
DISCUSSION AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
SHE LOOKS FOR TO THAT AND DOES
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING HERE
SHE'S ALSO BEEN IMPACTED BY ONE
OF THE LARGEST FIRES INTERSTATES
HISTORY THAT'S THE THOMAS FIRE.
IS GOOD EFFORT COMES OUT OF
THOSE TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE SHE
SAID SHE IS PHí
WITNESS HERSELF.
IN A AND I WANT TO SAY THAT THIS
BILL STRATEGICALLY CRAFTED.
ON THE MOST SEVERE WILDFIRE
THREAT ZONES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- IN DOES NOT
PREVENT THE BUILDING OF NEW
HOUSING THAT FOCUSES ON NEW
STANDARDS.
CANDIDLY THAT ALL OF A SHOULD BE
MEETING WHEN IT COMES TO KEEPING
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I DON'T
I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU.
TO OUR C. R. C. FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL.
THAT.
AND FOR THE SAME REASON IN GOOD
FAITH I WILL VOTE FOR THE BILL
TODAY KNOWING IT'S WORKING
PROCESS IN THE AUTHOR IT WILL
WORK WITH ALL OF US AND IN GOOD
FAITH.
AND WE ALL WORKING TOGETHER FOR
A COMMON PURPOSE WOULD YOU CHECK
WE HAVE A MOTION.
DO PASSED THE UNDERDEVELOPED AND
NOW WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
YEAH.
BIRD BOTTLES YELTSIN I HI OKAY
HOW MANY WHO HAVE. FOUR TWO ZERO
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR FORBEARANCE
[inaudible]
HAVEN'T.
WHEN I SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
SENATOR PORTANTINO? FOR HIS
INCREDIBLE PATIENTS HERE TODAY
WE'VE TO BILLS BY CENTER
PORTANTINO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
FIFTEEN AS WELL AS ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB -- FIVE THIRTY TWO
SOMEONE TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO CENTER NIELSEN.
FOR HIS WORK AND DURING THE
COMMITTEES IN PORTANTINO WE'LL
START WITH ITEM THREE ROLLED
ITEM FOURTEEN AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
APOLOGIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS -- TODAY AND
PRESENTING SB FIFTEEN AND I WANT
TO THANK -- SENATOR BELL AND THE
CHAIR -- FOR WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY ON THE REDEVELOPMENT
ISSUE -- AS YOU ALL KNOW -- I
HAVE THE BATTLE SCARS. TO PROVE
IT OF WHEN WE REMOVED
REDEVELOPMENT.
AS A TOOL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
TOOL AND A FUNDING SOURCE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BACK WHEN.
I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
I SAID THEN HOW DO YOU DO AWAY
WITH A STATES ONLY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
PLAN WITHOUT HAVING A
REPLACEMENTS THAT WE NEEDED TO
HAVE A REPLACEMENT IN PLACE
BEFORE WE DID AWAY WITH THAT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY AT THE TIME
THOSE COMMENTS FELL.
ON WITH SILENCE HAS RESPONSES
JUST PUT IT THAT WAY AND SO
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB FIFTEEN
AND I MADE A COMMITMENT TO THE
CHAIR THAT WE WOULD.
CONTINUE TO WORK -- AS HOPEFULLY
THIS PROGRESSES TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT I'VE DONE IS
I'VE REACHED OUT TO THE CITIES
IN MY AREA.
THAT ALL HAD ACTIVE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN
PARTICULAR PASADENA BURBANK
GLENDALE MONROVIA GLENDORA.
AND I'VE ASKED THEM TO PROVIDE
INPUT TO WHICH I AGAIN COMMITTED
TO BOTH MISTER BELL AND THE
CHAIR THAT I WOULD BE SHARING
THOSE WRITTEN COMMENTS -- WITH
THE TWO OF YOU SO YOU CAN SEE
WHAT MY CITIES ARE THINKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND SO I'D LOVE THIS BILL TO
PROGRESS TODAY -- WHICH ALLOWS A
CITY OR COUNTY FOR A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY -- TO SUBMIT A
REQUEST THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RECEIVE A PORTION OF THE
COUNTIES -- E. RAF -- TO MEET
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS -- I DON'T
ANTICIPATE THAT THAT WOULD BE
THE FINAL VERSION OF THIS BILL
BUT I DO WANT TO KEEP.
KEEP THIS MOVING SO WE CAN
FURTHER THAT CONVERSATION AND AT
THE CHAIR AND I SPOKE LAST WEEK
--
I THINK WE'RE ALL GOING TO COME
TO A MEETING OF THE MINDS SAYS
AS THESE PROGRESS SO -- THAT'S
MY STORY -- AND I HATE TO SAY I
WAS RIGHT BACK THEN BUT HERE WE
ARE A DECADE LATER STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
A REPLACEMENT PLAN AND STILL
TALKING ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND I KNOW -- CERTAINLY MISTER
BELL IS DEDICATED HIS HIS LIFE
IN PUBLIC SERVICE TO TRY TO HELP
ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SO.
I AM PLEASED THAT THERE SO MUCH
FOCUS AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ON SB FIFTEEN NOT VERY GRATEFUL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
I'LL HAVE A FEW QUICK COMMENTS
AND DO APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION TO SENATOR AND I
ASSUME YOU'RE GONNA TAKE IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS WELL
ABSOLUTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NOW WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME FOLKS WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TOOK PLACE
AT YOUR FIRST AND LAST
ORGANIZATION.
MR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE DON'T HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION ON THIS BILL
YET BUT WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF MOVING THIS BILL OUT CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION.
NUMBER SUPPORTING SB FIVE WHICH
IS A SIMILAR BILL AMID THE
REALLY APPRECIATE CENTER
PORTANTINO I'M FIGHTING FOR HIS
CITIES AND TRYING TO TO BRING
BACK THAT PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
HAD WITH THE STATE MUCH LIKE WE
DIDN'T SB FIVE AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE.
FINAL CALL FOR THOSE MAYES WHO
MAY BE IN SUPPORT.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BE A GOOD
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FOR THIS TIME.
WHY HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS
SOMEONE'S SECONDARY WITNESS?
PRIMARY WITNESS HAS FIVE MINUTES
SECONDARY HAS.
TO WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE
GOOD MORNING.
ALMOST AFTERNOON.
GET IN THERE ALMOST ALL RIGHT IF
YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR FIRST LAST
ORGANIZATION YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES I THANK YOU JENNIFER
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION -- WE
UNFORTUNATELY DO HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION ON SB FIFTEEN AND MUCH
LIKE WE COMMUNICATED WITH
SIMILAR BILLS -- AS T. TA DOES
OPPOSE THE USE OF THE RAF FUND
SAID IT IS IT PUTS HER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN A VERY VULNERABLE
POSITION WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THIS MEASURE AS WELL
AS SIMILAR MILLER MEASURES THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS HEARD
RECENTLY.
I DO ATTEMPT TO TRY TO PROTECT
EDUCATION FUNDING BY PROVIDING
THAT BACK FEEL IN GOOD YEARS
THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM NECESSARILY
WHAT WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT IS IF
WE GO INTO ANOTHER ECONOMIC
DECLINE -- AND WE ARE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THE GENERAL FUND
IS UNDER SUCH PRESSURE THAT THAT
GENERAL FUND MAY NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO BACK FILL AND WE'RE
IN A SITUATION WE MAY LOOK AT
PROP.
ON NINETY EIGHT BEING SUSPENDED
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND WE HOPE
THAT AT THE LEAD AS THE
LEGISLATURE PONTIFICATES ON THE
BEST WAY. TO TRY TO AMEND AND
TRY TO HELP OUR CALIFORNIANS
DEALING WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT WE CAN BE ASSURED THAT THAT
WON'T BE ON THE BACKS OF OUR
KIDS AND EDUCATION THANK YOU --
WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME ANYONE ELSE
WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS
TIME OPPOSITION.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND
LAST AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
THANK YOU ANTHONY TIME HOW WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE OPPOSED TO IT AS IT IS IN
PRINT AND WITH THESE AMENDMENTS
WOULD BE MOVING TO MITCHELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING NANCY TRIED ASSISTING US
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING WE
OPPOSE THE THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THE BILL.
BUT WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR WE APPRECIATE THE INTENT
TO HOLD EDUCATION HARMLESS AND
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO
WORKING OUT THE TECHNICALITIES
TO MAKE SURE THE BILL ACTUALLY
CHIEF THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND TODAY ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES A
CALIFORNIA.
WE WERE OPPOSED TO THE PREVIOUS
FOR OR THE EXISTING BILL AND
PLANT -- WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR CONCERNS AND AS
THE BILL IS TO BE AMENDED -- WE
WILL BE REMOVING OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE LIKE TO BE ADDED TO LAST CALL
FOR OPPOSITION LAST CALL PLEASE
ADVANCE.
WITH A GREATER BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SURE.
ALL RIGHT UP FOR SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH --
DISTANT CENTER PORTANTINO FOR
ITS COLLABORATION ON THIS ISSUE.
CENTER PORTANTINO'S ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT -- IN HIS TIME IN THE
ASSEMBLY -- HE FACED A BRUISING
FIGHT -- A AND WAS THE ONLY ONE
THAT OPPOSED -- THE DISSOLUTION
--
AND HE'S BEEN VERY CLEAR
ABOUT-HIS PASSION TO BE ABLE TO
WORK
IN THIS SPACE.
CENTER VALLEY NIGHT OVER THE
PAST GOING ON A YEAR NOW HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON SENATE BILL FIVE
IN.
CANDIDLY SENATE AS CENTER BELL
HAS BEEN THE LEAD ON ALL ISSUES
--
CENTER AND SENATE ILL FIVE AND
VERY GRATEFUL FOR ALL THESE
WORKING.
THE OUTCOME OF SENATE BILL FIVE
IN WHICH IS CURRENTLY IN PRINT
TO DATE.
WHAT IS -- DRAFTED AFTER A LOT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT MULTIPLE
PUBLIC MEETINGS -- IN HEARINGS.
AND WE WANT TO RESPECT THE GOOD
SENATORS.
REQUEST TO BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE
TIME TO WORK WITH THE CITY'S IN
HIS DISTRICT. TO BE ABLE TO
FLESH OUT.
WHAT A FINAL PRODUCT MAY BE?
AND AS A SENATOR AND SAID CENTER
BELL AND I ARE COMMITTED TO BE
TO WORK WITH CENTER PORTANTINO
TO BE A TO COME TOGETHER.
PRIOR TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS AND WHAT WE WOULD HOPE
IS DEVELOP A SOLUTION THAT WORKS
FOR CENTER PORTANTINO CENTER
BELL IN MYSELF AND I THINK THAT
YOU HAVE A THREE WAY COMMITMENT
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND WORKING WITH THE SENATOR ON
THESE AMENDMENTS AS WELL WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
LET'S TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOR CLOTHES.
NO I THINK IT'S EXCITING THAT
THERE'S SO MUCH FOCUS ON THIS
ISSUE AND YOU KNOW I THINK
YOU'RE A 100% CORRECT -- MISTER
BELL HAS BEEN A HARD CHARGER ON
THIS AND IT'S EXCITING TO SEE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU DO WE HAVE
A MOTION TO PASS A DO PASSED A
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
BALANCE IN ABOUT JUST WANNA
RECOGNIZE YOU AGAIN SIR FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK.
HEY ABSOLUTELY WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THIS HAS A DO PASSED AT
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE MOTION BY
SEN ABOUT MISS LANCASTER.
ROLL CALL PLEASE QUIET BY WHY
I'M MORE LONG THEY'LL.
THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG RICARDO
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A TWO ZERO IN
ON A HOUSEKEEPING NOTE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKING IN
HOUSING FOR TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN.
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN ON ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN THIS IS SB FIVE
THIRTY TWO MISTER PORTANTINO.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DON'T
HAVE A NUMBER OF FOLKS ARE GOING
TO COME UP AND JOIN ME.
I THINK I HAVE THE ENTIRE CITY
OF GLENDALE HERE [inaudible]
WELCOME GLENDALE.
WITH THE MAYOR IS HERE.
AND I'M NOT GONNA ASK YOU ABOUT
YOUR MOTHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB
FIVE THREE TWO AND I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE -- THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE CITY OF
GLENDALE AND IT'S APROPOS THAT
WE JUST HAD A DISCUSSION ON
REDEVELOPMENT BECAUSE THAT IS
GERMANE -- TO SB FIVE THIRTY TWO
AS WELL THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE GLENDALE TO USE THE
REMAINING BOND PROCEEDS FROM
THEIR TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
SUBORDINATE TAXABLE TAX
ALLOCATION BOND. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF INCREASING -- AND IMPROVING
AND PRESERVING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I'M TOLD THAT IF THIS
BILL PASSES WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY AND THREE HUNDRED ACTUAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
COMING TO THE CITY OF GLENDALE
THAT'S EXCITING BECAUSE IT'S NOT
THEORY IT WOULD BE PRACTICE IF
WE CAN -- PASS THIS BILL.
THE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN BUDGET
ACT APPROVAL WAS GRANTED
DISSOLVING THE STATE'S FOUR
HUNDRED PLUS REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES -- AND FOR THE RECORD I
OPPOSE THAT THESE AGENCY SERVES
AS AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
REDEVELOPMENT PROVIDED THE
LARGEST ONGOING SOURCE.
OF REVENUE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA AS LOCAL
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES PROVIDED
ROUGHLY ONE BILLION ANNUALLY.
FOR FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
CLOSURE OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
THE REMOVAL OF FINANCING FOR
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
NEW FOR ALL HOUSING UNITS AS
WELL AS FINANCING STRUCTURES AND
INCENTIVES. FOR DEVELOPMENT
STATEWIDE AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL
HOUSING PRODUCTION HAS NOT KEPT
PACE WITH THE INCREASING DEMAND
WILD DWINDLING INCOMES IN
REVENUE SOURCES HAVE COMPOUNDED
THE PROBLEM.
GLENDALE HAS A TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN SUBORDINATE TAXABLE
ALLOCATION BOND AND IN THE
AMOUNT OF APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
WHICH IS CURRENTLY CLASSIFIED AS
NON HOUSING DOLLARS FROM THE
CENTRAL GLENDALE REDEVELOPMENT
PROJECT AREA THAT IT IS
PREVENTED. TO UTILIZE BY THE
STATE BECAUSE IT'S NOT ALLOWED
UNDER THE DISSOLUTION
REDEVELOPMENT ACT.
RATHER THAN DE FEES OR CANCEL
THIS BOND GLENDALE REQUESTS
RESPECTIVELY TO DELEGATE IT
TOWARDS A 100%. FOR DOUBLE
HOUSING PURPOSES SO HERE'S A
CITY THAT WANTS TO TAKE TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S IN
LIMBO AND USE IT FOR A 100% OF
IT. FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PURPOSES I BELIEVE THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO LEVERAGE THIS TO EVEN
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITY. FIVE
NEVER GET ONE TIME SOLE SOURCE
OF FUNDS WHICH WOULD BE LOCALLY
CONTROLLED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THESE REDEVELOPMENT BONDS ARE
SETTING SITTING ON UTILIZED.
AND GLENDALE HAS MORE TO GAIN BY
COMMITTING THIS MONEY TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RATHER THAN
LETTING THE BONDS.
BE CANCELED WITH ME TODAY I AM
PROUD TO INTRODUCE THE PROUD
MAYOR OF GLENDALE ARE IN THE JAR
IN AND A NUMBER OF CITY STAFF
AND SO IF I GET HAVE THEM SPEAK
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME.
ABSOLUTELY WE TYPICALLY HAVE THE
I TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORTED TWO
MINUTES EACH MISTER MAYOR
OBVIOUSLY WILL GIVE YOU SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME WE WELCOME YOU
IN GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORKING
YOU'RE VERY LUCKY TO HAVE.
CENTER PORTANTINO REPRESENTS.
YES WE ARE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I'VE SERVED THREE
TERMS AS THE CITY'S HOUSING
AUTHORITY.
SO I KNOW OF WHICH I SPEAK AT
LEAST FOR THE CITY OF GLENDALE.
A GLENDALE TAKES ITS COMMITMENT
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SERIOUSLY WE BELIEVE IT IS OUR
OBLIGATION OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AND OUR DUTY TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHENEVER WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
AND IN THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS WE
HAVE CREATED A CLOSE TO SEVEN
HUNDRED AFFORDABLE UNITS. FOR
SENIORS FOR FAMILIES FOR VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FOR
VETERANS THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE GEARED UP TO DO WITH OUR
HOUSING AUTHORITY WITH OUR
DEDICATED STAFF.
WHO HAVE IDENTIFIED LOCATIONS
WITHIN THE CITY WHERE?
A FORMAL HOUSING MAKES THE BEST
SENSE THESE ARE PROJECTS THESE
ARE PIECES OF LAND THAT ARE NEAR
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION NEAR
SCHOOLS.
AND YOUR SHOPPING THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF AS A CITY THAT WE HAVE A
COMMITMENT. TO THIS.
THE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
WE WOULD.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT -- THE
COMMITTEE THE SENATE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT PERMIT US
TO USE THAT.
AND WITH THAT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION WE CAN LEVERAGE THAT AS
THE AS OUR GREAT STATE SENATOR
INDICATED. TO ABOUT EIGHTY
MILLION THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS
WITH PRIVATE COMPANIES WHOM WE
HAVE WORKED WITH THROUGH THE
YEARS WHO ARE -- RESPONSIBLE
SERIOUS AND DEDICATED TO
PROVIDING SAFE CLEAN AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. TO OUR
RESIDENTS.
IT'S IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON ON A DAILY
BASIS CREATING -- NEW COMMUNITY
PLANS WHERE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS ENCOURAGED AND IT IS
INCORPORATED IN OUR HOUSING
STRATEGY.
THAT WE HAVE -- ON THE
BOOKS-RIGHT NOW.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT -- THAT WE
WOULDN'T USE THAT MONEY ANY
OTHER WAY IF SOMEONE WERE TO SAY
HERE'S TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS GLENDALE.
DO WITH IT AS YOU WISH I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT OUR COUNCIL OUR
STAFF ARE CITY MANAGER.
TAKE THIS COMMITMENT SERIOUSLY
AND WE WOULDN'T USE IT FOR ANY
OTHER WAY PARKS SCHOOLS
LIBRARIES IT WOULD GO TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT'S A
CRISIS.
THAT GLENDALE HAS NOT ESCAPED --
AND WE DEFINITELY WANT TO SERVE
OUR RESIDENTS AND THOSE
LESS-FORTUNATE WHO NEED THIS TYPE
OF
HOUSING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMERICAN
WE'RE GRATEFUL HE TRAVELED AT
THIS FAR TO BE TO BE WITH US
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ELOQUENT TESTIMONY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK SIR.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU WE LIKE TO
GO TO SEE IF ANYONE ELSE FROM
LINDA WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
SPEAK.
IF TO ANSWER AS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
PHILLIP LANDS OF FAME AND THE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THAT OVERSEES
HOUSING -- I AM ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY I AM HERE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE AS WELL WE
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN UP TO
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE.
YOUR COMMENTS FIRST LAST
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION
SUPPORTER MEMBERS MAX PERRY WITH
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH ALSO IN
SUPPORT I THINK THEY CAN IS VERY
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
JILLIAN VAN MINE WITH THE CITY
OF GLENDALE CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE HERE WITH THE TEAM.
OBVIOUSLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD TO SEE YOU GOOD MORNING
STRENGTH MR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT ON GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MALLORY SPOKE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU LIKE ME TO DO A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL LAST CALL.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE
THERE ARE ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS
TIME.
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION CENTER
MORLOCK IS BEING IN PEOPLE IN
THE HEAD WITH THE DOOR.
WELCOME MORE LOCKED.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON SIR WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO JOIN US WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BE ABLE -- TO I'D SAY
YOUR PIECE AT THE MICROPHONE --
THIS IS THIS WE GREAT CHAIRMAN I
ANTHONY KENNEL CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED THE BILL AS IN PRINT.
LOOK FORWARD TO RE EVALUATING
AFTER THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
SO MUCH GRATEFUL.
WELCOME BACK.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY LIKE THE PREVIOUS
BILL WE WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS IT WAS INTRODUCED.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE WILL BE
REMOVED IN OPPOSITION THANKS SO
MUCH TO SENATOR VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR WILL
ALSO TAKE A MOTION AS WELL.
THE SYSTEM PLEASE CENTER OF LA
COUNTY THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
OF THE A PINT ON THIS BILL.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO IDEA OKAY I
DON'T BELIEVE SO [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE BILL ALRIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION -- BY CENTER BELL THAT
MOTION IS A DO PASSED THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE YOU
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BEFORE WE
GO TO THE GOOD SENATORS CLOSE.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEES CENTER
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AGAIN THIS IS AN
EXCITING.
OPPORTUNITY TO USE TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS DIRECTLY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LEVERAGE IT
TO CREATE ACTUAL UNITS AND WE
DIDN'T MENTION BUT I HAVE TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO GLENDALE OF
ALL THE CITIES IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY THE MOST ACTIVE
WITH HABITAT FOR HUMANITY -- IN
ADDITION TO THEIR OTHER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING EFFORTS HAS
BEEN THE CITY OF GLENDALE AND WE
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
GONNA.
GIVE THE KEYS TO THE CURRENT
PROJECT AND START A NEW ONE
RIGHT AWAY SO THIS IS A CITY
THAT REALLY DOES WORK HARD.
ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND IS A
MODEL -- AND WAS A MODEL FOR
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES BACK --
WHEN THEY WERE TAKEN AWAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE?
PORTANTINO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALL OF YOUR WORK MISTER MAYOR
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE.
AND THAT WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU THE ENTIRE GLENDALE TEAM UP
FOR COMING UP AND KEEP IN
SOUTHWEST IN BUSINESS TODAY.
SO -- VERY VERY GRATEFUL -- WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER BALANCE IS DUE PASSED A
HOUSING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE TAKEN IN HOUSING IS
LANCASTER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI WHY I'D LAW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HELLO.
THOSE AS WELL WIENER.
VERY EASY.
TO TO THIS IS A BILL OPEN TO BE
ABLE TO ADD ONS AND PORTANTINO
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TEAM FOR GLENDALE THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOT GONNA WELCOME.
CENTER MONEY TO BE ABLE TO COME
FORWARD CENTER MONEY AND I AM
GOING TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR.
I HAVE TO GO VOTE BRIEFLY IN
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND I APOLOGIZE
WE WELCOME VICE CHAIR MORE
LOCKED TO COMMITTEE.
MISTER VICE CHAIR I'M PASSING
GAVEL TO YOU I'LL BE BACK
MOMENTARILY AFTER I GO IN VOTE
AND WE'RE MOVING ON TO SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU
CENTER MONEY FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
IT'S A MY PLEASURE TO PRESENT TO
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY NINE THIS
MORNING I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
AS OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS.
HOUSE ONE OFFER A HEARTFELT
THANK YOU TO CONSULTANT JONATHAN
PETERSON FOR THE TIME HE IS
DEVOTED TO THIS ISSUE.
IT'S MUCH APPRECIATED.
SINCE ITS ESTABLISHMENT IN
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN THE FORT HOOD
MILITARY BASE HAS BEEN AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE MONTEREY
BAY REGIONS ECONOMY.
WHEN THE BASE CLOSED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED THE FORT
ORD REDUCE THE THORNY OR FOR A?
TO CARRY OUT THE PLANNING
FINANCING MANAGEMENT THE FORMER
FORT ORD FACILITY AS DESCRIBED
IN THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN RE
USE PLAN.
DUE TO AN ECONOMIC RECESSION FOR
STRUGGLE TO EXECUTE THE BASE
REDUCE PLAN.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED MY ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
FOURTEEN WHICH EXTENDED THE
SUNSET DATE OF FOR A FROM JUNE.
THIRTY TWENTY FOURTEEN TO JUNE.
THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRED FOR TO DEVELOP THE
TRANSITION PLAN FOR ALL
OUTSTANDING OBLIGATIONS.
THE FOUR BOARD HAS NOW APPROVED
A TRANSITION PLAN IN THIS
NEGOTIATING IMPLEMENTING
AGREEMENTS FOR WATER
AUGMENTATION TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION.
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS AND
LOCAL FUNDING MECHANISMS TO
SUPPORT THESE ACTIVITIES. FOR
NEEDS TO ADDITIONAL YEARS TO
ALLOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT ADEQUATE FUNDING
MECHANISMS TO SUPPORT PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED IN THE FOR TRANSITION
PLAN AS WELL AS TO ENSURE
CONTRACTS ARE ESTABLISHED. FOR
ALL TRANSITION PLANNING
IMPLEMENTING AGREEMENTS.
SB ONE EIGHTY NINE NARROWS THE
JURISDICTIONAL OVERSIGHT OF THE
FOR A BOARD AS WELL AS REDUCES
THE NUMBER OF BOARD MEMBERS
FROM.
THIRTEEN TO FIVE THE BOARD WILL
CONTINUE TO COLLECT REVENUES AND
EXECUTE THE FOR TRANSITION PLAN
UNTIL JUNE THIRTY TWENTY TWO TWO
TWO WHEN THE BOARD WILL SUNSET.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF FOR A HAVE
ADEQUATE FUNDING MECHANISMS TO
ACHIEVE THE REGIONAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
THAT WAS PROMISED WHEN THE
AUTHORITY WAS ESTABLISHED.
MEMBERS WE ARE WORKING HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PATH FORWARD
BENEFITS THE MONTEREY BAY REGION
AND IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
OBJECTIVES OF THE BASE RE USE
PLAN.
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME LIKE 2%.
I HAVE MICHAEL WHOM ARE WITH ME
AS A TECHNICAL.
ASSISTANCE WITNESS.
HE SERVES AS EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE FORT ORD RE USE A THORNY.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
--
I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND SPEND A FEW
MOMENTS JUST TO GIVE YOU A QUICK
OUTLINE.
OF OUR ROLE HERE AT THE FORMER
FORT ORD AS YOU PROBABLY ALL
AWARE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUFFERED
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF LOSSES
AS ACONSEQUENCE.
OF THE BASE REALIGNMENT AND
CLOSURE PROCESS THAT REALLY
BEGAN OVER. THIRTY YEARS AGO AND
REALLY TOOK FEET IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE WHEN FORD WAS CLOSE
THIS IS THE LARGEST UNITED
STATES ARMY CLOSURE IN HISTORY.
AND IT IS A VERY DIFFICULT TASK
IS THE PROPERTY LARGER THAN THE
COUNTY TO OF SAN FRANCISCO.
SB ONE EIGHT NINE SETS UP A
MEANS FOR THE REGION OF MODERATE
TO CONTINUE. TO HAVE A CENTRAL
RESOURCES THAT WOULD COMPLETE
THE BASE FOR USE PLAN MISSION.
IT ENABLES A SMOOTH TRANSITION
TO THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHO
ARE TAKING OVER.
INDIVIDUAL COMPONENTS OF WHAT WE
DO. FOR THESE REASONS AND MANY
OTHERS SOME WILL THINK THAT THIS
SHOULD BE LARGE LONGER OR
SHORTER.
BUT HOWEVER THIS BILL ITSELF
WILL MAKE SURE THAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE CENTRAL COAST
WILL STILL BE ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM ITS ORIGINAL ADOPTION THE
BASE REUSE PLAN IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES.
AGAIN I WANT TO ACT EXTEND MY
COMMENTS IN APPRECIATION FOR
SENATOR MINING'S INTRODUCTION OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE THE FOLKS IN
THE JURISDICTIONS OF THE
MONTEREY BAY WILL NEED THIS IN
ORDER TO COMPLETE THEIR WORK SO
I AM HERE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS OR RESPONSES.
THE ITEMS IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SHE WOULD LIKE
YOU TO SEE IF WE HAVE A SECOND
TO SECONDARY WITNESS YOUR TWO
MINUTES OF STILL [inaudible]
YES PLEASE. TO ANSWER AND IF YOU
COULD JUST INTRODUCE YOURSELF AN
ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JOHN GODLY I AM A COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF DEL REY
OAKS.
AND THE CITY'S -- FORT ORD RE
USE OF THE ALREADY BOARD MEMBER
DORY OAKS IS -- SMALL
RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITY OF SIXTEEN
HUNDRED RESIDENTS IN THE SUN
BELT OF MONTEREY PENINSULA.
OF THE TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
ACRES OF THE FORMER FORD OR DEL
REY OAKS ALLOCATION IS ROUGHLY
THREE HUNDRED FORTY ACRES
EFFECTIVELY DOUBLING THE SIZE OF
OUR SMALL CITY.
WORK FORCE IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ARE MAJOR ISSUES FOR DORY OAKS
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S EMPHASIS ON
SOLVING THIS CRISIS STATEWIDE.
DEL RIO TEXAS.
IN THE FIRST TIME IN THIRTY
YEARS IS ACTIVELY UPDATING
HOUSING ELEMENT OF ITS GENERAL
PLAN.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR FORD OR
PROPERTY WILL ALLOW US THE SMALL
COMMUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
STATE'S EFFORT TO SOLVING
HOUSING CRISIS IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY. TO REALIZE THIS GOAL IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT WE RETAIN A
REGIONAL HABITAT PROTECTION
ENSURE A STABLE WATER SUPPLY AND
HAVE THE ABILITY TO COLLECT
COMMUNITY FACILITIES DISTRICT
FEES TO FUND THOSE REGIONAL
NEEDS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE DOOR
ELKS AND MONTEREY WAITED UNTIL
THE JURISDICTIONS WERE MORE
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY FORWARDS
CLOSURE.
AND WE'RE ALLOWED TO
REDEVELOPMENT REDEVELOP FIRST TO
STABILIZE THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
THEIR THEIR RESIDENTS.
BY ALL MANNERS THOSE COMMUNITIES
ARE HEALTHIER NOW AND HRIVING
DUE TO OPPORTUNITIES IN
ASSISTANCE OF THE FOR A DEL RIO
TO MONTEREY HAVE A MORE FOCUSED
COOL ADDRESSING THOSE.
HOW ARE HOUSING AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES BUT STRONGLY
FEEL THE EXTENSION OF THE
COMMUNITY FACILITIES DISTRICT IS
ONLY EQUITABLE TO ALLOWING US
THE REGIONAL ASSISTANCE AFFORD
TO MARINE AND SEASIDE?
DORIAL TO SUPPORT OF OF THE
DIRECTION OF THIS BE ONE EIGHTY
NINE TO LOOK FORWARD O WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR AND HIS STAFF.
AS THE BILL MOVES FOR THE
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU KANSEN WE ONE
TECHNOLOGY SAY THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE ALONG
WITH CENTER MONEY WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE HERE CENTER MONEY.
YOU'VE BEEN A CHAMPION ON THIS
ISSUE FOR MANY MANY YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
ALL YOUR WORK AND HAPPIER IN
COMMITTEE.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO GET OPENING
UP TO ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE.
ADVANCE TO THE MICROPHONE THIS
TIME.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
NOT GONNA BE TURNED OVER TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE PLEASE
ADVANCE.
HEARING TINO OPPOSITION WE KNOW
THAT TO BE HERE AND BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTION TO APPROVE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
[inaudible]
CLOSING OPINION. ONE OF SURPLUS
WE WELCOME YOU TO THE TABLE HERE
OR DRAMA.
OUR SYSTEM HEY DOING SIR.
HE DOES INTRODUCE YOURSELF
PLEASE FIRST LAST ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU FOR SOURCE I'M CITY
MANAGER OF REMEMBER MY NAME'S
LANE LONG I'VE BEEN A MARINA
SINCE -- TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN I
APOLOGIZE TO MAYOR WAS NOT ABLE
TO BE HERE HE'S AT THE A CULTURE
COMMISSION HEARING TODAY AND SO
I'M HERE REPRESENTING HIM AND
OUR CITY COUNCIL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SOME MAJOR
BOMB.
AT OF ALL THE COMMITTEES THAT
ARE -- IN THE FORMER FORT ORD
PROPERTY HANG IN THERE ELKS IS
HERE IN MONTEREY IN SEASIDE AND
AND SALINAS AND ALL THE **** AND
ENTITIES.
READ IS THE ONLY ONE THAT IS
SUPPOSED IN THIS BILL AND SO THE
ASK YOU WHY ARE WE OPPOSE IN
THIS BILL.
AND THE REASON IS BECAUSE WE ARE
AFFECTED AND IMPACTED AND BIRD
AND A FAR MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY -- IN THE REGION AND
THE CONTINUATION OF FOR
CONTINUES TO SEVERELY CAN'T
HAMPER IN BURDEN OUR CITY --
WHEN FOR WAS FIRST CONTINUED IN?
TWENTY FOURTEEN HI.
THE DEAL WAS IS CONSENSUS TWENTY
TWENTY IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT
FOR STARTED MEETING IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN FORM TO
TRANSITION TASK FORCE MET. SIX
SEVEN TIMES.
AND THEN ON NOVEMBER FOURTH
TWENTY SIXTEEN THEY MADE A
PRESENTATION TO THE BOARD AND
THE PRESENTATION WAS -- THEY
WANT TO INITIATE A LEGISLATIVE
MA'AM PROCESS THAT WOULD EXTEND.
FOR THREE TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
THE GOAL HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO
CONTINUE TO EXTEND FLORA.
AND THAT CONTINUES THE THE
PROBLEM AND THE BURDENS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND AND WHILE WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
THAT THE BILL BEFORE YOU RIGHT
NOW IS ONLY A TWO YEAR EXTENSION
WE ARE COMFORTABLE THAT THEY ARE
NOT GONNA BE BACK AGAIN ONE TWO
EXTENDED AGAIN.
AND THEN EVEN THE TWO YEARS WE
HAVE SEVERE PROBLEMS WITH THAT
--
IT WE SEVERELY -- RIGHT.
IT'S A CHALLENGE FOR US TO
OPPOSE SOMETHING CEREMONY IS
INTRODUCING HE HAS BEEN A HUGE
ADVOCATE FOR REACHING HE'S BEEN
A HUGE SUPPORT.
FOR MARINA BUT WE HAVE SOME
REALLY PROBLEMS WITH THIS BILL.
AND THE REASON THAT WE OPPOSE IT
NUMBER ONE PRIMARILY IS WE HAVE
AN ALTERNATE TRANSITION PLAN --
THAT INSURERS.
THE THE GAP FUNDING.
THE REGIONAL PROJECTS.
ALL THE OBLIGATIONS THE INTIMATE
AGREEMENTS THOSE CAN ALL BE MAD
AT TRANSITION PLAN WE'VE
SUBMITTED TO LAUGH COAL WE HAVE
SUBMIT TO REGIONAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES WHO HAS BEEN HIRED BY.
FOR TO HELP WITH THIS TRANSITION
PROCESS AND THEY HAVE ALL SAID
THIS TRANSITION PLAN -- MEETS
THESE NEEDS IT WORKS AND FOR
CONSENT SAID IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND WE CAN MEET ALL THESE
OBLIGATIONS AND ALWAYS FUNNY
REQUIREMENTS SO WE DO HAVE A
TRANSITION PLAN THAT WILL WORK
THAT WILL OUT TO SUNSET.
THE OTHER PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE EXTENSION OF FOUR GETS
BACK -- TO SOME OF THE STATE
LEGISLATIVE.
ACTS THAT IT CONFLICTS WITHIN IT
ALTERS ONE IS THE REDEVELOPMENT
LOCK. FOR EXAMPLE 35% OF ALL
PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT CURRENTLY
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
CONTINUES TO FLOW TO FOR A
DESPITE THE DISSOLUTION OF THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SB ONE
EIGHTY NINE CONTINUES THE
PREFERENTIAL TAX INCOME MEANT
THREE JUNE TWENTY TWENTY OR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND EXPRESSLY
AUTHORIZES THE FOUR BOARD TO
ENCUMBER TAX INCREMENT FOR
DECADES INTO THE FUTURE.
WITHOUT RESTRICTIONS ON THE USE.
REDEVELOPMENT SUCCESSOR AGENCIES
ARE LIMITED IN THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENDITURES UP
OF UP TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR HAS NO
LIMIT FOR HAS NO OVERSIGHT.
THE CURRENT BUDGET FOR ALLOCATES
ONE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT TAX INCOME AND FOR THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENDITURES THE
EXTENSION OF FOUR CONTINUES.
THE DIVERSION OF TAXING IN
COMMAND THE GIRLS HE OTHER TEXAN
ENTITIES TO SCHOOLS TO RURAL
FIRE DISTRICTS -- IF WE EXTEND
THIS BE ON TWENTY TWENTY IT WILL
CONTINUE TO TO DIVERT THAT TAX
INCREMENT.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT -- SB ONE
EIGHTY NINE REALLY CONFLICTS
WITH THE MALE WRIST Là AND I
REDEVELOPMENT ATTORNEY DOES THAT
AND SO.
I CAN GIVE YOU A LOT OF DETAILS
ON THAT.
BUT THE THIRD REASON HAD IT
REALLY IS A PRIMARY REASON THAT
WERE OPPOSING THIS IF TO
MINISTER.
IS IT CONTINUES TO CRIPPLE OUR
COMMUNITY IN TWO PRIMARY AREAS
BLIGHT.
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IT'S BEEN ALMOST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS SINCE FORT ORD CLOSED IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AND A
MARINA THE BULK OF THE BLIGHT
STILL EXIST WE HAVE SIX HUNDRED
pMILITARY.
BARRACKS IN OUR CITIES THE
SURROUND HER HIGH SCHOOL OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
I'M SEE ISSUE AND BE EACH OF
THESE BLIGHTED STRUCTURES ARE
FULL OF HAZARDOUS LEADING
ASBESTOS THE ENTRANCE FOR HIGH
SCHOOL GOALS FOR THIS BLIGHTED
NEIGHBORHOOD KIDS WALK THROUGHS
BLIGHTED NEIGHBORHOOD.
KIDS CLIMB OVER OUR FENCES INTO
THESE BLIGHTED HOMES FULL OF
HAZARDOUS LEAD NASS BESTEST
HOMELESS PEOPLE LIVE NEEDS
BLIGHTED HOMES.
THERE IS NO.
STRUCTURE OR FUNDING MECHANISM.
OR THE OTHER PARTIES HAVE KEPT
THE SIX HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
BLIGHTED HOMES FROM BEING TAKEN
DOWN THAT IS A HUGE PROBLEM OR
CITY IN THE CONTINUATION OF FOUR
DOES NOT ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM.
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT WE'VE
HEARD WE HAVE A HIGH HOUSING
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS INNER CITY.
FOURS POLICIES HAMPER ABILITY TO
ADDRESS.
AFFORDABLE IN WORKING CLASS
HOUSING THE DEVELOPMENTS THAT
ARE MOVING FORTNER CITY ENTRY
LEVEL HOUSING.
IS ALMOST A MILLION DOLLARS WE
HAVE.
A TWO HUNDRED ACRE DEVELOPMENT
THAT IS SITTING VACANT TUNING
THIRTY TWO BLIGHTED HOMES
ADJACENT TO THE OCEAN.
AND DEVELOPERS A COME IN THEY
WANT TO START BUILDING THOSE
HOMES AT EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT'S WHERE CANCELS OUT
BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES IN THE
OBLIGATIONS THE CONSTRAINTS PUT
ON US BY THE FOUR DEGREES ACT.
OUR COUNCIL SAID NO BECAUSE WE
WANT TO KEEP THAT PROPERTY OPEN
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SO AS
LONG AS FOR EXIST WE CANNOT PUT
THE PLAN AND THE MECHANISMS THE
FUNDING TOGETHER.
THAT ALLOWS TO BUILDAFFORDABLE
WORKING MIDDLE CLASS HOMES AND
SO IT WILL SIT THERE.
AND SO IN CONCLUSION.
WELL ANOTHER TWO YEARS MAY NOT
SEEM SIGNIFICANT IN IN THE
TWENTY SIX YEARS OF FOR HAS BEEN
EXISTENCE BUT THAT TWO YEARS.
IS SIGNIFICANT TO US IMPLIED
THAT TWO YEARS IS X. SIGNIFICANT
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- MARINA
AND THE CITY OF SEASIDE CITY
COUNCIL WE BOTH UNANIMOUS
UNANIMOUSLY OPPOSE THE EXTENSION
FOR THANK YOU.
SHE YOU BEING HERE TODAY AT
CENTER BELLS WITHDRAW THEM
WITHDRAW THE MOTION WILL CALL
FOR MOTION JUST A BIT WE'D LIKE
TO BE A TO GIVE CENTER MONEY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
MARINA HAS DONE IN CONVERSION OF
SOME OF THE FORMER MILITARY
BASE.
I WOULD REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT.
THE LEGISLATION IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY.
IS CONSISTENT WITH A VOTE TAKEN
BY THE FOR A BOARD FOR IS A
REGIONAL ENTITY.
IN THE DECISIONS IN TRANSITION
HAVE TO BE LOOKED AT AND NOT AS
THEY AFFECT ANY ONE INDIVIDUAL
JURISDICTION BUT OUR ENTIRE
REGION.
I WOULD SAY THAT THERE'S NOTHING
IN THIS BILL THAT PREVENTS
MARINA FOR MOVING FORWARD -- IN
TERMS OF ITS ABILITY TO CONTRACT
ITS ABILITY. TO IMPLEMENT
EXISTING OBLIGATIONS AND PLANTS
WE DO BELIEVE THERE'S A BENEFIT
TO THE PLANS TRANSITION THAT IS
IS DIRECTED. TO BENEFIT THE
ENTIRE REGION AND IN PROTECTING.
SOME OF THE COMMUNITY.
DEVELOPMENT FEENEY RESOURCES AND
PROPERTY TAX RESOURCES -- THAT
WILL BE DIRECTED BY THE REDUCED
ABOARD REDUCED OVERHEAD AND COST
AND REALLY PROVIDE A CONTINUUM
OF MOVING RESOURCES. TO THE MANY
JURISDICTIONS THAT STILL TOUCH
FOR THE WORD AND IT WILL HAVE A
SEAT ON THE REDUCED BOARD -- I'D
ALSO LIKE TO JUST ASK IF IT
WOULD WITH THE PERMISSION OF THE
CHAIR. FOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WHO LAMAR TO ALSO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED I THANK YOU RECORD REFER
BRIEFLY IF YOU DON'T MIND --
IMMER VERY BRIEFLY I WOULD JUST
ADD THE TWO TWO QUICK COMMENTS
SO THAT IS THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
EVERYTHING IN SENATOR MINING'S
BILL SUSTAINS THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY. FOR THE REGION TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THE ISSUES
INCLUDED IN OUR PROGRAM FROM
HABITAT CONSERVATION TO WILDFIRE
PREVENTION WHICH YOU HEARD
EARLIER IS ANOTHER PART OF OUR
PROGRAM. TO THE TRANSPORTATION
AND TRANSIT ISSUES. TO THE
BUILDING A MOBILE APP EFFORTS
THOSE ARE ALL INCLUDED AS A
POTENTIAL FOR WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THESE RESOURCES AT THE BILL IF
THE BILL GOES FORWARD.
MR EXECUTOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
WITH THAT GOING TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR WE WELCOME A MOTION
ON THE ON THE FLOOR.
YEAH PLEASE CENTER BASED ON WHAT
HE WAS SAYING TO YOU NEW ADDRESS
THOUGH.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO GET THE
MONEY AND HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
REMOVE ALL THE?
THE OLD BUILDINGS WHAT'S THE
PLAN.
FOR WE HAVE HAD. TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN DEALING WITH
FORMER MILITARY BASEWE THOUGHT
ABOUT THE ARMY GAVE US THE
PROPERTY THEY SAID THE DO WE
COULD HAVE IT AT A REDUCED COST
HOWEVER.
THE COST OF REMOVING THE
BUILDINGS IS OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
JUST IN THE CITY MARINO LOAN
THAT THE COST WE ESTIMATED IN
ONE PROJECT TO BE -- IN EXCESS
OF FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO COMPLEX
THAT WE HAVE TAKEN RESOURCE OF
FROM MARLIN SALES REVENUES AND
APPLIED THEM DIRECTLY TO
BUILDING REMOVAL.
WE'VE DONE OVER SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF BUILDING
REMOVAL TO DATE THAT'S NOT TO
SAY WERE FINISHED BECAUSE WE
STILL THINK THERE'S ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE LEFT TO GO.
AND SENATORS THE SENATORS BILL
WOULD ENABLE RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE FOR THE
BUILDING MOBILE WORK WHICH ARE
JUST UNDERTAKING A STUDY RIGHT
NOW WHICH SHOULD BE WITH US
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS --
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE OTHER
CITIES TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO REMOVE ALL THESE OLD
BUILDINGS YES SENATOR AND I
BELIEVE THOSE JURISDICTIONS HAVE
REQUESTED THAT WE UNDERTAKE
THOSE STUDIES AND WE WILL HAVE
THAT BACK TO THE FULL BOARD
WITHIN THE NEXT SIXTY DAYS.
THANK YOU.
WITH THE BILL THANK YOU WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
THE MOTION IS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
BY SENATOR BELL CENTRE MONEY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE
YES JUST BRIEFLY IN A WARNING
AGAIN WHILE YOU WERE OUT MISTER
CHAIR I DID WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE WORK OF YOUR STAFF.
PARTICULAR JONATHAN PETERSON
WHO'S EVEN TRAVEL DOWN TO GET A
FEEL FOR THE SCOPE OF THE
CONTINUING EFFORTS IN THE REGION
--
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS WE
ARE INVITING COMMENTS FROM THE
COUNTY THE CITY'S -- OTHER
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS.
I THINK WE'VE WE'VE TRIED TO
STRIKE A BALANCE CONSISTENT WITH
THE BOAT WE'VE TRIED TO DEFER TO
THE REGIONAL LEADERSHIP.
IN SHAPING HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS LIMITED EXTENSION.
I'D JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT.
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE STARTING
THE ASSEMBLY I'VE CARRIED.
OVER EIGHT PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
ESTABLISHING A VETERANS CEMETERY
IN THE FORMER FORT ORD FACE ONE
OF THAT IS IS COMPLETED THEY'RE
DOING FOUR TO FIVE BURIALS
INTERMENTS -- PER WEEK THERE AND
WE'VE HAD TREMENDOUS SUPPORT
FROM -- FOR IN THE JURISDICTIONS
AND I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WORK OF EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HULA
MARRED.
ON THE FOR SIDE OF THE WORK IN
ESTABLISHING THE VETERANS
CEMETERY -- FIRST TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THERE'S MUCH WORK TO BE DONE
THAT'S WHY WE THINK THIS PAVES A
PATHWAY TO CONTINUE. TO
EVENTUALLY SUNSET THE REGIONAL
AUTHORITY AND LET THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES PICK UP THE BALL
THIS IS THE PATHWAY. TO THAT
TRANSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER MONEY
WE'RE GRATEFUL THIS IS A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO CENTER
PREPARATIONS MOTION BY CENTER
ABOUT WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
CENTER MONEY FOR ALL OF HIS WORK
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
CITY COUNCIL AND CITY MANAGER
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY THIS LINE JUST YOU CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I WIRE I'M MORE LOT.
WELL LIKE I DEL.
BURKE THE TITLE.
NIELSEN.
WIENER.
HI WE HAVE HIGH.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A BIPARTISAN
FOUR ZERO VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN WE'RE GONNA
BE COMING BACK TO THAT.
THE WRONG ONE CAN COME BACK TO
THAT IN JUST A FEW MOMENTS WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO SENATE
BILLS THREE ZERO NINE CENTER
RUBIO.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NINE WERE THEN
GOING TO GO STRAIGHT INTO FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR HUESO.
SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH CENTER
RUBIO -- FILE ITEM NINE SENATE
BILL.
THREE ZERO NINE THERE WILL BE A
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WOK ON
THIS WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU
WERE HERE.
BEN CENTER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS AND THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SB THREE OH NINE WHICH WOULD
REMOVE THE MINIMUM DONATION.
REQUIREMENT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR CITIZEN ADVOCACY
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION FUND MUST
RACE IN ORDER TO REMAIN LISTED
ON THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX FORM.
I LIKE TO THINK THAT TURNED HIS
STOP FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
AND I GLADLY ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS TO OUT THE SUNSET
DATE AS REQUESTED.
THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE OR C. S. L. IS IN
STATUTORY AUTHORIZED BODY
DEDICATED TO ENHANCING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SOME MIGHT ASKS WHY SINGLE OUT
THIS ORGANIZATION.
AND WELL I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BACKGROUND ABOUT THE
WONDERFUL PROGRAM THAT BEGAN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THROUGH THE WORK
OF SENATOR HENRY.
MELLOW SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
THE CSL OVER TWO HUNDRED CSL
SPONSORED PROPOSALS HAVE BEEN
ENACTED AND SIGNED INTO LAW.
AIMED AT ENHANCING THE OLDER UP
ELDERLY POPULATION THE CSL FUND
FIRST APPEARED ON THE TAX RETURN
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AND WAS
LATER NAMED TO CALIFORNIA FUND
FOR SENIOR CITIZENS IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR WHEN THE
FUND WAS FIRST CREATED IT WAS
NOT DIRECTLY SUBJECT TO THE
MINIMUM CONTRIBUTION
REQUIREMENTS UNTIL.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHICH HAS
BEEN BURDEN SOME OF THESE FEW
PASS FAST PAST YEARS AGAIN I
WANT TO STRESS THAT THE SI SL IS
COMPRISED END OF OF INDIVIDUALS
OVER THE AGE OF FIFTY FIVE THEY
GET TO ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN
THE DIM.
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS ANDTHEY'RE
SHAPING OUR POLICIES THAT HAVE A
DIRECT IMPACT ON OUR AGING
POPULATION.
THE CSL HAS ALWAYS DEPENDED ON
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS VIA THE
INCOME TAX CHECK OFF.
OUR WHICH HAS PROVIDED NEARLY
ALL FUNDING FOR FOR ITS FORM AND
ADVOCACY PROGRAMS HOWEVER OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE CFL
HAS RECEIVED LESS THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND
CONTRIBUTIONS AND THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE UNDER.
CURRENT LAW THE CSL WILL FALL
OFF THE FORM AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR WITHOUT THAT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS JOHN A
POINTER WHOSE -- IS ON THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN A RUBIO WE
WELCOME YOU SIR YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES ONCE A THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK AT CSL INSTEAD RUBIO
THANK YOU FOR ADVANCING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- ESPECIALLY
HOW IMPORTANT IS HIS CELL IS TO
THE STATE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO.
SENATE REQUIRE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF SB THREE OH NINE I'D LIKE TO
START BY POINTING OUT SOME OF
THE BRIEF HISTORY AROUND CSL THE
TAX CHECK OFF.
CSL WAS ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
PARTICIPANTS IN THE TAX CHECK
OFF.
AT THAT TIME THERE ONLY FOR
FUNDS.
ON THE TAX CHECK OFF AS YOU KNOW
THERE ARE NOW ALMOST.
THIRTY I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX ORIGINALLY
PARADE TO THE CALIFORNIA FUND.
FOR SENIOR CITIZENS THE PHONE
WAS DESIGNED TO CONDUCT ANNUAL
SESSION.
AND SUPPORT ONGOING ACTIVITIES
CONTINUOUSLY.
CONTINUOUSLY WITHOUT REGARD TO
FISCAL YEAR AND THERE WAS NO
MINIMUM CONTRIBUTION
REQUIREMENTS.
SB THREE OH NINE ENSURE CSL
REMAINS ON THE TAX CHECK OFF AND
WILL FUND IT'S ADVOCACY EFFORTS.
THE ANNUAL SESSION LEGISLATOR
VISITS ETCETERA.
AS NOTED EARLIER THE CSL IS OVER
TWO HUNDRED LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
SIGNED INTO LAW.
DURING ITS THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT YEAR HISTORY.
FINALLY SB THREE OH NINE IS A
KEY COMPONENT.
OF THE CSL FUNDING SOLUTION
OUTLINED IN THE THREE YEAR
FINANCING PLAN.
THIS LAST YEAR AT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
NUMBER ONE HEARING.
CENTER RUBIO IS PROVIDED A VERY
CONCISE FACTUAL OVERVIEW OF WHAT
SB THREE OH NINE PROPOSES LET ME
CLOSE WITH THE FOLLOWING
SUMMARY.
THE CSL THE LEGISLATIVE CHAMPION
OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS ARE THIRTY
EIGHT YEAR HISTORY OF
LEGISLATIVE SUCCESSES ATTEST TO
OUR SKILL IN THIS AREA.
AS EACH OF YOU KNOW THERE ISN'T
A LEGISLATOR IN THE CAPITAL THE
DOESN'T KNOW WHO WE ARE AND WHAT
WE DO.
THE LEGISLATION DEVELOPER CSL
MEMBERS IMPACTS THE LIVES OF
SENIORS ACROSS THE STATE.
YOU KNOW THE DEMOGRAPHICS FACING
THE STATE.
IN THE STATE.
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT WE NEED AN
ORGANIZATION WITH A THIRTY EIGHT
YEAR HISTORY OF ADVOCATING FOR
SENIORS.
SB THREE OH NINE PROVIDES CSL
THE ABILITY. TO CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE TAX CHECK
OFF.
A PROGRAM IN WHICH IT WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER A PROGRAM THAT
WAS DESIGNED ORIGINALLY.
THE FUNDS ITS EFFORTS IN
ADVOCATING FOR SENIORS.
THE FASTEST GROWING POPULATION
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF
THIRTY SECONDS HERE IN CLOSING.
IN CLOSING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF CSL IN THREE YOUR
SUPPORT TO SUPPORT A SENIOR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BY VOTING YES ON SB.
THREE OH NINE THANK YOU VERY
VERY GRATEFUL SIR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WOULD LIKE TO
OPEN IT UP FOR ANYONE ELSE WHO
IS IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ADVANCE THE MICROPHONE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT.
LAST CALL YOU KNOW LIKE TO BE TO
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE TO
SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
THE AUDIENCE.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION NOW
LIKE TO ENTERING INTO COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
RESEARCHER -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THESE BALI CONS THE
THE VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS SO I
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS.
I APOLOGIZE IT DID NOT GET YOUR
NAME JOHN POINTER.
ON POINTERS YES MISTER POINT OR
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR ORGANIZATION
DOING TO ENCOURAGE -- ITS ITS
MEMBERS TO DO THE VOLUNTARY
[inaudible]
CONTRIBUTION CHECKOFF.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'VE ALL
FIRST STARTED WITH A VENDOR?
WE'VE ARE CONTRACTED TO TRY AND
HELP US IN TERMS OF FUND
RAISING.
UP WE ALSO UTILIZE OUR MEMBERS.
TO ADVERTISE PROMOTE THE TAX
CHECK OFF WE HAVE A FIVE BY
EIGHT POSTCARD THAT IDENTIFIES
WHAT THE FUND IS WE PROVIDE A
FLYER.
WE ENCOURAGE VISITATIONS TO
EVERY SENIOR ORGANIZATION IN
THEIR LOCALE IN THE DISTRICT TO
PROMOTE THAT STARTS WITH SENIOR
CENTERS STARTS WITH OTHERS
SEEING YOUR GONNA STATIONS IN MY
CASE.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY SENIOR CITIZEN ADVISORY
COUNCIL I PROMOTED AT THE
MEETINGS THERE I'M A MEMBER OF
WHAT THEY CALL -- CAST WHICH IS
PART OF A PLANNING PROCESS IN
ORANGE COUNTY HI PROMOTE THE
PROGRAM TO THAT AS WELL I ALSO
USE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS LIKE AL
TIMERS. TO OUR COMMUNICATE --
AGE WELL STATE YOUR SERVE ALL
THOSE KINDS OF ORGANIZATIONS TO
GET THAT MESSAGE OUT IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE ARE.
AND HOW THE TAX CHECKOFF WORKS.
WE HAVE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN
THE STATE I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
OF THEM ARE FILING FIVE FORTY
FORMS BUT YOU'RE ONLY RAISING
NINETY THOUSAND A YEAR
[inaudible]
YES.
SO WHAT LET ME TALK TO THAT FOR
JUST A MINUTE SIR -- I'VE
PROVIDED A HISTORY OF OUR TAX
CHECK OFF REVENUES.
IT PROVIDES A OUR WIDE RANGE OF
SUCCESSES.
AND ALSO LESS THAN SUCCESS WE
HAD.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY TWO DOLLARS
DONATED. TO THE TAX CHECK OFF.
HOWEVER THREE DECADES LATER.
WE HAD CITY MAP FALL TO SIXTY
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN DOLLARS.
IN A TIME PERIOD BETWEEN TWENTY
ELEVEN AND TWENTY FIFTEEN ARE.
WE SOUGHT 80% DECLINE.
IN OUR DONATIONS.
THE UNFORTUNATE THING IS IS I
BELIEVE YOU KNOW AS WELL THAT
TAX INFORMATION THOSE DONATIONS
ARE PROTECTED.
UNDER THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY LAWS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHO THE DONORS
ARE.
SO WHAT I ATTEMPT TO DO
UNFORTUNATELY AS AS YOU POINT
OUT USE MY MEMBERS.
ARE TO TRY AND MASS MARKET IN A
BLIND FASHION SINCE I DON'T KNOW
WHO THEY ARE SO -- I CANNOT THE
FRUSTRATION IS I CANNOT GET AN
EXPLANATION AS TO WHAT HAPPENED.
YOU ASKED THE SAME QUESTION.
I BELIEVE CITY BEFORE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
WHAT HAPPENED IN IN FOUR YEARS
HOW CAN YOU TO CLIMB?
IN FOUR YEARS FROM OF OVER
300-100-0260 THOUSAND SO THE
FRUSTRATION IS I HAVE TO BLINDLY
MARKET.
I IT'S INSTEAD OF THE WHITE
HOUSE TIMERS OR THE BREAST
CANCER ORGANIZATION OR ANY OF
THE OTHER.
MEMBERS OUT THERE THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT I KNOW THERE'S
CHALLENGES IN IN -- CENTER MORE
LOCK HAS.
BEEN DOGGED -- IN BRINGING
REFORM AND WE'RE GONNA SEE A
PACKAGE COMING FORWARD HERE
LATER THIS YEAR.
CENTER MORE LIKE IS RIGHT HERE
I'M GONNA RUN TO EDUCATION TO BE
A VOTE.
AND PASSED THE GAVEL OVER TO YOU
AND THEN I I DON'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT THIS POINTER APOLOGIZE
--
INTERNET BACK TO YOU WITH THE AT
YOUR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM BE BACK
MOMENTARILY PLEASE PLEASE TAKE
YOUR TIME MISTER KERRY.
MR POINTER -- AS A GERMAN STATED
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK ON THESE
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS -- WE'RE
SEEING A DECLINE.
THAT WE'RE SEEING ARE EVER SPOKE
TO TWO HUNDRED CPA'S -- SINCE I
AM.
ONE AND I ASKED IN THE ROOM HOW
MANY OF YOU ARE EVEN ENCOURAGING
YOUR CLIENTS TO SELECT A CHECK
OFF BOX.
DID YOU GET TAX ORGANIZER'S WHEN
YOUR WORK WITH YOUR TAX
PREPARER.
AND AND IN LESS THAN. TWO HANDS
WENT UP BY TWO TWO HANDS OUT OF
TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE.
AND TURBOTAX TO COUPLE YEARS AGO
DIDN'T EVEN INCLUDED IN THEIR
SOFTWARE YOU KNOW SO SO YOU
MISSED A WHOLE SLEW.
OF OF POTENTIAL DONORS SO I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO HELP YOU IN INCREASING
THE AMOUNT OF CONTRIBUTIONS?
AND AND AND SO HERE WE ARE YOUR
YOUR VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION
BECAUSE THERE'S TWENTY NINE OF
YOU NOW WE'RE SO OR SO.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN AND
AND AND YOU'RE THERE BECAUSE YOU
HAD A LEGISLATOR THE PUT YOU
THERE SO IF YOU HAVE A FRIEND
YOU GET.
ON THE LIST AND THEN.
IN IN THE PIE IS THE SAME SO I
KNOW WHERE THAT MONEY BUT JUST
GOING TO THOSE TWENTY SEVEN OR
SO THAT'S WHY YOU'VE DECREASED.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME IF IF IF WE
KEPT THE NONPROFIT INDUSTRY HAS
TO SAY HEY HERE'S OUR CODE.
CAN YOU DO SOCIAL MEDIA.
YOU DO IN YOUR MAILERS HEY
MEMBER OUR CODE IS FOUR SEVEN
SIX OR WHATEVER IT IS PLEASE
GIVE US A BUCK OR TWO OR
WHATEVER ON YOUR TAX RETURN --
THAT WE COULD PROBABLY MARKET
THE WHOLE CONCEPT A LITTLE
BETTER SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT FOR LATER THIS
YEAR NOT EASY.
BECAUSE AT THE FIVE FORTY IS
LIKE FIVE PAGES ONE IS JUST THIS
THIS VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS.
SO I I I I I APPRECIATE WE TRY
TO DO AYE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
ONE WORD IN IN YOUR BILL AND
THAT IS INDEFINITE SO COULD YOU
EXPLAIN WHAT THAT MEANS.
IS A DEFINITE TO ANOTHER BILL
COMES ALONG.
ACTUALLY I BELIEVE THAT WAS
AMENDED.
AND IT'S NOW.
202-5 OKAY THANK YOU BECAUSE I
IF I COULD ALSO GET BACK TO YOU
IN JUST RESPOND HE REGARDS.
TO THE REPAIRS [inaudible]
UP [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
EMAIL.
MY EMAIL EVERY [inaudible]
PREPARE.
IN THE STATE.
PROMOTING OUR THE TAX CHECK OFF
AND MAKING THEM AWARE OF THAT.
IN AN ATTEMPT -- TO AGAIN OUR
RECEIVE DONATIONS.
HOWEVER EVERY TAX PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION TAKES THE FOLLOWING
POSITION.
I CANNOT PROMOTE ONE FUN OVER
ANOTHER.
HEY SO WHEN I WALK IN AND HAVE
MY RETURN PREPARED I CAN'T
DIRECT YOU MISTER POINTER.
TO CSL ARE I HAVE TO REMAIN
UNBIASED AND IN.
IT AND I UNDERSTAND THAT SAME
APPLIES IN THE SENIOR CENTERS
WHERE THERE IS A TAX PREPARATION
ROOM.
I CANNOT.
ARE THE PLAYERS IN THERE AGAIN
HAVE THE POSITION.
AND I UNDERSTAND RIGHTLY SO I
CAN'T PROMOTE ONE ORGANIZATION
OVER ANOTHER.
HI SO I AM AWARE OF WHAT THE
PREPARE STANCES BUT WE CONTINUE
TO ATTEMPT TO MAKE THEM AWARE OF
THE TAX CHECK OFF IN ITS
BROADEST TERMS AND AT LEAST
PROMOTE.
THE TAX CHECK OFF RATHER THAN
ANY.
ONE INDIVIDUAL ORGANIZATION --
NUMBER.
TWO YES I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH
YOUR OF OUR EFFORTS IN REGARD TO
THE TAX CHECK OFF I WAS THERE
WHEN LOS ANGELES WHEN YOU AND US
SENATOR HERTZBERG OR WHERE
THERE.
ARE I'VE I'VE HEARD YOUR
ORIGINAL I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE A
POSITION PUBLICLY.
IN REGARDS TO THAT I WOULD ONLY.
REMIND YOU THAT WE SURVIVE.
AS A RESULT OF THE TAX CHECKOFF.
I DON'T HAVE I'M I'M NOT LIKE
SOME OF THE OTHER LARGER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE A A
LARGE TAPE THEY DON'T EXACTLY
WHO THEIR DONORS ARE.
AND THEY CAN MARKET THAT THAT.
I INSTEAD.
AS I POINTED OUT EARLIER HAVE NO
CLUE BUT WHAT I WHAT I AM SO
DEPENDENT ON IS THAT.
THE TAX CHECK OFF AGAIN IS OUR
FUNDING SOURCE.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
SOLUTION WILL BE I JUST KNOW
THAT.
FOR CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE REMAINING ON THE TAX
CHECKOFF.
EQUATES TO SURVIVAL FOR US.
GREAT THANK YOU RISK MINOR
BECAUSE I'M GETTING CPA'S IN
EA'S THAT ARE JUST NOT EVEN
BOTHER.
AT ALL SOLD WE'RE NOT GETTING.
WHEN I GETTING THE SUPPORT SO
I'D BE HAPPY TO COME BY YOUR
OFFICE SOME TIME AND SPEAK TO
YOU I'VE GOT ONE GREATER DETAIL
PLEASE COME BY OKAY?
RIGHT SO I NEED -- I NEED A
MOTION RIGHT [inaudible]
TO AND SO I WILL RELUCTANTLY
MOVE IT CAN I MOVE IT AS VICE
CHAIR.
OKAY THEN I I WILL MAKE THE
MOTION.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THE FRENCH A TRIP YOU COULD
--
TO THE ROLE MADAM SECRETARY.
MORE LOCK.
I OKAY [inaudible]
ONE ZERO PART OF BY THE WAY
THERE.
THANK YOU VERY ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU I'M SORRY DID I GIVE YOU
CLOSING COMMENTS.
OKAY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND AND THANK YOU FOR OUR FOR
PASSING THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATE RUBIO
FOR GIVING ME A LITTLE TIME.
TO DISCUSS IT WITH MISTER
POINTER.
I LOST MY FRIENDS USED.
OUR NEXT BILL IS. FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU SB FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT THE WORLD FAMOUS SENATOR.
BEN HUESO.
IF YOU HAVE THE FLOOR CARE AND I
GUESS WHAT YOU AND I ARE GOING
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ON THIS
ONE IS JUST YOU AND ME.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
IT'S ALWAYS VERY THE I'M VERY
EAGER TO SUCCEED ONE DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK COMMISSION AND
PLACE THE AYE BANK UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF THE COMMISSION
FOR THE PURPOSES.
OF INITIATING BANKING ACTIVITY
IN IN -- REPRESENTATION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
LOCAL MUNICIPAL.
AND AND COUNTY AGENCIES OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SWITCHED OF
PARTICIPATE IN THIS INSTITUTION.
IT'S A LIMITED -- TO GOVERNMENT
ACTIVITY.
BUT THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT
THE AYE BANK BE CHARTERED AS A
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION.
AND AUTHORIZES TREASURER.
A STATE OFFICER LOCAL AGENTS
HERE UPON THE APPROVAL OF OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS A QUALIFY
PUBLIC.
NONPROFIT ENTITY TO ESTABLISH A
DEPOSIT ACCOUNT WHAT THE BANK.
SO WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO
ESTABLISH HERE -- ACCORDING TO
RECENT ESTIMATES CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE TO INVEST MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION OVER THE
NEXT DECADE AND PUBLIC
FACILITIES TO SERVE A GROWING
POPULATION.
UPGRADING SCHOOL.
THE SCHOOLS UNIVERSITY BUILDINGS
MAINTAINING HIGHWAYS AND PUBLIC
TRANSIT SYSTEMS AND MAKING THE
WATER SYSTEMATICALLY.
RELIABLE AND SUSTAINABLE SEVEN
HUNDRED BILLION MOST OF THIS
WILL COME IN THE FORM OF OF
LOANS AND BONDS.
AND THE HOPE IS THAT WHEN WE GO
OUT TO THESE INSTITUTIONS THAT
THE MARKET WILL.
PROVIDE US LOW INTEREST RATE
LOANS.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT WE CAN CONTROL
THAT IF WE DECIDE WE HAD THE
DESIRE.
BUT I WAS HERE -- NOT I WASN'T
HERE WHEN I WHEN THE THE I WAS I
CAME TO LEGISLATURE WHEN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE OAKLAND A
BIT BRIDGE.
COMMENCED.
AND BACK THEN THERE WAS AN
AGREEMENT AT TO ART BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T FIND.
BECAUSE OF THE STATE'S INTEREST
RATES AT THE TIME THE CREDIT
RATING THEY COULDN'T FIND.
A CAPITAL TO BUILD UP THE BRIDGE
IT WAS -- A NINE BILLION DOLLAR
BRIDGE AT THE TIME.
AND AND WHERE DID WE GO FOR THE
REST OF FOR THE LOAN FOR THAT
MONEY WE WENT TO CHINA AND CHINA
GAVE US LOWER INTEREST WITH THE
CONDITION THAT THE MAJORITY OF
THAT BRIDGE BE BUILT IN CHINA.
SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT.
THE COST OF CONSTRUCTING THAT
BRIDGE AND WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE
MEANT IT WOULD HAVE MEANT TO
LOCAL WORKERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO BUILD THAT BRIDGE BY LOCAL --
CONTRACTORS HERE CALIFORNIA AND
TO SPEND OUR MONEY LOCALLY IN
OUR ECONOMY WHAT THAT WOULD HAVE
DONE NINE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN OUR OWN STATE.
AND THAT WAS LOST [inaudible]
THAT BRIDGE.
WAS COMPLETED IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOR I'M SORRY
THAT DIDN'T THE NUMBER SIX POINT
FOUR BILLION.
BUT SIX POINT FOUR BILLION IS
STILL.
ON EARTH LOAD OF MONEY.
AND END OF END WELL THERE WERE
SOME LOCAL JOBS WITH WITH WITH
WITH THAT CONSTRUCTION THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY
MORE.
AND THOSE INTEREST RATES COULD
HAVE STAYED HERE IN OUR LOCAL
BANKS IN FACT IF WE HAD A STATE
BANK THAT MONEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPOSITED.
IN OUR OWN STATE'S BUDGET.
AND USED TO CUT UP A PROVIDE
OTHER LOANS TOWARD
MUNICIPALITIES SO IN ESSENCE
WHAT IS MY BILL DO MY BILL
ALLOWS FOR US TO CHARTER BANK
DEPOSIT OUR STATE FUNDS.
INTO THAT BANK AND ISSUE LOANS
TO MUNICIPALITIES -- IF YOU JUST
CONSIDERED IT IF WE JUST
DEPOSITED OUR RESERVES WHAT OUR
RESERVES TO IN RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
SITTING IN AN ACCOUNT.
NON PERFORMING.
RIGHT NOW THE INTEREST RATE I
THINK THAT WERE RECEIVING AS
LESS THAN 1%.
THIS IS NOTHING WORRY WERE
BASICALLY PAIN -- WE'RE GETTING
--
ALMOST NOTHING ON OUR MONEY.
BUT IT JUST LIST LIST THINK
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
DEPOSITED INTO AYE AYE BANK.
WOULD MAKE FOURTEEN BILLION
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE TO LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES FOR LET'S SAY.
WHAT IF WE WANTED TO CHARGE 1%
OR ONE POINT 5%?
AT ONE POINT 5% WERE LOOKING A
BIT AT A BILLION DOLLARS OVER
FIVE YEARS THAT WE WOULD
DEPOSIT.
INTO OUR AYE BANK.
BUT THAT WOULD ALSO SAVE THOSE
INSTITUTIONS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN INTEREST RATES
GO UP.
WHEN THEY GO UP?
AND AND AND SOME OF THESE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO DON'T HAVE THE
BEST CREDIT RATINGS COULD BE
PAIN. FIVE SIX SEVEN MAYBE MORE
PERCENT ON BONDS WE COULD GIVE
THEM MUCH MORE COMPETITIVE
RATES.
AND STILL MAKE A RETURN AND
WE'RE BANKING WITH INSTITUTIONS
THAT [inaudible]
CAN'T FAIL.
SO WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT RISKY
LOANS -- WILL YES.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IT'S NOT OFTEN
THAT THEY GOING TO BACKROOM C.
BUT WHEN THEY DO -- BANKRUPTCY
JUST MEANS REORGANIZATIONS FOR
CITIES IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY
GO OUT OF BUSINESS I'VE NEVER
SEEN.
A GOVERNMENT AGENCY GO OUT OF
BUSINESS IT'S VERY RARE BUT EVEN
IN THAT OF THEN WE WOULD BE
CVERED -- BECAUSE OUR
INVESTMENTS WOULD BE VERY HIGH
THERE BE ERY LOW RISK AND
RETURN RATE WILL COVER FOR THAT
BUT I MEAN IF YOU IF YOU THINK
THAT THAT.
THE RISK -- BY APPRECIATE THAT
BUT IT REALLY ISN'T BECAUSE WERE
REALLY OF BUT YOU KNOW IN THE
ACT WHEN WHEN WE WE MAKE TO HAVE
MADE IT HARDER FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RAISE CAPITAL THAN
EVER BEFORE IN OUR HISTORY.
WE'VE ELIMINATED --
REDEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS WE'VE
ELIMINATED A LOT OF A LOT OF
GRANT PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY TO
FEDERAL LEVEL WERE NOT SEEN A
LITTLE FURTHER.
A LOT OF FEDERAL FUNDS GO TO OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO
FOR THEM AND UP ANDUP AND UP
ALLOWING THEM TO GET VERY LOW
INTEREST RATE LOANS.
AND USING MONEY THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE THAT'S ON DEPOSIT.
BUT IMAGINE IF WE JUST TO BE A
POSITIVE FOURTEEN BILLION WE
WOULD HAVE FOURTEEN BILLION
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE AND
LEVERAGE BOWL -- WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO USE THAT MONEY TO
LEVERAGE TOLD THE FEDERAL
RESERVE WHICH ALLOWS TOMORROW I
DON'T SUGGEST THAT WE BORROW.
BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T NEED TO
BORROW -- IF THERE WAS AN
EMERGENCY THOUGH HOWEVER OUR
BANK WOULD BE ALLOWED TO BORROW
FROM THE RESERVE WHICH IS A VERY
NORMAL PRACTICE FOR EVERY SINGLE
BANK IN THIS NATION.
BUT I'M SAYING WE'RE BIG ENOUGH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH OUR
WHAT I MEAN TODAY LOOKING AT OUR
OUR BUDGET THAT WERE PUT WE'RE
LOOKING AT A HUNDRED AND NINETY
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET IF WE
DEPOSIT THAT AND TO OUR STATE.
OWNED FINANCIAL INSTITUTION.
THINK ABOUT ALL THE MONEY THAT
WE WOULD SAVE US A STATE.
AND IF WE LOANED A PORTION OF IT
THINK ABOUT ALL THE MONEY THAT
WE COULD RETURN TOWARD GENERAL
FUND.
I HAVE USED IN A ON A NORMAL
SICK ON MANY OCCASIONS THE THE
NORTH DAKOTA BANK THEY HAVE
ARGUED WELL IF YOU ARE OPEN TO
STATE BANK BANKS WILL CLOSE.
IN NORTH DAKOTA STATE WAS SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
THEY HAVE THE LARGEST PER CAPITA
BANK.
OF RATIO IN THE COUNTRY IN
ADDITION TO THAT -- THE INDOOR
DAKOTA BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY FELT
WELL.
WE'RE NOT GONNA WE DON'T WANT --
TO A GAUGE IN BANKING ACTIVITY
BUT WE WILL ALLOW DEPOSITS TO BE
USED AND THEY THEY WORK THROUGH
THEIR LOCAL BANKS TO TO GIVE
LOANS TO THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY WORK TO LOCAL BANKS.
AND SO THEY HAVE ALMOST NO
EXPENSES ALL THEY DO IS DEPOSIT.
THERE THERE ARE -- THE MONEY IN
THE BANK THEY USE IT FOR THEIR
OWN PURPOSES AND AND AND TWENTY
YEARS WITH THE STATE OF SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND THEY HAVE
RETURNED A BILLION DOLLARS OF
PROFIT.
TO THEIR THEIR THEIR THEIR STATE
A BILLION DOLLARS AND THIS IS
WHAT ENGAGE IN AND NO ACTIVITY
AT ALL JUST.
USING MONEY TO TO GET -- TO GIVE
IT LOW INTEREST RATES TO BANKS
IN THEIR COMMUNITY WHICH IS A
HUGE SERVICE FOR THE BANKS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY BECAUSE THE
BANKS IN THE COMMUNITY COULD
GET.
VERY LOW INTEREST RATE MONEY
THAT THEY WOULD OTHERWISE PAY
FOR FOR MORE FOR ON THE FEDERAL
RESERVE.
SO WE CAN DO BETTER IN ALL I'M
ASKING YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GIVEN
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE THIS BILL WOULD BE SO
GREAT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'D BE GREAT. FOR THE
CITIES IN THE COUNTIES AND AND
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
GONNA BE EMBARKING IN LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ARE
GOING TO GO TO BOND MARKETS.
WE'VE DONE SO MUCH REFORM ON
BOND REFORM AND WHAT.
AND AND SO MUCH REFORM ON ON
TAXATION.
WHY DON'T WE LOOK AT THIS AS AN
OPTION THIS WILL SAVE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS?
MILLIONS IF NOT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF THIS IS CALCULATED
STATEWIDE.
IT WOULD STATE SAVE OUR STATE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY AND IT
WOULD HELP US TO MOVE FASTER.
TOWARD REPLACING OUR AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND AND ALSO HELP HELPING TO
SAVE MONEY IN THAT PROCESS AND
RAISE MONEY FOR GENERAL FUND OR
JUST KEEP THE MONEY IN THE AND
THE STATE BANK AND AS THAT FUND
GROWS TO GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY
USE A FOR MORE.
A PUBLIC BENEFIT OF PROJECTS SO
--
I HAVE LOTS TO SAY THIS ALL ARE
CUT MY COMMENTS BECAUSE WE HAVE
A LOT OF GREAT WITNESSES ON THIS
AND I JUST WANNA.
US STATE.
YOU KNOW.
THE OPPOSITION IS STATED THE
EXPANSION.
OF THE AYE BANK. TO TWO OF THAT
WOULD BE VERY COSTLY.
AND I'M GONNA TELL YOU THAT IT'S
COSTLY IN AND THAT'S ITS ONLY
COSTLY WHEN YOU MAKE A TRANSFER
[inaudible]
OF MONEY. ONE ACCOUNT TO THE
OTHER SIDE HOW MUCH THAT COSTS
NOTHING BUT IF YOU LIST.
FOURTEEN BILLION AS OUR DEPOSIT
THEY'RE GONNA LIST WITH LOTS OF
COST.
BECAUSE IN ESSENCE THERE ARE WE
ALREADY HAVE AN AYE BANK THAT'S
OPERATING.
THAT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
ISSUING LOANS THAT HAS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAS
EVERYTHING THEY NEED ALREADY IN
PLACE ALL WE NEED TO DO IS
DEPOSIT SOME MONEY IN THERE.
FROM THE MINUTE WE DEPOSIT THE
MONEY INTO THE AYE BANK WELL.
THERE ARE SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OF ESTABLISHING THE BANK
AND THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT WOULD BE ABSORBED
IN THE FIRST YEAR OF REVENUES.
BECAUSE WOULD MAKE ENOUGH MONEY
IN THE FIRST YEAR TO PAY FOR
THAT AND IT'S WORTH.
GIVING THE AYE BANK ALONE.
FIRST TO FUND START UP COSTS
THAT WILL RECOVER IN THE FIRST
YEAR.
OF ISSUE IN LOANS.
BUT IF WE EVEN WANTED TO USE
JUST -- I MEAN MODELED AFTER THE
NORTH DAKOTA BANK.
WE WOULD HAVE.
OF AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF OF
DISCRETION TO TARGET MONEY INTO
OUR CITIES AT VERY LOW INTEREST
RATES AND THAT IS THE ALSO --
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES TO DEPOSIT IN THE
STATE BANK THAT THAT COULDN'T IF
THEY HAVE A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP THE LOCAL BANK THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO DO THAT -- IT
DOES NOT SEEK TO PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL FINANCING OPTIONS --
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FINANCING OFF OPTIONS
FOR MUNICIPALITIES AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO DEPOSIT WHAT THE
STATE.
TO OBTAIN THOSE IT'LL BE BASED
ON THE AVAILABILITY OF MONEY SO
IT COULD BE A WIN WIN.
THEY CHOOSE NOT TO DEPOSIT THEY
CAN STILL HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH OUR AYE BANK IF THEY CHOOSE
TO DO SO.
THEY CAN -- YOU HAVE THEIR MONEY
BE USED FOR THEIR PURPOSES SO.
I I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS WE HAVE ALLEN BROWN THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE PUBLIC BENT
BANKING IS TO TO HEAR TO ADD TO
MY REMARKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYWAY SO IT
TOOK A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE
CENTER HUESO FIRST PASSION IS
FOCUS ON THIS AS WELL VERY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR SIR IN APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THE TIME TO COULD BE
HEARING COMMITTEE TODAY.
WE WELCOME YOU MAN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS IF YOU
DON'T MIND IS INTRODUCE YOURSELF
IN ORGANIZATION THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
AND I'D THANK YOU SENATOR I SO
IT'S WELL FOR HIS CASH IT'S
GOING ALL THE WAY BACK TO TWENTY
ELEVEN WHEN HE BROUGHT THE FIRST
BILL AND THAT'S GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
THAT GREW OUT OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT BANKING CRISIS.
AND IS GENERATING GROWING
INTEREST PARTICULARLY AMONG A
NEW GENERATION OF MILLENNIALS
WHO ARE DEMANDING REAL CHANGE IN
HOW BANKING IS PRACTICE TODAY.
IN THE LAST DECADE MANY BILLS
HAVE BEEN FILED AND FEASIBILITY
STUDIES DONE NATIONWIDE. FOR
PUBLIC BANKS INCLUDING ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE BILLS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ACTIVE BUT THE ONE
THAT APPEARS TO BE THE MOST
PROMISING AT THE MOMENT IS THIS.
ONE IT WOULD SIMPLY TRANSFORM
THE EXISTING AYE BANK INTO A
DEPOSITARY BANK EXPANDING ITS
CAPACITY TO MAKE SAFE AND
PRUDENT INFRASTRUCTURE LOANS.
AT BELOW MARKET RATES WELL
PAYING ITS MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENT
DEPOSITORS ABOVE MARKET RATES.
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM IS A
STRONG ADVOCATE OF ITS STATE ON
BANKING AND HAS EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN THE AYE BANK
APPROACH PARTICULARLY.
ARE CONTRADICTED TENSIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MAKING ASSERTION
VISION A DEPOSITARY AYE BANK
WOULD NOT COMPETE WITH LOCAL
CALIFORNIA BANKS OR TAKE
DEPOSITS AWAY FROM THE LOCAL
AGENCY INVESTMENT FUND.
WHICH INVESTS LONGER TERM
DEPOSITS IN LOCAL BANKS IN THIS
CASE THE AYE BANKS COMPETITORS
WOULD BE WEALTHY BOND HOLDERS
WHO FIND INFRASTRUCTURE LOANS
WHILE AVOIDING STATE TAXES.
AND VERY LARGE OUT OF STATE OR
MULTINATIONAL BANKS THAT NOW
HANDLE ABOUT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLARS IN DEPOSIT TRANSACTIONS.
FOR CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENTS AND
THOSE BANKS AND NOW ARE GETTING
ONE OR TWO POINT 4%.
INTEREST ON THEIR RESERVES AT
WHICH THEY ARE PARKING AT THE
FEDERAL RESERVE WHICH IS LIKE.
MANY THEY'RE NOT LENDING OUT
THERE GETTING TWO POINT 4% ON
FROM THE FED.
AND THEY'RE PAYING OUR ON OUR
PUBLIC DEPOSITS ALMOST NOTHING.
FINANCING IS HALF THE COST OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE AYE BANK
CAN REDUCE THEIR COSTS BY 50%.
LEE HAS ONLY ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION TO LAND.
OF THAT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
WERE USED INSTEAD TO CAPITALIZE
A BANK AND A 10% CAPITAL
REQUIREMENT IT COULD LAND FOR
BILLION DOLLARS.
IT WOULD EVENTUALLY NEED
DEPOSITS OF A FEW BILLION THIS
SORT OFDEPOSITS THAT ARE NOW
TRANSFERRED TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSET MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
BUT OFFERING CLIENTS HIGHER
INTEREST AND ACCESS TO BELOW
MARKET LOANS WOULD ATTRACT THE
NECESSARY DEPOSIT.
THE BANK DOES NOT HAVE TO BE
STARTED FROM SCRATCH THE AYE
BANK HAS A FIFTEEN YEAR SUCCESS
RECORD EXPERIENCED STAFF AND
DETAILED PROCEDURES.
DEMAND FOR ITS LOANS IS THIRTY
TIMES WHAT IT CAN CURRENTLY
SERVICE.
ITS CUSTOMERS ARE VERY LOW RISK
CONSISTING SOLELY OF GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES IT IS PROJECTED TO BE
PROFITABLE BY YEAR.
THREE RATHER THAN FINDING A
FEASIBILITY STUDIES THE
POSSIBILITIES COULD BE EXPLORED
BY A TRANSITION TEAM DRAWN FROM
AYE BANK PERSON OUT.
DURING THE TWO TO THREE YEARS
NEEDED TO GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF REGISTERING WITH THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE NOT
GONNA WELCOME GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE GONNA WELCOME
FOLKS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD FIRST LASSEN
ORGANIZATION GOOD MORNING.
KATIE MADE ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOCRACY COLLABORATIVE
SPONSORED THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU IN
THAT SHOULD BE GOOD AFTERNOON
SORRY.
JERRY BROWN ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THINK
INSTAGRAM.
WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
I DON'T CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING UP THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE WE'VE TWO
SEATS IN THE FRONT.
WE'RE GONNA ONE PRIMARY WITNESS
IN FIVE MINUTES.
SECONDARY WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
YOU PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER KAREN J.
SETTLING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE TO OPPOSE
THE MEAURE.
MUCH OF WHAT WAS SAID BY -- THE
SENATOR AND THE SPONSORS SORT OF
IGNORES SOME PRETTY FUNDAMENTAL
BANKING PRINCIPLES.
ON THE NOTION THAT WE COULD TAKE
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS AND
DEPOSITED AND THEN LOAN IT OUT
--
IGNORES THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
TONS OF COLLATERAL REQUIREMENTS.
CAPITALIZATION REQUIREMENTS
ASSESSMENTS ON FDIC INSURANCE SO
THERE'S THERE ARE LITERALLY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH CREATING -- OR
CONVERTING THE AYE BANK INTO A
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION -- THAT
DIDN'T GET DISCUSSED HERE TODAY
--
IN OUR VIEW THIS IS CLEARLY A A
SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM
THE AE BANK FUNCTIONS -- VERY
WELL -- IS OUR INSTITUTIONS
PARTNER WITH THE I. BANK.
THROUGH THEIR LOAN SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAM
WHICH IS A VERY ROBUST PROGRAM
IT OPERATES IN A VERY EFFICIENT
MANNER -- UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
--
UNDER THE THE GOVERNOR --
UNDERGO BUSINESS AND IN OUR VIEW
THAT SHOULD REMAIN -- AND YOU
KNOW THIS THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR IS ONE THAT I THINK
IS A BIT ROM THE INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
HEAD SCRATCHER WE'RE NOT QUITE
SURE -- HOW OLD THE NUMBERS
PENCIL OUT AND THE GOAL IS TO
TAKE TAXPAYER DOLLARS WHICH I
WOULD SAY ALSO INCLUDE PENSION
INVESTMENTS -- PUT THEM IN A
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION THEN PAY
DEPOSITORS AN INTEREST RATE THAT
IS HIGHER THAN COMMERCIAL BANKS
WOULD PROVIDE WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY MAKING
INFRASTRUCTURE LOANS AT A RATE
THAT IS LOWER THAN A COMMERCIAL
BANK WOULD PROVIDE.
ALL THE WHILE MAINTAINING
CAPITAL.
CAPITAL RESERVES AND COLLATERAL
--
A AND THE OPERATIONS COST
ASSOCIATED WITH -- ALL THE
COMPLIANCE THAT GOES ALONG WITH
--
OPERATING A BANK.
I DON'T KNOW A SINGLE
INSTITUTION -- IT IN CALIFORNIA
THAT CAN MAKE THAT TYPE OF DEAL
PENCIL OUT -- WITHOUT MASSIVE
LOSSES -- IT THE INTERESTING
THING IS THAT THE PROPONENTS
TIME AND TIME AGAIN THEY BRING
UP FOR DAKOTA -- AND THAT'S
THAT'S AN INTERESTING.
EXAMPLE -- I'D REMIND FOLKS THAT
NORTH DAKOTA AS A STATE ITS GDP
IS THE SIZE OF OXNARD IT IS
LITERALLY 2% OF CALIFORNIA'S
GDP.
WHAT THE PROPONENTS DIDN'T TELL
YOU IS THAT NORTH DAKOTA LOST
MONEY FOR A DECADE BEFORE IT
EVEN BROKE EVEN -- AND MANY%
DOUBT -- THAT THAT BANK WHICH BY
THE WAY WAS FORMED IN NINETEEN
NINETEEN BEFORE -- THE LET ME OF
REGULATIONS THAT THE CAR BANKS
--
BANKING INDUSTRY OPERATES UNDER.
MANY DOUBT THAT WOULDN'T EVEN
EXIST TODAY -- GIVEN THE
REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS -- AGAIN
I WOULD SAY THAT THIS BILL POSES
A TREMENDOUS RISKS TO TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THESE ARE LOCAL AGENCY
DEPOSITS THE COMMUNITY BANKS USE
AND LEANED BACK INTO THEIR
COMMUNITY -- AND ESSENTIALLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT IT
TAKES AWAY A VITAL SOURCE OF
LIQUIDITY FOR COMMUNITY BANKS
AND IT PUTS THEM IN A STATE BANK
THAT HAS NO PHYSICAL PRESENCE IN
ANY OF YOUR COMMUNITIES. FOR
THIS REASON WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON THIS MEASURE.
HE WAS FINE WHEN I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO WALK UP TO ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MICROPHONE.
I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE I SAID
SUPPORT I'M IN OPPOSITION I
APOLOGIZE MA'AM YOUR MIND IS
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST AN
ORGANIZATION.
YEAH -- I TWEENER ALRIGHT.
GALLERY NARAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE
TWEENER WE HAD SOME CONVERSATION
WITH SENATOR STAFF AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING MORE SO THAT
WE CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THIS BILL.
WE HAVE A VERY FINE POINTED
INTEREST IN THE SMALL BUSINESS
LOAN ASPECTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GRATEFUL.
ANYONE ELSE IT MAY BE SQUISHY
END OR OPPOSE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
WE NOW LIKE TO BE TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR A MOTION TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FROM COMMITTEE.
HEARING.
CENTER ABOUT -- JUST ANSWER WAS
SO THE ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE WITH -- THE
HOUSING.
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS -- THE
INABILITY TO BORROW -- MONEY TO
FINANCE -- PROJECTS.
WHETHER PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS SO -- HOUSING IS A
PROBLEM IN TERMS OF LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- PROGRAMS
--
FOR COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT AND
SMALL BUSINESSES AND AREAS THAT
NEED TO BE -- YOU KNOW UPGRADED
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD PROVIDE JOBS
FOR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS OF WITH
THE THE CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK.
HAVE MAYBE A DIFFERENT PURPOSE.
OF AND BENEFIT TO THE STATE --
IN THOSE AREAS VERSUS A REGULAR
BANK.
NOW MY HOPE IS THAT ONE DAY THEY
COULD.
AND MY HOPE IS THAT ONE DAY --
WE COULD ESTABLISH PRIORITIES.
THROUGH OUR BANKS LIKE THE BANK
OF NORTH DAKOTA WOULD THAT
PROVIDE STUDENT LOANS HOUSING
LOANS BUSINESS LOANS ON SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS.
AND YOU KNOW AND THEIR LETTER
AND IN -- THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE TODAY THE BANK IN THAT
INDUSTRY WILL HAVE YOU BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE NO PROBLEMS AND
THAT I I HAVE FAILED TO IDENTIFY
HOW THE CURRENT MARKET OUR
MARKETPLACE IS NOT MEETING THE
THE NEEDS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
IF YOU BELIEVE THAT.
THEN THEN THERE IS NO NEED FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE IN MY
EXPERIENCE.
WORKING WITH LOCAL BANKS WAS
CITY IS CITY GOVERNMENTS.
NEITHER ARE THEY GIVING THE
LOANS -- TO THE THE THE SMALL
BUSINESS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND IN
THE AREAS WHERE WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO FOCUS ON BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT OR ARE THEY
PROVIDING THE SERVICES TO CITIES
ON BANKING THAT.
ARE.
OUR OUR FREE OF OF COST.
WHEN I WHEN I?
THANK BACK WHEN I WAS ON CITY
COUNCIL WE HAD AN AGREEMENT THAT
WAS APPROVED WHAT'S UP BANK OF
AMERICA AND IT WAS A VERY
FAVORABLE AGREEMENT TO THEM AND
WE STARTED TALKING ABOUT WHAT
ARE THEY DOING.
IN THE COMMUNITY AND THEY SAID
THIS AGREEMENT DOES NOT.
OBLIGATED TO DO ANYTHING.
AND AND WORDS WERE ACTUALLY
DOING YOU A FAVOR BECAUSE
MANAGING YOUR MONEY IS A
LIABILITY IF THAT IS TRUE.
AND THAT THAT'S WHAT I TOOK AWAY
FROM THAT MEETING AND THAT'S WHY
THAT'S WHY I'M RUNNING THIS
BILL.
WE CAN DO MORE WE CAN WE CAN DO
A LOT MORE BUT IF WE JUST FOCUS.
ON ON ON HELPING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SAVE MONEY.
THROUGH THROUGH THIS OPTION.
WE WOULD BE DOING A TREMENDOUS
SERVICE A CURRENTLY DOES NOT
EXIST IN THE IN THE MARKET PLACE
NOW.
OF ANOTHER LIKE WHEN I WAS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR ON MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- THE GOVERNMENT
DEPOSIT MONEY IN THE PRIVATE
BANKS -- AND AT ONE POINT -- WE
WERE DISCUSSING OUR CAL WORKS
PROGRAM.
NO WOMEN AND CHILDREN MANLY --
THEY WANT TO HAVE YOU KNOW CAL
WHICH IS A SMALL.
PROGRAM AND WE WE WANTED TO HAVE
THEIR FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS --
MADE MORE EFFICIENT SO WE WE WE
DECIDED TO HAVE.
THEIR DEPOSITS IN USING ATM FOR
THE CAL WORKS -- FUNDING AND SO
FORTH -- AND WE SAID WELL WE
LIKE TO DEPOSIT ARE FUNDS HERE
AND THEN HAVE [inaudible]
BANKS SO.
WAIVE THE FEES FOR THE ATM ON
THE CAL WORKS [inaudible]
TRANSACTIONS.
AND THEY REFUSE TO DO SO
[inaudible]
CHAU.
THE COUNTY -- PUT ON HIS AGENDA.
THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD REMOVE
OUR DEPOSITS FROM MANY BANKS
THAT REFUSE -- TO ABIDE BY OUR
DECISION NOT TO CHARGE -- A FEE
[inaudible]
AND SO WHEN WE WITH.
ENGAGE IN DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
AND WE HAVE THEIR FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY NOT JUST -- TO
MAKE EARNINGS WE HAVE THE
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY.
TO THROUGH THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
IN OUR COMMUNITY THERE'S A TOOL
RESPONSIBILITY -- IS NOT THE
SAME RESPONSIBILITY OF BANCOS.
DO YOU THINK THAT -- THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT X. --
WOULD BE CLOSER TO ONE I'M
TALKING ABOUT IF THIS BILL WAS
APPROVED.
I GAVE THE EXAMPLE EARLIER
IMAGINE IF THE STATE DEPOSITED
JUST OUR RESERVES FOURTEEN
BILLION IN RESERVES MONEY THAT
WE HAD LIKE A TWO AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS SO.
THE COUNTY CASH RESERVES SO WE
WERE.
WELL RIGHT THEN IMAGINE IF THEY
DEPOSITED THEIR RESEARCH AND
THEY ONE OF THE ONLY WORK FROM
RESERVES HOW MANY HOW MUCH MONEY
COULD WE RAISE. FOR FOR LOW
INTEREST.
BONDS LOANS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND AND THOSE THOSE
THOSE PROJECTS COULD FIND THE
OVER.
YOU KNOW SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION
THAT ARE ARE ARE ALL THE
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE OVER
THE NEXT DECADE ACROSS THE
STATE.
SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION AND
INFRASTRUCTURAL UNMET NEEDS THAT
OUR ROADS SCHOOLS.
LIBRARIES PARKS THINGS THAT ARE
ARE ESSENTIAL TO OUR STATES
[inaudible]
OPERATION.
IF WE COULD DRAMATICALLY REDUCE
THE INTEREST RATE THAT WE OFFER
TO FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF THESE
PROJECTS THINK AND AND WE CUT
OUT THE RED TAPE IN TERMS OF HOW
--
HAVING ACCESS TO THIS MONEY
THINK ABOUT ALL THE GOOD THAT WE
COULD DO FOR OUR OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS [inaudible]
WHEN WHEN?
WHEN IT WHEN A GOVERNMENT HAS A
POOR CREDIT RATING?
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS THEY PAY A
HIGHER INTEREST RATE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN WE
CAN YOU KNOW.
WHY DO WE PUNISH GOVERNMENTS?
NEVER GO OUT OF BUSINESS
GOVERNMENT'S CITIES COUNTIES AB
HAVE YOU HAS A COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA EVER GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS AND IF THEY HAVE AN
THAT INTEREST RATE.
IS THERE A RISK THAT THEY CAN'T
REPEAT LOS HAVE IT HAS A CITY OR
COUNTY EVER DEFAULTED ON A LOAN.
YET THE WE STOOD THERE STILL
SUBJECT TO THE CREDIT RATING.
OF FORMULAS WE CAN WE CAN BY
PASS THAT AS A STATE AND GIVE
THEM.
A LOWER INTEREST RATE LOANS.
AND AND THEY CAN REPAIR THEM AND
THEY'RE JUST SO MANY THINGS THAT
WE CAN BENEFIT.
A DRUG BENEFIT FROM IN A IN A IT
IN THE IN YOU IN USING OUR BY
BANK.
MORE WISELY USING A TO DO A
PUBLIC GOOD USE IN ITS DEPOSIT.
ALL OF OUR STATE OF THE THE IF
JUST THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
USED THE I BAG JUST TO DEPOSIT
ITS OWN.
BUDGET THINK ABOUT.
HOW MUCH MONEY WE WOULD SAVE IN?
OUR MEDI CAL THE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR MEDICAL.
PROGRAM WE HAVE WE COULD USE OUR
ALLY BANK TO LEVERAGE LOAN TO
DRAW REVENUE AND THAT REVENUE
COULD FIND ANYTHING THAT WE
WANT.
INCLUDING BALANCING OUR BUDGET
OR JUST KEEP IT IN THE BANK AND
USE THAT.
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO LOANS FOR
OUR COMMUNITY THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO AND WE
COULD OFFER LOW INTERESTED IN.
LOANS I MEAN THERE'S I JUST SEE
SO MUCH POTENTIAL.
BUT IF IF THE IT'S IT'S IT'S UP
TO THIS LEGISLATURE OF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE AN
APPETITE FOR EXPANDING THE THE
AUTHORITY OF THE AYE BANK.
I MEAN WHAT ARE.
I JUST THINK WE SHOULD DO
SOMETHING IT WOULD BE FOOLISH OF
NOT OF US NOT TO TRY.
AND THE COSTS ARE SO MINIMAL.
THE COSTS ARE SO MINIMAL THEY
CAN EASILY BE -- PAID AND
REPAID.
AND THEN.
I WE COULD HAVE REVENUE OFFSET
THOSE COSTS.
AND IF IT'S GONNA COST TAKE FIVE
YEARS -- TO TO ESTABLISH A
PROCESS A PROFIT IT'S WORTH.
IT'S IT'S WORTH THE EFFORT
BECAUSE OF THE BENEFIT IS
ENORMOUS THANK YOU CENTER.
GERMAN -- I THINK THAT -- THIS
BILL WAS WORTHY OF PUSHING
AHEAD.
I DON'T KNOW -- COMMENTS FROM
THE OTHER MEMBERS BUT I WOULD
MAKE A MOTION.
TO ALLOW THE BILL TO PROCEED AND
APPROVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DOUG VERY GRATEFUL SAN ABOUT
WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER THE VICE
CHAIR BUT WE DO HAVE A FORMAL
MOTION THE FLOOR WHICH IS TO
PASS TO BANKING FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS.
WERE IN TURN OVER THE VICE CHAIR
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- MISS BROWN THANK YOU
FOR COMING THANK YOU FOR THE
BOOKS ONE OF YOUR FANS SENT ME A
COPY I SHOULD HAVE A BETTER
KNOWN YOU WERE HERE ACTUALLY
BROUGHT IT TO HAVE YOUR
AUTOGRAPH AT THE TIME.
I JUST WISH HAD BEEN HERE WHEN I
WAS TREASURER OF THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE I ACTUALLY STARTED OR TRY
TO START A BANK CAME ABOUT THIS
CLOSE I WON'T GIVE THE LONG
STORY -- BUT THE ISSUE WAS
WELFARE RECIPIENTS I HAD MY
DISBURSEMENTS -- AND AND TO PUT
DEPOSITORY BANKS JUST UNWILLING
AB THEY DIDN'T WANT FIFTY
THOUSAND WELFARE RECIPIENTS IN
THEIR BRANCHES.
THEY DON'T WANT THE DIAPERS THE
THE MASS THEY WERE IT WAS IT WAS
AN AMAZING PARADIGM THAT I HAD
TO DEAL WITH.
SO -- SO I DECIDED MAYBE I
SHOULD START MY OWN BANKING IT
WAS AN INTERESTING EXPERIENCE --
IT BUT IT IT IT ACTUALLY WOULD
PENCIL OUT.
BUT NOT ENOUGH TO MAKE IT WORTH
ALL OF THE EXTRA WORK AND I I
WON THE LABOR.
IT YOU WITH THAT BUT HAVE FUN
WORKING WITH THE BANKS
INSTITUTION.
DEPARTMENT FOR THE STATE WENT TO
LA MET WITH.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM WHAT I HELP
--
REDUCE CHECK CASHING COST
SERVICES YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THE WELFARE RECIPIENTS
WERE GOING THEY'RE PAYING A
LARGE AMOUNT.
WOULD DO WOULD WE HAVE -- POINT
OF SALE CARDS WOULD BE PRE PAY
RENT AND AUTOMATICALLY PAY
UTILITIES WE WE HAVE A LOT OF
FUN.
AT THE END OF THE DISCUSSION.
ARE THEY SAID HOW DID YOU FEEL
OUR OF OUR OUR MEETING WENT I
SAID WELL I THOUGHT THE FIRST.
I THINK YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO THROW
ME OUT AFTER MY FIRST.
QUESTION LIKE WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE DOING AND GET OUT OF HERE
BUT WE HAD A P. I SEE APPROVAL
BETTER RESERVE APPROVALS KIND OF
AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE.
BUT ARE WE ALREADY HAVE THE
MONEY AND WAVE I DON'T KNOW
WHERE ARE.
STATE TREASURER IS OUR STATE
CONTROLLER BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
MONITOR THE CASH FLOW OF THE
STATE -- BUT I I I HAD TO PUT
TOGETHER A BUSINESS PLAN AND I I
DON'T SEE THAT HERE AS WELL ON
WHAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE THAT WAS
AN INTERESTING EXERCISE ASWELL
--
AND ACTUALLY GET GREAT FEEDBACK
I SHOWED IT.
TO TWENTY SMALL BANK CEOS IN THE
RESPONSE I GOT WAS THAT ONLY
LIKE THAT THEY WANT TO BE ON MY
BOARD WHICH IS.
KIND OF FUNNY FOR GOVERNMENT.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT GETTING INTO
THIS ARENA IS IS RATHER DICEY
IT'S RATHER INTERESTING YOU'VE
YOU MENTIONED BANKRUPTCY A FEW
TIMES I'VE BEEN THERE.
TOO YOU KNOW THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE DID FILE FOR CHAPTER NINE
BANKRUPTCY GUESTS WERE STILL IN
BUSINESS.
BUT WE WERE GENERATING REALLY
NICE RETURNS FOR DEPOSITORS AND
THEN AFTER THE COUNTY WOULD
BANKRUPT AND REALIZE THAT THEIR
FUNDS WERE PUT ON HOLD.
YOU KNOW OPENING A BANKRUPTCY
JUDGE RELEASING THOSE FRIENDS
THAT.
THAT WAS A KILLER THAT ONCE THE
FUNDS COULD BE FREED THEY WERE
THEY LEFT AND RIGHT HARDLY ANY
CAME BACK.
AND SO IT JUST GOT REALLY
AWKWARD SO EVEN THE FEAR OF OF
OF OF HAVING.
A LOSS OF CONTROL WOULD BE.
REAL ARE GREAT THAT'S WERE MAYBE
A BUSINESS PLAN WOULD BE HELPFUL
WITH SOME OF THESE.
PROVISOS BUT CREATING A NEW
DEPARTMENT IN AN INTERESTING
AREA WHERE WHEREVER YOU BEEN I'M
GONNA BE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AT
THIS TIME.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR VISION.
AND AND YOUR APPROACH BUT I'D.
JUST BECAUSE I HAVE A HISTORICAL
CONTEXT I'LL I'LL I'LL BE A
LITTLE.
APPREHENSIVE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A VICE CHAIR I WANNA
TURN IT OVER TO THE CENTER TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND IF YOU'D LIKE
[inaudible]
WELL I'M.
MOST OF US WOULD BE HARD
PRESSED.
TO MENTION.
A BANKRUPTCY IN OUR STATE THERE
HAVEN'T BEEN VERY MANY BUT EVEN
WHERE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME.
NOBODY HAS GONE OUT OF BUSINESS.
AND IT'S HARDER TO RECOVER MONEY
FROM SOMEBODY.
THAT HAS GONE OUT OF BUSINESS
AND AND IN BANKRUPTCIES AGAIN
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH.
P. SO FEW OF THAT'S KIND OF
SOMETHING THAT A LARGE
INSTITUTION.
THANKS DEAL WITH THAT EVERY DAY
THEY'RE STILL IN BUSINESS NOT
ONLY THE DO THEY DEAL WITH.
A MUNICIPAL BANKRUPTCIES BUT
THEY ALSO DEAL WITH CORPORATE
BANKRUPTCIES.
AND AND THEY ARE -- OBVIOUSLY
STAY IN BUSINESS OUR AYE BANK IS
ALREADY FORMED OUR AYE BANKS
ALREADY BEEN ISSUING LOANS ARE
AYE BANK HAS ALREADY BEEN
HANDILY IN.
MONTHLY PAYMENTS AND AND REVIEWS
THEY ALREADY EXIST.
WERE WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
HERE SIMPLY JUST TRANSFERRING
MONEY FROM OUR STATE.
BUDGET TO THE AYE BANK THAT'S
ALL WE'RE REALLY REALLY
DISCUSSING OF COURSE -- AS FAR
AS GOING TO THE EXTENT OF
GETTING THE ALL THE TECHNICAL
APPROVALS.
CALL US WHETHER WE START THE
PROGRAM IS IS CONTINGENT ON ON
GETTING THOSE TECHNICAL
APPROVALS CAN WE DO IT
ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE THE SKILL AND EXPERIENCE
THE THE THAT IS NOT WHERE MY
CONCERN LINES MY MY CONCERN IS
TO WHAT DEGREE DO WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS AND AND IT'S
IT'S NOT REALLY.
MUCH OF A CONCERN I MEAN.
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THERE ARE
GOING TO BE A E. WILL BANKS LOSE
DEPOSITS ABSOLUTELY.
BUT THEY'LL BE THEY'LL LOSE
DEPOSITS ONLY WHEN THEY'RE NOT
BEING COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER
LOCAL CITIES.
AND IF THEY'RE NOT OFFERING GOOD
SERVICES THERE.
LET'S GIVE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ANOTHER OPTION TO COME TO THE
STATE WORK WITH US.
AND IF AND IF THEY WORK WITH US
AND GET BETTER RATES.
BUT I I THINK THAT'S WHAT BANKS
ARE MOSTLY AFRAID.
AFRAID OF COMPETITION.
AND EN I AGREE WE SHOULD FOLLOW
EVERY RULE AND CROSS EVERY.
WE LOOK AT EVERY DETAIL AND AND
I THINK WITH THERE SHOULD BE A
LEVEL PLAYING GROUND.
BUT ALSO WHAT WHY DON'T EVERY
TIME I MEAN THE WHOLE ESSENCE OF
GOVERNMENT IS.
TO IS TO POOL OUR RESOURCES AND
GIVE THE PEOPLE.
OF CALIFORNIA.
A BETTER RETURN ON THEIR MONEY
ON THEIR TAXES ON THEIR FEES.
AND WHY HAVEN'T WE USE BANKING
TO DO THAT.
AND THAT'S THAT'S A QUESTION
THAT NOBODY CAN ANSWER BECAUSE
THEY ALWAYS EQUATE IT WITH RISK.
YEAH OUT EVERYTHING HAS A RISK
CREATING OF GOVERNMENT HAS A
RISK PROVIDING SERVICES HAS A
RISK.
BUT TEST FIT HERE AND SAY THAT
IT WOULD BE A RISK TO DEPOSIT
TAXPAYER FUNDS.
INTO A STATE BANK BUT IT'S NOT A
WRIST TO DEPOSITED INTO.
A PRIVATE BANK THAT'S NOT A
RISK.
END WHEN THE SAME BANKING
INSTITUTIONS SAYS NOT A RISK IS
IS PUSHING.
FOR THE REGULATION.
IN IN WASHINGTON THAT HAS
CAUSED.
A MARKET MELTDOWN.
WE YOU CAN'T FORGET THAT EITHER
WE CAN'T FORGET THAT.
AND WE CAN.
HAVE MORE CONTROL IN TERMS OF
HOW WE LEND THIS MONEY.
IN A BANK AND WE WON'T BE.
AS AS HARD PRESSED TO TURN A
PROFIT BECAUSE WERE NOT
MOTIVATED BY THE IF YOU WERE
MADE MOTIVATED BY LENDING THANK
YOU MISTER SORRY FOR GOING ON
SOLANO YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE GOOD I
I APPRECIATE THAT.
SIR WE SO WE JUST WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR WHICH IS I
DO PASSED TO BANKING FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS I JUST WANT.
TO WE'RE GONNA.
QUICK HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT
IF THAT'S THE CASE IN A WAY SO.
WE ARE AT WE HAVE A HARD OUT.
A LITTLE AFTER ONE O'CLOCK SO
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO ADVANCE IS
WE'D LIKE TO BE TO TAKE A VOTE.
ON THIS BILL.
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE A MEMBERS --
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP THIS ON
CALL WE'RE AT THEN AT CYNICAL
GYRO WHO HAS TWO BILLS IN FRONT
OF US.
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO TAKE CARE OF
THOSE TWO BILLS WE WILL THEN
RECONVENE BETWEEN ONE THIRTY AND
ONE FORTY IN ROOM -- TWENTY
FORTY FOR AN AFTERNOON SESSION
IN A WAY SO QUICKLY IF YOU DON'T
MIND CLOSING AND I APOLOGIZE I
JUST CLOSE OKAY -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
LET ME LET ME CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS IF ANYTHING.
I THINK WE COULD HAVE A
WONDERFUL CONVERSATION -- FOR
THIS LIST NESTLE I DON'T SEE ANY
REASON WHY.
I CAN HAVE YOUR SUPPORT TO AT
LEAST WORK ON THIS FOR THE NEXT
--
THIS THIS LEGISLATIVE SEASON I
THINK THERE ARE MERITS AND AND
THIS BILL AND IT'S WORTHY.
OF YOUR SUPPORT JUSTICE SIMPLY
EXPLORE HOW WE CAN BETTER SERVE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAVE TAXPAYERS
MONEY.
AND AND HELP OUR OUR CITIES
THRIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER HUESO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY CENTER BELL DO
PASSED TO BANKING FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS.
ISN'T JUST A ROLL CALL PLEASE
WIRE [inaudible]
LARA.
WELL I KNOW WELL.
HERTZBERG.
HELLO.
NIELSEN WIENER.
WIENER HIGH [inaudible]
WELL I REALLY ENJOYS A TWO ZERO
VOTE OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THIS WHOLE OPENS AGAIN ONE
EXCUSE ME I APOLOGIZE EIGHT TWO
ONE TWO ONE WE'RE TO KEEP THIS
--
ROLE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE NUMBERS
ADD ON THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
HUESO.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEMS TWELVE IN ITEM
[inaudible] EIGHTEEN FIRST
WE'RE GONNA START WITH SB FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN CENTER COPYRIGHT
WILL FOCUS AND LEANS IN ACTING
CANNABIS.
WHEN ANY CAN BE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR PLANNING AND ZONING?
WE'RE GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO CENTER CUT THE AIRLINE
SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN AGAIN.
QUICK HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT.
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE IS GOING
TO HAVE A HARD AT RECESS A HARD
RECESS.
A BIT AFTER. ONE PM -- WE WILL
NAME READ JOURNAL -- AT BETWEEN
ONE THIRTY AND ONE FORTY IN.
TWENTY FORTY IF YOU ARE WAITING
FOR ADDITIONAL BILLS I WOULD USE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
GO GRAB SOME GRUB -- AS A WE
WILL BE RECONVENING BETWEEN ONE
THIRTY AND ONE FORTY IN ROOM
TWENTY FOURTEEN I APOLOGIZE
FOLKS IN NYC THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE.
CENTER CAREER YOUR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ON SB.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN CHOIR -- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN MEASURE THAT
WOULD ALLOW CANNABIS AND
INDUSTRIAL HEMP CULTIVATORS. TO
RECEIVE THE SAME PROPERTY TAX
ASSESSMENT.
AND RELIEF AS OTHER AGRICULTURE
SECTORS IN THE STATE BY
INCORPORATING THEM INTO THE
WILLIAMSON ACT WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TODAY.
THE CALIFORNIA LAND CONSERVATION
ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE ALSO
KNOWN AS THE WILLIAMSON ACT
ESTABLISH A MEANS TO PROTECT THE
AGRICULTURAL AND OPEN SPACE LAND
BY REDUCING THE BURDENS IMPOSED
BY REASON RISING PROPERTY TAX
RATES.
THE ACT ALLOWS PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS TO ENTER INTO
CONTRACT CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENTS
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
VOLUNTARILY RESTRICT THEIR LAND
TO AGRICULTURAL AND COMPATIBLE
OPEN SPACE USES.
THIS RESULT IN SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENTS
WHICH ARE BASED UPON INCOME
GENERATED RATHER THAN THE
POTENTIAL MARKET VALUE OF THE
PROPERTY.
AND IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THIS ACT
SAVES AGRICULTURAL LANDOWNERS
ANYWHERE FROM 2275% IN PROPERTY
TAX LIABILITY EACH YEAR.
HOWEVER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AT
THEIR DISCRETION ARE ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHICH AG PRODUCTS ARE
DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR THE ACT.
SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN WOULD LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD AND PROVIDE
THAT THE CULTIVATION OF CANNABIS
PURSUANT TO CERTAIN TYPES OF
CULTIVATOR LICENSES ISSUED TO
THE MEDICAL AND ADULT USE
CANNABIS REGULATION AND SAFETY
ACT.
IS A COMPATIBLE USE OF OF LAND
UNDER WILLIAMSON ACT CONTRACT
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE INCLUDE
CANNABIS AND INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
CULTIVATORS WITHIN THE IT'S AN
ACCIDENT THEY CAN RECEIVE THE
SAME TAX ASSESSMENT IS OTHER
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTION PRODUCTS
IT TO VERY SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
STEP.
INSIDE THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY WITH ME TODAY IS CASEY
O'CONNOR FROM THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WHEN I SAY
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO INTO
THE STATE TREASURER FOR OTHER
THANK YOU SEE O'CONNOR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR STATE
TREASURER FEE ON A MALL -- I'LL
KEEP THIS QUICK SINCE WE HAVE TO
MOVE BUT WHEN THE TREASURE WAS
AT THE BE -- WE WE TALKED ABOUT
WAYS TO HELP INCENTIVIZE
CANNABIS FOLKS COMING TO THE
REGULATED MARKET WE FOUND THIS
IS A UNIQUE WAY IF WE CAN
CLARIFY THIS LAW -- THAT STATES
THAT CANNABIS AND HEMP CULTURE
ELIGIBLE BE INCLUDING PROPERTY
TAX ASSESSMENTS -- UNDER THE
WILLIAMS ACT WITH CANNABIS AS
COMPATIBLE USE ONLY THEM.
IN OUR CONVERSATION THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION WHO I
WANT TO SAY HAS NOT TAKEN A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL WE
JUST CHECKED IN WITH THEM.
THERE HAS BEEN CONFUSION AROUND
THIS -- BEING INCORPORATED
BILLION SNACKS OR BILL JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT THIS IS A FLUID
PROCESS WE WANT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
MAKE SURE.
THERE AREN'T ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES BUT WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TO KEEP THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
SMITH WITH THE RURAL COUNTIES
ASSOCIATION THE INITIAL VERSION
THIS BILL WE HAD SOME CONCERNS
ALTHOUGH WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
COMMITTEES ADOPTING ALONG WITH
SENATOR COVER YOUR WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT WE REALLY.
APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AND
COURAGE THIS BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD.
THANKS MUCH FOR SMITH WE'D LIKE
TO TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF TWO COULD PLEASE
RISE COME FORWARD.
PERSON LAST NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
SURE MEMBERS AT A FRANK ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THINK IT'S FRANCO.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESERVE THE COMMITTEE KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEMP COUNCIL NO
OFFICIAL POSITION ACTUALLY ON
THE BILL TODAY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT.
BY VIRTUE OF IT ALREADY BEING AN
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITY.
AT SO WE ARE HOPING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR ADAM.
ON THE BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
THANKS ALWAYS GOOD SEEM IS FOUND
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD
LIKE TO TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE KNOW LIKELY HAD
OPENED UP TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE OPPOSITION IF YOU PLEASE
COME FORWARD THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED.
CURRENCY NINE AYE SOME QUICK
COMMENTS BUT I WANT TO TURN IT
OVER TO THE COMMITTEE TO BE A TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTONS
COMMENTS.
AND OR EMOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
WINNER ON SB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR FOR WAITING INTO THIS
TOUGH SUBJECT -- AND I
UNDERSTAND INTO.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
GOOD SENATOR I THOUGHT WE SHOULD
HAVE GONE FARTHER.
AND IT IS A TOUGH SUBJECT -- THE
AND THE SENATOR IS NAVIGATING
AND WALKING A FINE LINE AND I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU BUT I I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT PIECE LIKE
IT OR NOT.
CANNABIS IS LAW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO IT'S A ALSO AN OFFICIAL
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT AND THAT'S
WHAT THE WHIMS IN ACT IS
INTENDED TO BE A TO PROTECT ITS
AGRICULTURAL LANDS.
I UNDERSTAND WE WANT TO BE A TO
PROVIDE COUNTIES.
FLEXIBILITY AND IT'S THE LAW.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP BEFORE TO
WORKING IN THE SKY -- ON FUTURE
AND AGAIN I KNOW YOU'RE WALKING
THAT FINE LINE MAN SENATOR AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK.
IF YOU TAKE THE TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS PLEASE THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
THANK YOU NO THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY SENATOR WINNERS DO PASSES
AMENDED. TO PASS AS AMENDED
FLOOR ISN'T JUST A ROLL CALL
PLEASE [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
AS CHAIR.
Q. I APOLOGIZE ADULT GOODMAN
CLARIFICATION -- IS CANNABIS ARE
RECOGNIZED AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS
IT IS.
WHAT CODE SECTION IT'S PROP --
SIXTY FOUR IT WAS RESOLVED IN
PROP SIXTY FOUR YES OKAY I DID
NOT HAVE IN MY NOTES AFFECT
THANK YOU.
I WE HAVE A MOTION EN DO WE HAVE
--
WE HAVE A MOTION THIS GO TO ROLL
CALL PLEASE MISSING JUST FOR
CHOIR.
WHY I'M MORE A LOT?
HI MORE LIKE ARDELL.
I HERTZBERG RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO WINNER.
WIENER AYE.
IS CURRENTLY EIGHT FOUR ONE VOTE
FOR WENT OVER AND KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M GONNA.
MOVES QUICKLY AND AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE -- THIS COMMITTEE AND
I APOLOGIZE THAT WE'RE DOING A
LITTLE BIT OF A RUSH THAT COULD
TURN IT OVER ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN SB SEVEN FOUR FORMS
COME HERE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER WIENER THIS IS
A DO PASSED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY -- WE DO NOT HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
SO HAVE YOU PLEASE PRESENT YOUR
STATEMENT BUT YOU DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
I WON'T GO INTO THAT WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS WHY WE REALLY NEED
pTO FOCUS ON MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES
LET ME JUST SAY THAT -- THIS
BILL IS REALLY -- SPONSORED --
BY THIS STEINBERG INSTITUTE SO
THAT WE CAN GET AN EXPEDITED
REVIEW PROCESS -- IT SETS UP UP
AS A PARADIGM OR FRAMEWORK --
WHERE IF -- A PIECE OF PROPERTY
IS ZONED -- FOR MULTI FAMILY USE
THAT YOU CAN'T DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST -- BUILDING UNITS -- FOR
HOMELESS MENTALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS AND SO IN A NUTSHELL
IT'S HAS AN EXPEDITED JUDICIAL
REVIEW PROCESS AND THERE'S BY
RIGHT -- AT THE SET UP IS A BY
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO TO BUILD
THESE UNITS AND WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WE
WOULD LET WELCOME -- ANY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST AND
WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMUTING
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON A TRYING TO THROW
THAT'S WHAT THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE AND I JUST.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AIBO WE ARE
THE PROUD SPONSORS OF SB SEVEN
FOUR FOUR AND WE ARE HERE TO
KIND OF CONTINUE THE VOTERS WISH
WHICH WAS TO BUILD SUPPORT OF
HOUSING PROPOSITION TWO AS YOU
KNOW.
HOW PASSED OVERWHELMINGLY AND --
LAST YEAR AS LAST YEAR'S
NOVEMBER BALLOT AND WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY TO END
THE CYCLE OF HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S GOOD TO
SEE POLICING TO GET A GOOD MAYOR
FOR ALL OF HIS WORK IN THE
ENTIRE TEAM WE HAVEMR BUT WE
LIVE IN A PERSON. TWENTY BELOW
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SEE SIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
JOHN KENNEDY WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS BILL HAD TO WAIT AN EXTRA
LARGE PROJECT DELIVERY AND TRIES
TO AVOID LITIGATION CHOKE
POINTS.
THAT WOULD DELAY THESE FILE
PROJECTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
KENNEDY.
WELCOME ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT-OF COULD PLEASE COME FOR
THIS
TIME THOSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
JUST WANNA CONFIRM SIR YOU ARE
COMING IN A POST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WALKED ME TO COMMITTEE
FOR SOME LASSEN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
MEMBERS TEN POINT FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OUR
ISSUES HAVE TO DO WITH COURT
IMPACTS IN THE ADVERSE IMPACT
ANOTHER LITIGANTS WHICH WILL.
PICK UP WITH THE BILL MOVES FOR
BUT JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT FOR
THE RECORD THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GRATEFUL THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US -- FOR THE MORNING HERE.
BACK TO WHERE WELCOME ANYONE
ELSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
PLEASE ADVANCE.
WE HAD A MUCH MY CENTER WINNER
AND WE AT THE PROUD SECOND.
BYCENTER VAL -- WOULD LIKE TO
ADD A CINEMA LEXICON FOR THIRD
LIKE TO OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
NO QUESTION I WHISPERED AS FOR
THIS ONE PUT OUT OF THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY SUPPORT TODAY -- SAY
WHAT I SAID AND HOUSING THAT --
WE NEED TO WE'RE GONNA BE
STREAMLINING AND WE HEAR THIS A
LOT WHENEVER WE STREAMLINED
ANOTHER SPORTS ARENA.
PEOPLE SAY WHEN I'M GONNA START
STREAMLINING HOUSING AND I THINK
IT'S FRANKLY -- APPALLING THAT
WE HAVE A STREAMLINED FOR ARENAS
WHICH HAVE SUPPORTED.
BUT NOT FOR HOUSING WHICH IS
WHERE PEOPLE LIVE AND I LOVE
GOING TO CONCERTS IN THE
BASKETBALL GAMES BUT I LOVE
LIVING IN A HOUSE EVEN MORE --
AND SO IT'S TIME THAT WE START
PUTTING OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS ON HOUSING I WILL ALSO
SAY.
I DO UNDERSTAND THE RESPECT THE
POSITION OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL.
BECAUSE WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
CALIFORNIA IS WE'VE ALLOWED
SEQUEL -- TO SPIRAL INTO THIS.
ALL ENCOMPASSING THING IT'S SUCH
AN IMPORTANT LAW.
AND THEN IT GETS USED TO SHUT
DOWN.
NAVIGATION CENTERS WHICH IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO SHUT DOWN
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING TO SHUT DOWN
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY INFILL
HOUSING. TO SHUT DOWN PROJECTS
THAT HAVE NO CONCEIVABLE LINK TO
THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND WE YOU KNOW AND THEN WE DUMP
IT ALL ON THE COURTS AND THE
COURTS HAVE TO ABSORB ALL OF
THAT WITH OR WITHOUT A
STREAMLINING -- AND SO I THINK
WE DO NEED TO TAKE A STEP BACK
AND MAKE SURE THAT SEQUEL IS
ACTUALLY BEING USED FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL -- OF THIS IS A
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT LONG
TERM CONVERSATION BRING LABOR
AND ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
EVERYONE TO THE TABLE. TO WORK
TOGETHER -- TO FIX THE PROBLEM
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WINNER.
ABOUT QUICKLY DOES THOUGH OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ADVISORY
COMMISSION MEMBER.
AND YOU KNOW CAMPAIGNING FOR
PROPOSITION ONE TWO LAST YEAR WE
HEARD A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT.
WELL WE WANT TO GET PROPOSITION
TO PASS BUT WE WANT.
WE WANT TO HOUSING FOR THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE.
OF A COMPLETE AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE SO SO I THINK THIS BILL
--
IT GOES WITH THE SPIRIT OF
PROPOSITION TWO WE CAMPAIGN HARD
WE WORKED HARD -- WE HEARD A LOT
OF VOTERS AND AND IT PASSED
OVERWHELMINGLY -- SO NOW THE
VOTERS HAVE SPOKEN.
IT IS TIME TO IMPLEMENT WITH THE
DAYS TOLD US TO DO AND I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL BECAUSE
THIS WILL HELP US GET THOSE.
PEOPLE.
HOUSING OFF THE STREETS THAT ARE
MENTALLY ILL.
AND YOU KNOW THE SAME TIME I'D
HAVE TO SAY -- WHAT A BETTER
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT FOR THEM?
YEAH I WAS GOING TO BE A GREAT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT FOR THE
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR BANK
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK AND
GENERALLY YEARS WORKING.
GET A CLOSING STATEMENT --
SCURRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO BETTER
ADVANCE ACTUALLY ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH WITH
THE MOTION THE FLOOR BY CENTER
WINNERS IS A DO PASS
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
THIS THING JUST -- ACCOMPLICES
CHOIR HI WHY I'M MORE LAW.
YEAH Là GUIDE BELL.
WELL I HERTZBERG RICARDO
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO WINNER WIENER HIGH
FOUR ONE FOUR ONE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS
MEMBERS WE LIKE TO BE A ADD ON
REAL QUICK ADD ON US IN A WINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD ON TO
BILLS WE'RE GONNA DO IN THE FIVE
MINUTES WE HAVE LEFT.
START WITH CONSENT THAT'S ONE
ITEM ITEM SIXTEEN SB -- SIX
THIRTY SEVEN IS THERE A MOTION
TO BE ABLE TO APPROVE ITEM.
SIXTEEN ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT NOW
DAY SENATOR BELL IS IN A NO
THANKS TO THE VICE CHAIR ALL
RIGHT AT THE YEAH EXACTLY.
ALL RIGHT -- WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY SIR ABOUT DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS MISSING JUST RECALL
PLEASE.
I WHY I'M MORE A LOT MORE LIKE
VAUDEVILLE.
WELL I HERTZBERG MODEL NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
HI FIVE FIVE ZERO THAT BILL IS
ON HOLD WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING
ITEM TO SB.
THIRTEEN THIS HAS THE DO PASSES
A MINIATURE PREPARATIONS.
MOTIONLESS LANCASTER.
I DO NOT HAVE A MOTION THIS YEAR
--
I APOLOGIZE OKAY SO I DO HAVE A
MOTION ON SB THIRTEEN ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE
CHAIR TO PASS AS A MANAGER
PREPARATIONS MISSING CHESTER
WICKWIRE I WHY I'M MORE LAW.
ALONGSIDE BELL.
I HERTZBERG HELLO NIELSEN.
BILLS AND I WINNER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A BIPARTISAN
LOVE FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM THREE SB FIFTEEN CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A TWO ZERO VOTE. TO PASS
A HOUSING COMMITTEE MISSING
CHESTER WARLOCK.
WELL I KNOW HERTZBERG.
HELLO NIELSEN.
WIENER HI WIENER I HAVE THREE
ONE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ONE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKING --
WITH CENTER WIENER IN THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM FIVE
SB.
ONE SIX TWO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER THIS IS A DO
PASSED YOU APPROPRIATIONS IS
LANCASTER.
WIRE BY WHY I'M MORE A LOT MORE
LIKE GOD BILL.
I HERTZBERG RICARDO NIELSEN I
BILLS AND I WINNER.
WHEN HIGH?
LOOK AT ACT.
A BIPARTISAN FIST BUMP.
FIVE ZERO NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB ONE EIGHTY TWO
JACKSON.
THIS IS A DO PASS TO RULES FOR
CONSIDERATION OF A RE REFERRAL
TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE AND
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN IN THAT
NEXT COMMITTEE WE CURRENTLY HAVE
A FOUR ZERO VOTE.
MISSING CHESTER MORE A LOT MORE
A LOT NO HERTZBERG RICARDO.
WE HAVE A FOUR ONE CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR OH ONE VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SP ONE EIGHTY NINE
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE PREPARATIONS MOTION. FOR
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE MISSING CHESTER.
HERTZBERG OR TITLE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HIGH ZERO FIVE EIGHT
ZERO WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO SB THREE
ZERO NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
PREPARATIONS.
MISSING CHESTER MCGUIRE FIVE WHY
I'D DEL.
WELL I HERTZBERG HER TITLE
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER [inaudible]
I'M WHERE.
YOU HAVE. FIVE FIVE FIVE SIZE
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
ROLE OPEN MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOR FIVE
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ONE VOTE
MISSING CHESTER HERTZBERG --
TARO.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT
LIKE THAT FOR ONE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB.
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT DO PASSED TO
BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
TWO ONE VOTE MISSING CHESTER
FLYER [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HELLO NIELSEN.
YES AND NO TO TO TO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR NOW MOVING
ON TO SB FIVE THIRTY TWO THIS IS
A DO PASSED TO HOUSING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN WITH
CENTER WIENER IN HOUSING
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A TWO TO VOTE.
ST CHESTER [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
WIENER.
I AM.
FOURTEEN THERE ARE THREE TWO
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE TWO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE.
SEVERAL BILLS STILL LEFT AND I'D
SAY AN HOUR AND A HALF.
MAYBE TWO DEPENDING ON THE VICE
CHAIR -- SO WE HAVE -- IS.
I DON'T ONE THAT'S AS BEING NINE
ITEM FOR SB FORTY EIGHT ITEM TEN
SB THREE THIRTY ITEM ELEVEN AS
BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT ITEM FIFTEEN
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT THAT ONE'S
TROUBLE -- AND THEN THE LAST ONE
IS ITEM SEVENTEEN AS V..
SIX EIGHTY ONE SO -- PLEASE
BRING YOUR FOCUS -- TO THE
AFTERNOON SESSION.
I NOT YET.
WE'RE GONNA BE RECONVENING FROM
RECESS. ONE THIRTY TO ONE FORTY
ISHE.
IF -- WE WILL BE BACK IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ONE THIRTY ONE
FORTY ISSUE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
AGAIN THANK YOU.
TO BOTH SIDES BOTH REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRATIC STAFFER OTHER
WORK TODAY
THE AFTERNOON EDITION.
OF THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
INTO OUR TEN OF OUR HEARING.
WE WELCOME YOU HOPE EVERYBODY
HAD AN ABILITY TO GET A BITE TO
EAT.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT. TO DO A
GET SOME QUICK HOUSEKEEPING ON
THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT
OF US FOR THE AFTERNOON.
AS YOU CAN SEE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A WOMAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND
CENTER SKINNER HERE WAS GOING TO
PRISON IN ON SB -- THREE THIRTY
AD THEN WE HAVE SB SIX EIGHTY
ONE STERN.
MISTER BELL IT SB NINE MISTER
WEINER WITH SB.
FORTY EIGHT MISTER HERTZBERG AT
SP.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT AND MISTER
MOORE LOCKET.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT SO WE ARE OFF
AND RUNNING AND WE WELCOME
CENTER SKINNER TO COMMITTEE ON A
ALSO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM BERKELEY.
FOR ALL OF OUR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE WE HAVE GONE
BACK AND FORTH FOR LIKE THREE
WEEKS -- IN IT'S EEN ABOUT
COLLABORATION AND COOPERATION
AND I JUST CANNOT SAY THANK YOU
ENOUGH -- TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FOR WORKING WITH US I THE ENTIRE
TIME THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU I'M CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE --
YES DEAD DILIGENCE THAT YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF SHOWED WAS
VERY VERY IMPRESSIVE AND I THINK
WE GOT TO A GOOD SPOT AND I'M
HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
AND NOW LET ME -- AS A SO I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WE CAN GO INTO A
LITTLE DETAIL ON THOSE LATER BUT
LET ME JUST SAY WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF MY BILL.
SB THREE THIRTY RECOGNIZES THAT
CALIFORNIA IS IN A HOUSING
CRISIS.
WHY ARE WE IN A CRISIS OR
WHATEVER THE INDICATORS THAT
DEMONSTRATE TO US THAT WE ARE IN
THIS CRISIS WE ARE THE?
FORTY NINE OUT OF OUR FIFTY
STATES IN NUMBER OF HOUSING
UNITS PER CAPITA.
THE PRICE OF A HOME IN
CALIFORNIA IS TWO POINT FIVE
TIMES THE U. S. AVERAGE SO MOST
ANY OTHER STATE YOU GO TO YOU
WILL PAY.
LESS.
AND YOU WILL HEAR PAY TWO POINT
FIVE TIMES.
OF THE FIFTY CITIES IN THE US
WITH THE HIGHEST RENTS THIRTY
THREE OF THEM ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE HOMELESS POPULATION WHICH I
THINK ALL OF US ARE.
IT WE CAN HARDLY LIVE WITH
OURSELVES BECAUSE WE TO SEE IN
THIS RICHEST NATION AND IN THIS
STATE WHICH IS THE FIFTH HIGHEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. TO SEE
PEOPLE.
IN ON SIDEWALKS IN DOORWAYS AND
INTENT ENCAMPMENTS WE CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT WE'VE COME TO THIS
PLACE.
WHY HAS HOMELESSNESS GREW 16%
JUST FROM?
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BECAUSE THE COST OF
HOUSING ARE TOO HIGH.
THOSE NEWLY HOMELESS.
ARE NOT MENTALLY ILL ARE NOT
ADDICTED.
THEY HAVE JOBS AND THEY HAVE
NEVER BEFOREBEEN HOMELESS.
THEY JUST CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA UNDER OUR CURRENT
PRICES.
KNOW WHAT MY BILL DOES IS
RECOGNIZE THAT WHEN WE'RE IN A
CRISIS IF WE TAKE OTHER CRISES.
FOR EXAMPLE ALL YOU SANTA ROSA
IS A GREAT EXAMPLE AFTER THAT
HORRIFIC FIRE AND SANTA ROSA
LOST SO MANY HOUSING UNITS
GENERAL'S A NEW.
WE NEED TO GET BACK TO NORMAL SO
THEY RELAXED SOME OF THE RULES
THE STREAMLINED PROCESS SEES.
GET IN THOSE HOMES BACK.
WELL WE'RE NOT HERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW TO GET HOMES BACK
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW. TO GET
MORE UNITS ADDED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
NOW SB. THREE THIRTY WELL SOME
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IT OR
THINK THAT IT'S AN OVER REACH
IT'S REALLY A VERY MODEST
MEASURE.
BECAUSE UNLIKE OTHER BILLS IT
DOESN'T ASK LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
TO CHANGE THEIR ZONING OR TWO IN
A WHOLE VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS
IT SAYS LOOK.
IF WE LOOK AT YOUR EXISTING
ZONING THERE IS A LOT HOUSING
THAT COULD FEEL THAT YOU ARE
ALREADY THROUGH YOUR GENERAL
PLAN THROUGH YOUR SECRET
DOCUMENTS OR ANYTHING THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY DECIDED TO ALLOW.
SO WE'RE JUST SAYING OKAY.
DO WHAT YOU DO BUT DO IT FASTER
DO IT MORE EFFICIENTLY.
AND TRIED TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT
REDUCES THE COST TO THE PERSON
WHO IS BUILDING BECAUSE IF WE
CAN REDUCE THE COST OF THAT
HOUSING.
WE NEED BOTH MARKET RATE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE NEED BOTH
KINDS.
BUT IF WE CAN [inaudible]
STREAMLINED.
AND NOT HAVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CHANGE THE RULES MIDSTREAM.
OR NOT ENACT GROWTH CAPS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WOULD STOP
AND GO BACKWARDS ON HOUSING.
JUST FOR A LIMITED TIME PERIOD
THIS BILL WOULD ONLY GOING TO
AFFECT FOR TEN YEARS.
THEN WE MIGHT HAVE THE HOPE OF
GETTING.
THE THREE MILLION.
UNITS BETWEEN NOW AND TWO THIRTY
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
ACTUALLY THAT GO UP BUT IT WILL
IT'S PROBABLY HARD TO DO THAT BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE BUT STILL
THAT'S WHAT THE GOVERNOR SAYS WE
NEED.
THAT'S WHAT THE LA -- SAYS WE
NEED EVERY REPORT THAT LOOKS AT
OUR CRISIS SAYS WE NEED AT LEAST
THREE MILLION MORE UNITS IN TEN
OR SO YEARS SO HOW DO YOU GET
THOSE FASTEST.
BY LETTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO
WHAT THEY'VE ALREADY DONE BUT DO
IT FASTER AND DO IT MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
I WILL LET MY WITNESSES SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND THEN I'LL JUST
BRIEFLY DETAIL WHAT THE
SPECIFICS ARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE.
WHAT IF YOU COULD PLEASE SEE
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME ALONG
WITH ORGANIZATION YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES WE WELCOME YOU COMMITTEE
AND THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US
IN YOUR PATIENCE AND?
APOLOGIZE THAT WE'VE GONE IN THE
AFTERNOON IT'S GOOD TO SEE.
THE TERM ACQUIRE A MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PATRICK
I'LL FOLLOW AND I'M WITH THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE FORTY YEAR OLD OF A
HOUSING ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
I'M BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO BUT
WE DO ADVOCACY AND ALL NINE BAY
AREA COUNTIES.
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY TODAY BECAUSE NO ONE CAN
DISPUTE THAT CALIFORNIA IS AN
AFFORDABLE IS IN AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING EMERGENCY.
AND BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOMES
FOR SENIORS VETERANS PEOPLE'S
WITH THIS ABILITY IS A MORAL
IMPERATIVE AND SB THREE THIRTY
WILL BE A CRITICAL TOOL TO HELP
MAKE THAT A REALITY.
WE ALWAYS SAY IN OUR LINE OF
WORK THAT THERE ARE THREE MAIN
COMPONENTS TO BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- LAND OF
MONEY AND POLITICAL WELL AND SB
THREE THIRTY WILL GREATLY HELP
WITH THE POLITICAL WILL SIDE OF
THE QUESTION.
RIGHT NOW AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS
WITH ANY OTHER HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS SUBJECT TO LOCAL
RULES -- AND WHILE WE ARE HPPY
TO FOLLOW THE RULES THAT ARE SET
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SOMETIMES
THOSE RULES ARE CHANGED
MIDSTREAM.
AND SB THREE THIRTY WILL CREATE
MORE CLARITY THAT THE RULES
UNDER WHICH THE PROJECT WAS
APPROVED.
I WILL NOT MIDWAY THROUGH THE
PROCESS WE HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF A
PROJECT IN BERKELEY WHERE AFTER
HAD BEEN APPROVED THE CHANGE THE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS RESULTING
IN.
NEEDS TO SEEK MORE SUBSIDIES TO
SUBSIDIZE ESSENTIALLY MORE
PARKING UNIT.
AND WE THINK THAT THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS IS.
TO IS TO SERIOUS FOR US TO THE
LATE APPROVAL SUCH PROJECTS ANY
LONGER.
IN THE BAY AREA AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS CAN TAKE
ANYWHERE FROM FOUR TO TEN YEARS
TO GO FROM CONCEPT TO REALITY.
AND BY LIMITING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS TO TWELVE MONTHS FOR NEW
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS SB THREE
THIRTY WILL GREATLY SPEED UP THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE HOMES --
AND FINALLY WE JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS BILL CREATES
MORE CLARITY AND CERTAINTY IN
THE PROCESS AND THAT THIS WILL
NOT ONLY HELP GET MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMES BUILT.
FOR OUR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
BUT ALSO HELP BUILD MORE HOMES
FOR CALIFORNIANS IN GENERAL THAT
ARE.
SEVERELY NEED IT AND SELL --
WITH THAT OF RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THANK YOU PLEASE SIR
WELCOME.
YOUR FIRST LESSON OPPOSITION TO
MANY THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DAVID GARCIA.
I AM THE POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE
TURSUNOV ROUSING INNOVATION AT
UC BERKELEY AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL. THREE THIRTY I
DON'T THINK I I NEED.
TO LABOR THE POINT CALIFORNIA IS
IN THE THROES OF A VERY DEEP AND
WE'RE STAYING.
HOUSING CRISIS AND A BILL SUCH
AS SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
REPRESENT A BOLD STEP TOWARDS
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE HEAD ON
TODAY MORE THAN 50% OF RENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE CONSIDERED
RENT BURDENED.
AND OF THOSE 30% ARE CONSIDERED
SEVERELY RENT FOR IT.
AND ON TOP OF THAT OWNING A HOME
HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
UNACHIEVABLE AS WELL AS WE ARE
WITNESSING.
THE LOWEST RATE OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
SINCE THE NINETEEN FORTIES.
AND AS OUR WORK AT THE TURNER
CENTER HAS SHOWN THIS LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OFTENTIMES IS PUSHING PEOPLE OUT
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES WHICH IN
MANY CASES MEANS THAT THEY'RE
LEAVING THE STATE ENTIRELY.
SO THE SCALE OF THE CHALLENGE IN
FRONT OF US REALLY DEMANDS
POLICIES THAT MATCH THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM AND
THERE ARE FEW PROPOSALS ON THE
TABLE THAT ARE AS BOLD.
AS WHAT SENATE BILL.
THREE THIRTY HOUSES SO BY
PROHIBITING CITIES FROM ENACTING
MORATORIUM'S OR OR DOWN ZONING
THAT WOULD DIMINISH THE CAPACITY
FOR YOU HOUSING WE'RE SENDING A
CLEAR.
AND UNMISTAKABLE MESSAGE THAT WE
ARE NO LONGER GOING TO TOLERATE.
LOOKING PEOPLE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGH EXCLUSIONARY
PRACTICES ESPECIALLY IN THE FACE
OF ONGOING HOUSING PRESSURES.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY WILL
ALSO DO YOU VERY MUCH TO ADDRESS
THE COST OF HOUSING BY MODIFYING
HOWELL PARKING REQUIREMENTS ARE
STRUCTURED.
BY MODIFYING HOW FEES ARE
IMPOSED AND BY CURBING OTHERWISE
REQUIREMENTS OUR WORK HAS SHOWN
THAT.
WHEN TAKEN TOGETHER THESE
REQUIREMENTS AND POLICIES
CUMULATIVELY WILL RAISE THE COST
TO BUILD NEW HOUSING?
SO -- MANY CITIES CONTINUE TO
WORK IN GOOD FAITH TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO HOUSING.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SOME
THAT RELY ON EXCLUSION PRACTICES
TO SKIRT THERE HOUSING
OBLIGATIONS SO WITH THAT I WILL
SAY AGAIN WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND LOOK FOR THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR VERY
GRATEFUL WE KNOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE A WELCOME ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE OF THE FRONT.
WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT FIRST LAST ORGANIZATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THAT THERE MISTER MEMBERS AS ARE
THE OTHER HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL.
I THINK THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US IN
ADDRESSING SOME OF CONCERNS WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA U. M. B. AND SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON SILVIO FOR OUR
AND HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI FOR MANY WOULD LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AND SPORT.
THANK.
TIFFANY VAN ON THE BRIDGE
HOUSING IS PART.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY DO A LAST CALL.
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT LAST CALL?
ALL RIGHT BUT WE WELCOME THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSED TO COME FORWARD.
WE'RE GONNA ASK GERMAN IF YOU
DON'T MIND -- AND YOU CAN COME
RIGHT BACK UP AFTER WE'RE DONE
WITH OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TIME FOR A
PRIMARY A PRIMARY INDIVIDUAL.
FIRST TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
THAT WILL BE FIVE MINUTES.
AND WE HAVE A SECONDARY AT TWO
MINUTES.
SO THIS TORRENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SOCIAL XIN
WE PRODUCE HAD OPPOSING WAS
AMENDED POSITION BUT WE HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION AND
WE'RE NOW NEUTRAL.
DOES A PROVISION OF REGARDING
DEMOLITION IN THE BILL.
THAT WE HAD ISSUES WITH THAT
SINCE BEEN RESOLVED WITH THE
LAST MOMENTS AND JUST WENT THINK
THE CENTER FOR OPENNESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER BAILEY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE THIS AS
FAR AS A PRIMARY WITNESS.
I'M SORRY.
OTHER SCREENING IS GIVES YOUR
FIRST AND LAST AN ORGANIZATION
OF FIVE MINUTES AND WE'LL GO TO
THE CITIES.
FOR GREAT THANK YOU -- SENATE
GEORGIA VISITING AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
J. THE AUTHOR AND HER -- STAFF
WORKING WITH US ON SOME OF THE
CLEAN UP PROVISIONS AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE REALLY
HELPFUL SO COMBINING SOME OF
THOSE THOSE A DIFFERENT SECTIONS
INTO ONE HAS BEEN.
MADE MADE IT MUCH EASIER TO
ACTUALLY READ -- WE DON'T HAVE A
MAJOR PROBLEM WITH THE STRUCTURE
OR THE IDEA THAT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME THINGS THAT JUST ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAPPEN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS WE APPRECIATE THAT -- AN
APPLICATION OF MORATORIUM THAT
MAKING THAT A LITTLE BIT CLEANER
MORE UNDERSTANDABLE AND ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT IF YOU HAVE AN
INCOMPLETE APPLICATION THAT THE
REVISED APPLICATION YOU DON'T
GET TO DO.
NEW INFORMATION THAT YOU DID
REQUIRE IN YOUR CHECKLIST THE
FIRST TIME AROUND SO WE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WE REALLY LIKE IN
THE BILL -- WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE
A SUB OPPOSE IT LESS AMENDED
HOWEVER THE BILL IS NOT CLEAR
AND IT MAY BE CLEARER FOR
DEVELOPERS I DON'T KNOW BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS IN THE
BILL THAT ARE -- NOT.
ARE NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
UNDERSTAND OURSELVES HOW WE BE
ABLE TO COMPLY.
IT ISN'T CLEAR WHAT
JURISDICTIONS ARE IN AND ARE OUT
AND FOR WHAT REASON AND WHAT THE
IMPACT WOULD BE ON EVERY IN
DIVIDEND -- TO EVERY
JURISDICTION THAT WOULD BE IN WE
HAVE A MAJOR PROBLEM WITH ADDING
SOMETHING CALLED A COMPLETE
INITIAL APPLICATION.
THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION THAT'S
THERE WOULDN'T EVEN ALLOW US TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION WHETHER OR
NOT THE THE APPLICATION AND THE
PROJECT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO SEEK
WERE.
THE TIME LINES OF TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD AND ONLY THREE HEARINGS
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE YOU STILL
HAVE TO DO SEE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
YOU SEE C<c.cyan> AND THE
PERMIT</c>
STREAMLINING ACT IN.
TWELVE MONTHS.
DO YOU WANT TO DO THAT YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU GO THROUGH
ALL THE AREAS HEARINGS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE OF THAT.
WHATEVER YOU END UP WITH IS
SECURE IN THE EVENT THAT THERE
IS A SEQUEL LAWSUIT SO.
THOSE THE KIND OF THINGS WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR ON BUT THERE ARE SOME
ON STARTERS LIKE THAT COMPLETED
INITIAL APPLICATION THAT WE
DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY SO --
WE DO HAVE SOME THINGS THAT WE
CANNOT AGREE.
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PLEASE THE CITY'S.
FUTURE MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES I'M CERTAINLY
CONCURRENT COMMENTS FOR MY
COLLEAGUE OVER THE PA.
I'M AYE I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE SENATOR
STAFF FOR REACHING OUT TO US AND
BEING SO WILLING TO WORK WITH US
AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
CONTINUE.
I'M TO WORK IS THAT ALMOST SORT
OF IT DOES WHICH AND COME.
YOU KNOW THE ONE THING WE CAN
ALL AGREE ON ADMISSION FOR THERE
CERTAINLY IS HOUSING CRISIS AND
WE NEED TO BUILD HOMES.
FASTER AND WE NEED A LOT MORE OF
THEM AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
COMMITTED.
TO HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THAT I
THINK WHAT YOU TAKE AWAY FROM
THAT AND AND ONE GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THAT IS.
YOU KNOW THE FREEZING OF IMPACT
FEES FOR THAT DECADE -- AND
OTHER FEES AND EXACTIONS THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY PRECLUDED FROM
IMPLEMENTING BILLS THAT PASSED
THIS LEGISLATURE LIKE AB FIFTY
NO FIVE EXPANDED INCLUSIONARY
ORDINANCES TO INCLUDE RENTAL
HOUSING.
THAT'S A POLICY THE STATE WANTS
OUR CITIES TO ADVANCE WE WOULD
BE PRECLUDED FROM DOING THAT IN
THIS BILL FOR A DECADE.
THE SAME GOES FOR RENT CONTROL
UNDER EXISTING LAW NOW CITIES
CAN IMPOSE RENT CONTROL ON THE
LAWN THE FALL COSTA HAWKINS.
AGAIN THIS WOULD PRECLUDE CITIES
FROM TAKING THOSE ACTIONS FOR
THAT DECADE SO.
AND SO -- WE CERTAINLY THINK
THAT THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
MODIFIED THE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS I'M THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW OUR
LOCALS ALWAYS LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TO MANAGE SO THAT WE CAN MANAGE
PARKING OR COMMUNITIES THIS
AGAIN WOULD FREEZE OUR ABILITY
TO POSE ANY OF PARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR A DECADE.
WHICH AS THE DEVELOPERS
MENTIONED EARLIER -- WOULD SAVE
A GREAT DEAL OF MONEY WHICH IS
AND IN FACT THE CASE BUT THE
STATE ISN'T CAPTURING THAT.
IF YOU USE EXISTING DESI BONUS
ON NOW -- AND YOU DO GET A
WAIVER FROM PARKING REQUIREMENTS
WE GET AFFORDABLEUNITS OUT OF
THAT.
I'M THIS WOULDN'T PASS ON THAT
SAVINGS OR GUARANTEE THAT ANY OF
THESE UNITS WILL BE BUILT OR
RENTED MORE CHEAPLY.
THE COST MY GO DOWN FOR THE
DEVELOPER BUT THERE'S NO
ASSURANCES THAT THE RENTS WILL
GO DOWN OR THE FOR SALE PRICE
WILL GO DOWN.
SO AGAIN WE THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY SHOULD
BE LOOKED AT AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
AND THEN FINALLY I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY THOUGH THAT IF YOU
FREEZE THE OUR FEES FOR TEN
YEARS COSTS WILL CONTAIN TO GO
UP NO MATTER WHAT.
AND THEN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO NECESSARY PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
EITHER TAP OR GENERAL FUND IN
ORDER TO FILL IN THE GAPS OVER
THAT DECADE.
OR WE WILL PROVIDE THAT SERVICE
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S A LEGISLATURE
WANTS US TO DO AND WITH THAT WE
WILL BE CONTENT OR FOR THE
CENTER.
HI MODIFY THE BILL SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY COME INTO SUPPORTER OF
YOUR INITIAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A GREAT
BUT WE LIKE TO OPEN UP FOR
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME PORTS AT YOUR FIRST AND
LAST AS WELL AS ORGANIZATION
[inaudible]
WE WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
OF ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES.
WE APOLOGIZE WE GOT A LETTER IN
ON MONDAY OUR POSITION IS OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED OUR SOLE CONCERN
WITH THE BILL IS THE TEMPORARY
MORATORIUM ON CONNECTION FEES
INCAPACITY CHARGES.
I DO WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
AND HER STAFF WE HAVE HAVE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THAT ISSUE.
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN GET IT
RESOLVED AND IF WE DO WE HAVE NO
FURTHER CONCERNS THE BILL THANK
YOU MISTER ANDERSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE ROSS ON
BEHALF THE CITY SOLANO BEACH IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WOULD
OCCUR THE CONCERNS OF THE LEAGUE
CITIES ANOTHER THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
WELCOME WE HAVE A SQUISHY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JASON I CAN ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION.
S. C. MUA DID NOT TAKE A
POSITION ON SB [inaudible]
THREE THIRTY LARGELY.
MR ACT ANDERSON FROM AQUA
REFERENCE THE ISSUES WITH IMPACT
FEES AND PASSED THE CHARGES.
ARE STANDING IS THAT IT WAS NOT
THE INTENT OF THE SENATOR.
TO INCLUDE CONNECTION FEES AND
TO PASS THE CHARGERS WHEN
CONSIDERING THE LIMITATIONS ON
IMPACT FEES.
WE WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL ONCE
IT GOES JUST TO SENATE HOUSING
AND HOPEFULLY THAT SNATOR
REMAINS COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL.
THANK YOU TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE -- WHO MADE THANK
YOU SO MUCH ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ADVANCED THIS TIME THIS
CAN BE A LAST CALL FOR
OPPOSITION?
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE WE ARE GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
SKINNER FIRST.
RESPOND -- ON ANY ITEMS OF
WITNESS TESTIMONY CENTER
SKINNER.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- WELL FIRST OF
OWNERS SAY THAT I WAS VERY
PLEASED THAT THE PLANNING
ASSOCIATION EXPRESSED THAT THEY
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THEY
REALLY LIKE IN THE BILL.
I'M.
WE I AM -- WILLING TO TALK TO
THE MORE ABOUT THE ISSUE OF THE
COMPLETE INITIAL APPLICATION AND
WHETHER OUR DEFINITION OF IT IS.
OF FAULTY ON SO WE CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PROBLEM
THERE IS WE MAY OR MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO COME TO RESOLUTION BUT
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER WE CAN.
AND THEN THE ISSUE OF THAT DE BY
LANGUAGE MAY BE CONFUSING WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT ANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO FIND.
THE LANGUAGE CONFUSING I THINK
ALL OF US HAVE EXPERIENCED IN
THIS IS WE HAVE A WONDERFUL
LEDGE COUNCIL HERE THAT TRAPS
ARE BILL ARE BILLS.
BUT SOMETIMES THERE IS DRAFTING
LANGUAGE THAT IS HARD FOR THE
INTERVIEWS AFFECTED TO INTERPRET
SO I'M MORE THAN WILLING TO SIT
DOWN.
WITH OTHER WITH A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT ARE THEY IN THE LEDGE
COUNCIL'S DRAFT OF IT IS AS
CLEAR AS POSSIBLE IN A WAY THAT
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
V. I..
THE ISSUES AROUND -- THAT THE
WATER AGENCIES AND MUNICIPAL
POWER ASSOCIATION WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS IN THE FEES IN GENERAL.
I AM CERTAIN THAT WILL COME UP
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND WE WILL
PROBABLY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
SWEET SPOT -- WHAT WE WERE
REALLY TRYING TO DO IS I OPENED
IN THE BILL IS? TO GET.
THE THREE MILLION UNITS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
WE WERE TRYING [inaudible]
TO SHE VIçT.
AT WITH ALSO REDUCING COST
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS AFFORDABILITY AND WE
DON'T WANT.
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR MARKET
RATE HOUSING TO BE ANY MORE
EXPENSIVE.
THAN IT SHOULD BE ANOTHER WORDS
WE DON'T ADD TO THE COST OF THAT
MARKET RATE WHERE WE COULD AVOID
SO THAT WE CAN KEEP SOME LEVEL
OF AFFORDABILITY NOW CLEARLY
THIS BILL DOES NOT INTERFERE.
WITH ANY JURISDICTIONS.
ON DENSITY BONUS ORDINANCES OR
INCLUSIONARY ORDINANCES IT DOES
NOT IT RESPECT ALL OF THOSE SO
IT HAS A AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMPONENT IN THAT FROM THAT
POINT OF VIEW.
BUT OF COURSE IT ALSO SUPPORTS
THE MARKET RATE HOUSING BUT WE
WANT TO TRY TO ACHIEVE IT.
OUT LOWEST COST AS POSSIBLE SO
THE ISSUE OF SPEED WHAT'S THE IT
MAKES HOUSING EXPENSIVE BESIDE
SCARCITY IT IS THE TIME IT TAKES
FROM THE POINT YOU. SEVEN YOU
KNOW TRY TO GET YOUR PERMIT TO
THE POINT YOU GET TO BUILD IT.
AND ANY COSTLY REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE ADDED WHETHER THAT'S PARKING
OR OTHER THINGS SO BUT WE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE OF COURSE
LIKE ANY MEMBER.
ANY AUTHOR I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
A BILL THAT WOULD HAVE NO
OPPOSITION -- WHETHER I CAN
ACHIEVE THAT OR NOT DON'T KNOW
BUT I WILL CERTAINLY TRY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE SKINNER
BUT I COULD OPEN UP FOR THE
COMMITTEE WERE SERVICE CENTER
WINNER AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A SHARE
BEFORE WE START I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS AND I
KNOW THERE WERE THERE WERE --
SERVE.
DISCUSSIONS UNTIL THE AND ON THE
I WANNA MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT THE AMENDMENTS.
ARE SO IF WE COULD WALK THROUGH
THE EXACT AMENDMENTS I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT.
AND THIS BILL IS COMING THE
HOUSING -- MANY.
I'M INTERESTED NINE ONE VOTING
ON ABSOLUTELY SO WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO BE DOING.
EACH OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ALSO RECEIVE THE AMENDMENTS LATE
LAST NIGHT AS WELL EACH YEAR
STAFF.
AND WILL OUTLINE THE FOR IN THE
LAST CENTER SKINNER TO BE ABLE
TO ADD ON IF THERE ARE ANY THE
NAME IS HE LIKELY TO MAKE TO MY
WORDS.
NUMBER ONE IN MANY GRANDFATHER
IN LONG STANDING VOTER APPROVED
GROWTH MANAGEMENT ORDINANCES IN
PREDOMINATELY AGRICULTURAL
COUNTY. FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES MORE BAG PLAN.
IN HALF THE COUNTY OR MORE MUST
BE ANGLING.
AND I CAN I UNDERSTAND MORE WHAT
THAT.
WHAT THAT MEANS IN THIS I MEAN
THAT THOSE -- AND WHAT THOSE
VOTERS OUT INITIATIVE DAR THESE.
ARE THESE COMMUNITIES THAT UP
DOT THE I HOUSING MORATORIUM A
POPULATION COP [inaudible]
HOUSING TOP [inaudible]
OR BECAUSE SOME JUST YOUR I WANT
TO KNOW WHAT WHAT EXACTLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WERE WE GIVEN
PERMISSION TO PUT A MORATORIUM
ON HOUSING.
THESE ARE MOSTLY [inaudible]
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY.
TYPE OF GROWTH MANAGEMENT ORDER.
MANY HAVE BEEN LOOSING SINCE THE
ORIGINAL óRDENES HAVE BEEN IN
BACK.
I IN WHERE AND I'LL LET TENER
SKINNER FILLING SHE THINK THAT
I'M MISREPRESENTING.
I'M IT WAS.
OUR BELIEF THAT WE SHOULD NARROW
WHAT THE ORIGINAL DEFINITION
WHAT.
IT IS NOT FOCUS ON ACTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN ADMINISTRATIVELY
BY COUNSEL. FOR MAINSTREAM PLAN
BUT SIMPLY VOTER APPROVED.
IT'S FULL FOCUS AN AGRICULTURAL
COUNTIES.
WHERE GROWTH INTO AG LANDS WOULD
BE THE GREATEST THREAT?
BECAUSE I DON'T I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WHEN AGRICULTURAL AREAS
SAY WE WANT TO PRESERVE OUR OUR
OUR OUR FARMLAND I DON'T PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
WHAT WHAT I DO HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH THIS ONE COMMUNITIES DECIDE
WE'RE GOING?
TO LOCK DOWN AND NOT HAVE NEW
HOUSING FOR A MORATORIUM ON
HOUSING.
I SOME DO IT THROUGH A
POPULATION COP WHICH IS BIZARRE
AND OUTRAGEOUS TO ME -- AND THEN
WERE A NUMERICAL THING HAVE NO
MORE THAN EXT NUMBER OF HOUSING
UNITS.
AND SO I DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
SAYING WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT ENCROACHING ON TO OUR
PROBLEM WITH FRANK GUYS I AM
OKAY WITH THAT -- AND YOU DO
THAT GROUP BUILDING MORE HOUSING
AND URBANIZED AREAS.
BUT THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN.
PUTTING A MORATORIUM OR A OR A
COP SAYING.
IN IN THROUGH OUR RESEARCH.
OVER THE LAST WEEK WE CAN HALF.
IT WOULD BE MORE CAP ON NUMBER
OF UNITS BUT NOT ON POPULATION.
OKAY NUMBER OF UNITS SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
YOU HAVE A IT'S NOT A IN A NOT
AT ALL TRYING TO BE DIFFICULT --
BECAUSE I KNOW I KNOW YEAH IT'S
IT'S THERE ARE.
THEY'RE JUST DIFFERENT
DEFINITIONS OUT THERE BUT RIGHT
SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU HAVE LET'S
SAY IF TOWN.
THAT IS SURROUNDED BY FARMLAND.
SO -- SO YEAH ARE THESE
SITUATIONS WHERE THE TOWN HAS
SAID YOU CAN INCLUDE IN THE FARM
LAND.
OR WE'RE GONNA SAY IN OUR
URBANITE URBANIZED AREAS -- IN
THE TOWN ITSELF WHICH IS NOT
FORM AND WE'RE PUTTING A CAP ON
THE NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS SOME
MAY HAVE BOTH.
SO IN THE ORIGINAL DISCUSSION --
PLEASE ENTER SKINNER TO FREE TO
ADD IN IF I AM AND STAY CAN.
WE WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT URBAN
GROWTH BOUNDARIES WOULD NOT BE
INCLUDED WITHIN THE BILL.
SO WE ACTUALLY TOOK OUT THE
ISSUE OF URBAN GROWTH BOUNDARIES
BECAUSE WE BOTH BELIEVE.
THAT URBAN GROWTH BOUNDARIES ARE
A GOOD THING.
WHAT IS LEFT AND WHAT IS IN
FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE HERE
TODAY IS ON VOTER APPROVED
GROWTH MANAGEMENT ORDINANCE --
THAT HAVE BEEN OF APPROVED BY
THE LOCAL LOCAL ELECTRIC -- IN
TO BE ABLE TO NARROW THAT
DEFINITION BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE COMMITTEE WAS THAT.
WE FOCUS ON THOSE AGRICULTURAL
AND SMALLER CANCERS BUT THAT
THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE SOME THESE
MEASURES.
THE RED DOT TO GO BEYOND THE
URBAN GROWTH BUT I DON'T PROBLEM
WITH URBAN GROWTH BOUNDARY.
BUT URBAN GROWTH BOUNDARIES.
EARTH MANAGEMENT YOU KNOW THAT
IS IT BEEN PROVED RIGHT WITHIN
THE INTERIOR THE CITY WITHIN THE
INTERIOR OF THE CITY IN OTHER
WORDS IN AREAS THAT ARE NOT
GOING TO RISK PROGRAM.
I'M WONDERING IF WE COULD LIMIT
THAT.
EXEMPTION. TO THE PROTECTION OF
FARMLAND AS OPPOSED TO SAYING IN
OUR CITY WORK HOPPING THE NUMBER
OF HOUSING UNITS THE BILL.
HAS A AYE THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO SAY THAT'S NOT OKAY.
ANYMORE TO TO SAY.
YOU CAN ONLY HAVE X. NUMBER OF
UNITED TENDED TO LEGAL TO BUILD
MORE THAN THAT.
SO UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE
ON THE DICE AT THIS TIME.
HI THIS IS AT AN AGREEMENT THAT
WAS STRUCK I THINK COMPROMISES
WERE MADE ON BOTH SIDES -- AND
BE HAPPY TO HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONON THIS -- BUT THIS
IS THE AGREEMENT THAT IS IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY AND
THE NAME IS THAT WERE
DISTRIBUTED TO EACH OF THE
MEMBERS.
THE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE ADVANCE WAS NO PARKING
MINIMUM.
IN A FOR A QUARTER MILE OF RAIL
STOPS IN CITIES AND COUNTIES --
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND OR
CITIES OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION IN SMALLER COUNTIES.
POINT FIVE SPACES PER UNIT ELSE
WHERE.
I NUMBER THREE INCREASING NUMBER
OF HEARINGS AND SINGLE PROJECT
OFFERED A NOBLE HEARINGS FROM
325% OF YOUR MONEY.
I YES YEP IN THE END THAT IS A
CLARIFICATION Là THAT WE ARE
ADVANCE ON I KNOW THIS CAME FROM
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION.
THAT THAT TWELVE MONTH CLOCK
ONLY STARTS TICKING AFTER SEEK
WHAT.
SO AFTER SEEKERS RATIFIED THEN
THAT TWELVE MONTHS -- STARTS
TICKING SO THAT THE THREE DO
NOVOS GOES TO FIVE ALL WITHIN
THAT SHOT CLOCK OF TWELVE AND IT
WAS A IN THE RESULT IN THE
VERSION BILL BEFORE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THREE THE THAT A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD START UP THE
SEAT WAS WHILE.
I BELIEVE SO YES SO THAT'S WHERE
THE DISCUSSION NOT.
BE A RAISED AROUND.
THE SECRET THING WAS NOT.
IT IS NOT YOUR MAIN BECAUSE
RIGHT THIS WOULD BE AFTER THE
OKAY SO SO GOING FROM THREE TO
FIVE SO WHAT AND ALMOND PERIOD
RIGHT I CAN.
I CAN LIVE WITH THAT BUT I WOULD
JUST I JUST FOR THE RECORD
MISTER CHAIRMAN I KNOW I'M
OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL AND I'M NOT -- OF THE
COMMITTEE ALTHOUGH THE TERM IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE ON I I
STRONGLY DISAGREE.
WITH ALLOWING.
ANY MORATORIUM ON HOUSING.
HOUSING NUMERICAL COP POPULATION
POP TO BE AN IMPACT I DON'T TO
ME IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE A
SMALL CITY.
WORLD A LARGE CITY -- I AM.
VERY MUCH OKAY WITH PROTECTING
FARMLAND.
AND HAVING GROWTH BOUNDARIES TO
PROTECT FARMLAND BUT WITHIN THE
URBANIZED AREAS HAVING THOSE
KINDS A MORATORIUM COPS.
I'M FRANKLY IS ONE OF THE
THINGS.
THAT IS HAS FUELED.
OUR OUR OUR HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS ON THE GROSS ASIAN APENNINE
I RESPECT THAT PROCESS BUT I
WILL EXPRESS MY DISAGREEMENT
WITH THAT.
REMEMBER NO VERY GRATEFUL CENTER
US AND WIENER ANY.
AS A PROMISE A GOOD SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE.
A FROM WHEN I JUST AT ISSUE WELL
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DISCUSSED WAS AN ISSUE AROUND
TIME.
WE AS YOU MENTIONED WE DID
COMPLETELY AGREE ON THAT WE WERE
IN NO WAY TRYING -- TO ELIMINATE
GROWTH BOUNDARIES BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT IN MANY AREAS THOSE
WERE ENACTED TO PROTECT
AGRICULTURAL LAND -- OPEN SPACE
RATHER THINGS.
NOW WE DID HAVE A LOT OF BACK
AND FORTH AROUND CAPPING NUMBERS
OF UNITS BECAUSE OF COURSE THE
WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL.
I'M IS TO HELP US GET THE THREE
MILLION UNITS THAT WE NEED.
AND SO YOU KNOW I DID HAVE
SOMEONE COME TO BILL EIGHTY
WITH.
WITH AYE THOSE RESTRICTIONS BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DISCUSSED THAT WE DIDN'T END UP
INCLUDING.
THAT WE MAY WANT TO REVISIT IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE WASN'T
ANY CAP ON THE NUMBER OF LOW
INCOME UNITS.
SO IN A YEAH WE MAY WANT.
TO REVISE THE AFFORDABILITY
FACTOR YEAH I THINK YEAH
SOMETHING.
IN ONE OF THE ITEMS I WANT BUT
WORDS INTO CENTER SKINNER'S
MOUTH BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE IS ANY ISSUE IN REGARDS TO
AYE AE CAPTAIN AFFORDABLE.
NO WITHIN THOSE THREE CATEGORIES
THAT WOULD BE RENO WHEN AT THE
MODERATE LOW THERE MAY BE SOME
AND YOU KNOW WE'D HAVE TO GET
GRANULAR BUT THAT'S WHERE I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SOME ABILITY.
TO HAVE A DISCUSSION AND WORK IF
WE WERE TO IDENTIFY THAT THERE
WERE SOME THAT THROUGH THIS
AMENDMENT.
WE WERE INCLUDING.
SOME JURISDICTIONS THAT MIGHT
HAVE.
A MEASURE THAT CAPPED LOW INCOME
UNITS WE MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT
THAT AGAIN AND WE DID NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO LOOK IN DETAIL.
NO I M. FIRM BELIEF IN REGARDS
THE WONDER PERCENT AFFORDABLE.
I HOULD NOT BE AS WE DISCUSS
RIGHT SHOULD NOT BE CAP SO HAPPY
BETTER CONTINUE THAT.
WHAT IS IN FRONT OF US THOUGH
TODAY ARE THE AMENDMENTS I THAT
HAVE BEEN?
HAMMERED OUT IN VERY GRATEFUL --
TO SENATOR SKINNER AND HER TEAM
I INTO THE GOVERNOR FIGHT TEAM
HERE'S WELL.
I THINK THAT -- AFTER ANY
NEGOTIATION I THINK I EACH SIDE
WALKS AWAY.
WITH COMPROMISES.
AND KNOW THAT EACH SIDE WALKED
AWAY IN THIS NEGOTIATION WITH
COMPROMISES THROUGH A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH WHICH
WERE VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR I WOULD LIKE TO BE RETURNED
OVER THE VICE CHAIR -- AND THEN
ALSO TO SENATOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I MISSED
THIS THE OPENING PRESENTATION.
AND I CAN'T FIND IT ANYWHERE IN
THE MATERIAL BUT ARE THERE ANY
EXEMPTIONS FOR ANY CITIES OR
COUNTY.
ON THE THE WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS.
IT'S FOR TEN YEARS ONLY.
AND IT BASICALLY RECOGNIZES IT
TELLS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO WHICH
ALREADY DOING.
BUT DO IT FASTER AND SO THE ONLY
THING IT LIFTS IN THE TEN YEAR
PERIOD.
IS.
THAT IT IT.
PUT IT RESTRICTS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FROM ENACTING.
A MORATORIUM ON HOUSING OR
ENACTING A CAP ON HOUSING UNITS
OR DOWN ZONING DURING THAT TEN
YEAR PERIOD SFI ANY PARTICULAR
CITIES YEAH BUT WHAT IT DOES IS.
IT APPLIES BASED ON HARD
CRITERIA [inaudible] FOR
VACANCY.
AND HI RENTS SO THERE ARE RURAL
AREAS IN THE STATE THAT DON'T
GET INCLUDED.
AND AND I AM CERTAINLY WILLING
TO SEND TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
LA -- DEVELOPED A TOOL FOR US
WHERE.
THE THE HIDE CRITERIA THAT WE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL THE LA --
STEEP TOOL ALLOWS YOU TO SEE
EXACTLY WHICH RURAL AREAS IN THE
STATE THEN AREN'T COVERED.
AND THE REASON IS THAT.
THIS THOSE AREAS ARE NOT
EXPERIENCING THE HOUSING PRICES
THEY'RE NOT EXPERIENCING HIGH
HIGH COSTS THEY'RE NOT
EXPERIENCING.
REALLY A LOW VACANCY RATES SO.
THIS IS NOT A NECESSITY TO ASK
THEM TO DO EVERYTHING FASTER
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
THROUGH THIS.
IS THAT GETTING THOSE THREE
MILLION UNITS OF HOUSING WE NEED
IN THOSE NEXT TEN YEARS.
AS AS MUCH AS IN REFLECTING WHAT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
ALREADY AGREED.
THAT TO WHAT THEY WANT IT'S JUST
LET'S DO IT A LITTLE FASTER AND
DON'T CHANGE THE RULES
MIDSTREAM.
SO SCRATCHES WERE AGES
[inaudible]
YEAH SO.
CITIES CERTAIN COUNTIES LIKE
MARIN ARE NOT EXCLUDED THEIR THE
SAME AS ANY OTHER [inaudible]
COUNTY.
YES MARIN SAID OR HUNTINGTON
BEACH.
EXACTLY.
WHAT I MENTIONED MARIN THEY
HAVE?
NO WELL THEY WERE EXEMPTED UNDER
A DIFFERENT.
THIS.
THE BUDGET ACT BUT THAT IS NOT.
THAT.
ANY CITY IN MARIN UNDER THIS
MEASURE.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT A
PREDOMINATELY AGRICULTURAL
COUNTY.
AND PLUS THE PRE DONNELLY
AGRICULTURAL COUNTY ONLY DEALS
WITH GROWTH -- RESTRICTIONS
ANYWAY BUT ANY CITY IN MARIN
COUNTY.
AND THEY'VE ALL GOT THEIR OWN
ZONING RULES.
AND I I DON'T WANT TO SAY EVERY
BUT THE MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE
ZONE SOME PORTIONS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES FOR HOUSING.
RIGHT TO DESERVE A SEAT BUT BUT
THEY ALL EVERYBODY HAS SOME
PARTS OF ZONING OF HOUSING AND
THEIR NOT YET.
IF YOU WERE TO LOOK AT THEIR
THEIR ZONING YOU COULD PROBABLY
FIND AREAS WHERE IT'S NOT YET.
COME A COMPLETELY BUILT OUT IN
OTHER WORDS A DAY.
AND SO WHAT THIS DOES IS SAYS.
UNDER EXISTING ZONING LAWS.
IF I COME IN APPLY. TO BUILD ONE
HOUSE AN APARTMENT THREE HOUSES
AND IF THAT YOUR RULES.
THEN YOU'VE AN AYE YOU TELL ME
WHAT NEEDS TO BE IN MY
APPLICATION I SUBMIT MY
APPLICATION.
AND IT'S COMPLETE THEN YOU GOT
TO GIVE ME THE PERMIT IN ONE
YEAR.
YOU GOT A PROCESS MY PERMITTING
YEAR WHATEVER AMOUNT HEARINGS
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU GOT TO
HAVE IN THAT YEAR.
AND SO THAT WE CAN GET THAT
HOUSING THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS PLEASE I ACTUALLY --
FOR AYE AND QUESTIONS PER -- FOR
A BA IN THE LEAGUE OF CITIES.
WHEN THEY WERE UP HERE I DON'T
WANT TO INTERRUPT THE FLOW --
pMIND I EACH OF YOU RE
INTRODUCING YOURSELVES.
THANK YOU I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
BOTH A PA AND THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES CAUSED UNCLEAR TO MELIKE
YOU'RE.
YOU'RE POSING THE BELL BUT THEN
YOU REYES SORT OF SOME -- REALLY
TECHNICAL -- OBJECTIONS TO IT
BUT YOU KNOW THE HEART OF THIS
BILL IS -- FIRST OF ALL THE YOU
KNOW WAS CLARIFIED THAT IT
DOESN'T INTERFERE WITH A CAMERA
BUT THIS IS THE TWELVE MONTHS
AFTER SHE WAS DONE SO THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE AN INVALID.
OUR CRITIQUE OF THE BELL -- SOME
GLAD THE RECORD GOT CORRECTED ON
THAT THIS WHOLE NOTION -- IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO DO THAT IT
IS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
I'M.
BUT I THE THE HEART OF THE BILL
IS REALLY SAYING [inaudible]
YOU CAN.
THERE ARE THESE TOOLS THAT
FRANKLY WEALTHY COMMUNITIES HAVE
USED FOR MANY YEARS TO KEEP FIVE
ONE CALL IT HOURS OR WEALTHY
COMMUNITIES.
THAT HAVE CREATED OVERWHELMINGLY
WEALTHY COMMUNITIES THANK THIS
IS OUR WAY TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT --
HAVE NO CHANGE IN OUR COMMUNITY
IMPRISONED AMBER THEY WERE GONNA
PUT A MORATORIUM ON HOUSING.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT A POPULATION
COPPER GROWTH COP OR GOING TO
DOWN ZONE.
AND SAY WE'RE GONNA NOW BANNED
APARTMENT BUILDING.
AND WHEN THE STATE HASN'T RESIST
HISTORY OF USING THESE TOOLS TO
MY QUESTIONS THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES.
AN API IN TERMS OF THIS BILLS
TEN YEAR.
PROHIBITION ON DOWN ZONING ON
POPULATION COPS ON GROWTH COPS
ON HOUSING MORATORIUM.
DO YOU THE DO A PA AND LEGAL
CITIES [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
DOT PORTION OF THE BILL.
THURMOND COMMENTS OFF.
HEY I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT MY
PHONE IS ON WE'RE GOOD.
I'M WE DO SUPPORT THE
CLARIFICATION OF THE APPLICATION
FOR THESE GROWTH ORDINANCES WE
DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR THAT SOME
JURISDICTIONS GET THE LIMIT
HOUSING UNITS.
IN THEIR JURISDICTION SO -- I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION ON THE SEQUEL IF I
WAS WRONG I APOLOGIZE BUT THE
WAY WE READ IT BECAUSE OF SOME
OF THE STATEMENTS IN THERE.
IT WASN'T CLEAR SO THAT IT'S NOW
CLEAR.
THANKFUL FOR THAT.
AND THE OTHER SEPARATED SO THE
ON SONY DOWN.
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE THEM SO AFTER
THE BILLS FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS
BUT WE DO NOT SUPPORT DOWN SONY
AND LESS IT'S TO REARRANGE
THINGS AND YOU HAVE THE SAME
KNOWN AT LOS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION SO IF YOU WANT TO
DO SOMETHING ELSE HERE.
NO MATTER WHETHER THE HEALTHY
AND WE'RE NOT WE SUPPORT
REQUIRING THAT YOU OF PLACE ELSE
YOU DON'T LOSE OUT.
OKAY TO THE BAD THE BAN ON
POPULATION COP.
COP MORE THROUGHOUT YOUR KIDS OR
TIME LESS IT'S IT'S BECAUSE OF A
FIRE RELATED ISSUE OR UNLESS YOU
HAVE NO WATER THOSE TWO THINGS
THAT WERE TURNED ABOUT SO.
AT ME A TEMPORARY MORATORIUM
UNTIL THOSE THINGS THANK YOU IN
LATER TODAY IT IS RIGHTLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE SERVE OCCUR
I MEAN IN MY JUST MY ONLY TALKED
THINGS WE DIDN'T LIKE -- BUT
CERTAINLY THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WE WE WE AGREE WITH AND JUST TO
ADD A LITTLE MORE THE DOWNS I
MEAN I MEAN.
DOWNTURN IN ITSELF IN.
CENTERS CAN HAVE THE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN LAST YEAR THE DOUGH AND
KNOWN AS LOSS OR MEANS YOU'RE
BEFORE.
YEAH NO NET LOSS.
RIGHT RIGHT.
THE QUESTION IS DOES THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES SUPPORT THE
PROHIBITION ON DOWN ZONING
HOUSING MORATORIUM POPULATION.
GROWTH.
WE DON'T HAVE EXISTING POLICY TO
SUPPORT THAT BUT WE CERTAINLY DO
NOT OBJECT TO THE LEGISLATURE
WANTING TO TAKE THOSE ACTIONS.
OKAY SO IT IF THAT IT'S NOT ALL
BILL BUT ABOUT WHERE THE VALUE
TO THOSE -- YOU WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY CERTAINLY YES WOULD NOT BE
HERE CORRECT OKAY.
WHAT ONE THING THAT I ALL AND
THANK GOOD INTELLIGENCE I MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- I DO WANNA --
SPECIFICALLY WITH A P. A. B..
ABOUT.
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT BILLS -- I
WOULD I WOULD TEST I WAS ONE OF
MY JUST MY OWN OPINION -- I I
FEEL LIKE SOMETIMES A PA HAS
TECHNICAL OR WHAT.
ALL OUR IMPLEMENTATION.
CONCERNS ABOUT A BILL AND THAT
OPPOSES THE BILL AND AND AND
TRULY TECHNICAL IMPLEMENTATION
AMENDMENTS SHOULD BE THE EASIEST
ONES.
TO DOES WORK BROUGH.
AND I KNOW THERE BILLS NOT JUST
MY OWN BUT OTHERS THAT IT IS.
COMPOSED AT EVERY PLANNER THAT
I'VE EVER MET SUPPORT.
AND SO I FEEL LIKE A PA AT TIMES
TO JUMP TO IMPOSE POSITION
CURRICULA THAT MY OPINION AND MY
OPINION ONLY.
I KNOW YOU DISAGREE -- BUT I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
I I DON'T THINK IT'S HELPFUL FOR
GOOD HEALTH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WIENER ANY
ADDITIONAL RESPONSE FROM A P. A.
N. OR THE CITY'S.
GRATEFUL ALL RIGHT.
MASON GENERAL WE'RE AT THE POINT
WHERE WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE IF THERE IS A MOTION.
A MOTION ON SB THREE THIRTY
WHICH IS A DO PASS HOUSING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN.
IN HOUSING IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE.
WITH A MOTION BY CENTER WINNER
CENTER SKINNER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS FOR CLOTHES.
THANK YOU ARE THAT WE ARE VERY
--
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION AND I
THINK IT'S CLEAR WITH THE ILL'S
DOING SO WITHOUT I ASK YOUR
RIGHT AS AMENDED ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE ONE MOMENT IS
WE'RE WORKING ON GETTING NINE
SENATORS HERE.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE MISSING CHESTER
JUST GIVE US A THIRTY SECONDS AS
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND SOME
AUTHORS JUST GIVE US THIRTY
SECONDS PLEASE.
I WANT TO SAY THANK GOODNESS
LANCHESTER SHE'S BEEN WORKING AT
TODAY -- TRACKING DOWN WITH A
TASER -- MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
GET INTO COMMITTEE.
THIS AYE CHESTER WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR THIS IS A DO
PASSED A HOUSING COMMITTEE ON
SB.
THREE THIRTY AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKING IN HOUSING COMMITTEE.
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
THE FLYERS HIGH WIRE ARDMORE LAW
[inaudible]
L. [inaudible]
WIENER.
CURRENTLY THE TWO ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND SKINNER AND YOUR
TEAM.
INDEED WE WILL -- WAIT TO ADD ON
HERE IN JUST A BIT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD TO SEE.
MEMBERS WERE NOT TO MOVE ON SB
FORTY EIGHT CENTER WIENER. TEN
WIENER IS GONNA BE PRESENTING ON
ALL ISSUES AND PRE SHAVE HIS
WORK ON HOMELESS SHELTERS.
HE'S BEEN A CHAMPION ON THIS.
ONE WE WELCOME THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO ALONG WITH
HIS WITNESS. TO COMMITTEE.
THIS IS SENATOR WHEN YOU ARE
READY THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE YOU IN
THIS OP WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH
US ON THIS BILL AND WE ARE -- IT
WILL BE ACCEPTING OF THE CAN OF
THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- RELATING TO THE
NEW STREAMLINED PROCESS. FOR
HIGH QUALITY LOW BARRIERS
SHELTERS SPECIFICALLY A
REQUIREMENT IS THAT STAFF BE ON
SITE DURING THE OPERATING HOURS.
OF THE FACILITY I TO ADD IN A
SEVEN YEAR SUNSET. TO THE BILL.
AND TO ALLOW THIS NEW VERSION OF
STREAMLINING I IN -- MIXED YOUR
MIXED USE ZONES OF YES. TO THAT
THAT'S THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
GOOD SENATOR I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO DEFINE THE
PRIVACY REQUIREMENTS LATINOS
MEANT THAT WAS MINE THE NEXT
YEAR ALL RIGHT.
WORKING ON THE PRIVACY
DEFINITION.
US TO THOSE OF THE I MEMBERS ARE
ACCEPTING IN THE CONTINUE WORK
ON A DEFINITION OF PRIVACY AND
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK -- WITH
US ON THE BILL.
SB FORTY EIGHT CREATES A NEW US
STREAMLINING PROGRAM FOR INTERIM
SHELTER DEVELOPMENTS ALSO KNOWN
AS NAVIGATION CENTERS.
OF THE GOAL OF WHICH IS TO
EXPEDITE THE APPROVAL OF HIGH
QUALITY LOW BARRIER SHELTERS. TO
CONNECT PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO SERVICES AND
ULTIMATELY TO PERMANENT HOUSING
--
ONLY A NAVIGATION CENTERS THAT
MEET ALL APPLICABLE HEALTH
SAFETY AND BUILDING CODES.
ALLOW FOR THE PRESENCE OF
PARTNERS PATHS IN THE STORAGE OF
POSSESSIONS PROVIDE PRIVACY OUR
LOW BARRIER -- AN OFFER SERVICES
TO CONNECT PEOPLE TO PERMANENT
HOUSING.
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS NEW
FORM OF STREAMLINING.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES TERRIFYING
CHANGES TO EXISTING HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW WITH REGARDS TO
ZONING. FOR EMERGENCY SHELTERS
ARE WHICH HAS LONG BEEN THE LAW
--
REQUIREMENT THE CITY'S.
IDENTIFY THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT A
ZONE. TO PERMIT -- EMERGENCY
SHELTERS ARE WITHOUT CONDITIONAL
USE OR DISCRETIONARY PERMIT.
WITH ON SOME CITIES HAVE --
IDENTIFIED THOSE ZONES IN AREAS
WERE KNOWN WHATEVER PUT.
A SHELTER FOR EXAMPLE IN A
DISTANT INDUSTRIAL AREA.
AND SO WE WILL BE MODIFYING --
THAT ELEMENT OF HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW.
I'D HAVE TO IDENTIFY EITHER
RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE ZONE.
AND INDUSTRIAL ZONE WILL BE
ALLOWED ONLY IF IT'S CLOSE
ENOUGH THAT IT'S CONNECTED TO
SERVICES -- AND ACTUALLY USABLE
--
SHELTER TO BE THERE -- WE HAVE
NEW.
HAS JUST COME OUT SHOWING THAT
CALIFORNIA WOULD KNOWN
CALIFORNIA HAS BY FAR THE
LARGEST -- ON SHELTERED HOMELESS
POPULATION IN THE US.
BUT WE LEARNED RECENTLY FOR
EXAMPLE THAT IN THE BAY AREA.
TWO THIRDS OF 67% OF HOMELESS
PEOPLE ARE ON SHELTERED AND LOS
ANGELES 75% BROWN'S SHELTERED.
BY COMPARISON NEW YORK CITY IS
5%.
SEATTLE WHICH HAS A A REAL
PROBLEM ON HIS HANDS IS OFF
FORTY SEVEN OR 48% SO.
IN OUR MAJOR METROPOLITAN AREAS
BUT REALLY STATEWIDE WE HAVE FAR
TOO MANY ON SHELTERED
INDIVIDUALS -- THERE ARE ENTIRE
--
COUNTIES IN BIG STRETCHES OF
CALIFORNIA WITH NO SHELTER BEDS
THE MINIMUS.
OR SHELTERS ARE ONLY OPEN IN THE
WINTER.
I AND IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT
EASIER -- TO INCREASE OUR
SHELTER AND NAVIGATION CENTER
CAPACITY -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WITH ME TODAY.
I IS.
ON THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND A WINNER
AND SALAS FLOORS YOURS YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES THANKS FOR YOUR
WORK.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
ANYA LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY -- AS
A CENTER NOTED FOR OVER A DECADE
STATE LAW HAS REQUIRED EVERY
CITY AND COUNTY IN THE STATE TO
HAVE AT LEAST A ZONE.
WHERE AN EMERGENCY SHELTER CAN
OPERATE AS HE'S BY RIGHT --
WE'RE NOW AT A POINT OF ABOUT
90% COMPLIANCE WITH THAT LAW --
THE LETTER OF THE LAW BUT IT'S
BEEN A LONG SLOG TO GET THERE
AND AS HE NOTED ALL IN A LOT OF
CASES THES BY RIGHT SOUNDS ARE
IN FAR FLUNG INDUSTRIAL AREAS --
AND THEY STILL FACE A LOT OF
BARRIERS TO ACTUALLY CITING THE
SHELTERS -- SO ANDAND AND THAT
WERE REALLY BY SIMPLY REQUIRING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IS THE NAME A
ZONE DOES NOT REALLY ALLOW THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SHELTERS THAT THE
SCALE THAT WE NEED THEM IN MANY
PLACES IN THE STATE I'M.
SO WELL THE SOLUTION
HOMELESSNESS.
IS ACTUALLY AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY
OF HOUSING OF ALONE VERY LOW
INCOME FOLKS IN EVERY COMMUNITY
IN THE STATE.
US SOLDIERS ARE CRUCIAL TO
ENSURING THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
LIVING ON THE STREETS AND IN
OTHER LOCATIONS THAT ARE UNFIT
FOR HUMAN HABITATION WHILE THEY
RECEIVE NEEDED SERVICES AND
ASSISTANCE IN SECURING PERMANENT
PART OF HOUSING.
SB FORTY EIGHT WILL EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE HIGH
QUALITY LOW BARRIER SHELTERS AND
TEMPORARY HOUSING SITUATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES WHERE MORE SHELTER
RATHER DESPERATELY NEEDED.
WE NEED FRANKLY TO GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MORE TOOLS TO GET
BEYOND THE REACTIONARY TYPE OF
OPPOSITION PROVIDING SHELTER
THAT ARE MOST BUT BROWN ON BOTH
MANY MEMBERS NEED.
AND THIS BILL WOULD DELIVER THAT
NIGHT OR DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SOLAR.
GRATEFUL FOR ALL YOUR CONTINUED
WORK OVER THESE PAST MANY YEARS
WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE.
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR THE FIRST IN
LASSEN ORGANIZATION.
SEVENS IS FIRED UP SHE'S BEEN
HERE SINCE NINE THIRTY THIS
MORNING THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ERIN EVANS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON TYRONE BUCKLEY
HOUSING CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER BUCKLEY
[inaudible]
HE AFTERNOON DOLLARS WILL GROWTH
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE.
SQUISHY NOW WE ARE IS THAT THE
SENATORS REPRESENTING AMERICAN
PLANS A STATION WE DO HAVE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION ON
THIS ONE WE DO HAVE STRICTLY
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND WE WE HAVE
TO WE DID WORK THE AUTHOR ON
THOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE ELSE IN BETWEEN AND OR
SUPPORT OF TO PLEASE ADVANCE
THIS TIMES COULD BE LAST CALL
FOR SUPPORT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NOW I'M GONNA WELCOME ANYONE
ELSE.
WHO MAYBE OPPOSED IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD?
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO OPPOSE
[inaudible]
THAT'S CALL.
ALL RIGHT WE THANK YOU BETTER
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
HERE LOOK [inaudible]
I WE HAVE HEARD.
FROM.
SOME CITIES IT OTHER CONCERN AND
I WANNA.
I COMMEND CYRIL WINNER FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE.
FOR YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE NORTH
COAST IN PARTICULAR MENDOCINO
COUNTY AN EXAM FOR AS AN
EXAMPLE.
MENDOCINO COUNTY IS A SECOND
HIGHS HOMELESS POPULATION UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
SOME THE HIGHS HOMELESS NUMBERS
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA AND
RURAL.
THIS BILL.
WITH THE NAME INSTEAD OF AN
ADVANCE IN THE COLLABORATION.
BETWEEN BOTH SIDES.
I THINK MAKES IT STRONGER AND I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU. TO THE
CENTER FOR A SAN FRANCISCO FOR
HIS WORK ON THIS AND ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS TIME OF CRISIS.
CENTER WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BE.
BEST FOREVER ALL RIGHT -- WE ARE
GOING TO BE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION.
A MOTION FROM THE SENATOR
HURTADO -- ON AN ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR SB.
FORTY EIGHT ALL RIGHT THERE WE
GO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY CENTER TANTO THIS IS A DO
PASSED TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
THE AMENDMENTS -- THAT HAD BEEN
PRESENTED TODAY WILL BE TAKE IT
N. E. Q..
AT THE NEXT AVAILABLE.
MISS LANCASTER LOCAL POLICE
REQUIRED HI.
I'M MORE ALONG L..
BURKE RICARDO.
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
TURNING TO IS A THREE ZERO VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THIS ROLL OVER.
IS A GERMAN COME INTO A STRAIGHT
FROM THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HE IS HERE ON SB.
SIX EIGHTY ONE FOCUSING ON SOME
AMENDMENTS. TWO LOCAL
REFERENDUMS WE WELCOME.
GOOD SENATOR SENATOR STONE.
ON ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN CENTER
CENTER STONE.
I APOLOGIZE A SINISTER DESCENT
OF HIS GO TO SHOES I CENTER
STONE I LOVE YOU SEEN ANY SCENES
ARE SOME SHOES.
THEY'RE THEY'RE PRETTY FAST.
I SINISTER -- IS GONNA BE
THINKING ABOUT THOSE SHOES AND
I'M GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
MISTER STERNON SB SIX EIGHTY
ONE AND I APOLOGIZE SIR.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR -- LONG
DAY FOR YOU ALSO.
IT SHORT SWEET AND SIMPLE HERE
--
YEARS BACK -- BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WE PASSED TO ME WHICH
IS A VERY GOOD GOVERNANCE
MEASURE TO ALLOW -- WITH SENATOR
STEINBERG ACTUALLY BACK WHEN HE
WAS THE PRO TEM TO ALLOW A
PROPONENTS OF STATEWIDE
INITIATIVES TO WITHDRAW THAT
INITIATIVE.
UP TO THE DEADLINE TO QUALIFY
FOR THE BALLOT HE WAS A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIRST DAY -- WE'VE
EXTENDED THAT SAME OPTION NOW
THE TWO THE LOCAL INITIATIVES
LAST YEAR WITH SB.
ELEVEN FIFTY THREE BUT ELEVEN
FIFTY THREE DIDN'T INCLUDE
REFERENDA.
SO THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
SCOPE OF WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR
--
TO ALLOW THE OPTION FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE BALLOT
INITIATIVES REMOVED -- TO ALSO
INCLUDE REFERENDA CHALLENGING
EXISTING LAW -- SO PRETTY SIMPLE
MEASURE WE THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALLOW THE
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR GOVERNMENTS AT WHATEVER
LEVEL LOCAL OR STATE TO BE ABLE
TO INTERVENE WE RECOGNIZE WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS THAT.
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF GAME
PLAYING THAT DOES GO ON AROUND
THE BALLOT PROCESS AND WE DO GET
LEVERAGED.
I STILL THINK THOUGH THAT GIVING
US THE TOOL TO INTERVENE AND TO
COME UP WITH LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTIONS AND ALLOW THAT OPTION
AUDI WILL HOPEFULLY AVOID.
EXPENSIVE VALID FIGHTS IN THE
FUTURE AND THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF OF NOT INCLUDING
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN THE PROCESS
THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
APPLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH STERN WE'RE
GOING TO TURN OVER YOUR WITNESS
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR HANGING
WITH US ALL DAY.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES SIR.
USE ALL THE TWO MINUTES --
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS TERRY
BROWN ABOUT FAST YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORTED THE
GENIUS THAT WAS -- ELEVEN SB
ELEVEN FIFTY THREE LAST YEAR.
AND THIS BILL MERELY MAKES IT
MORE GENIUS OR NOT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THERE WE GO WATCH OUT THANK
YOU TO PRINT AND WE'RE GONNA
OPEN IT UP TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE ENTER YOUR MEMBERS ROSS
BUT THE ON BEHALF THE THIEF
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
BUT I COULD DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE
AT THIS TIME.
HEARING SCENERY NOW WOULD LIKE
TO GET A LOOK TO ANYONE WHO MAY
BE OPPOSED IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
HEARING SEEN I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
BING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE COULD
LIKELY TO SEE IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE ON THIS
ISSUE.
AND OR WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
ADVANCE MOTION.
NOT -- THERE WE GO HER TITLE IS
IN BY A HEARING THERE I LIKE IT
--
CENTER STERN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GET A CLOSER RESPECT AS REV UP
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY SENATOR HER TITLE
THIS IS A DO PASSED TO
PREPARATIONS WERE TAKEN TO SAY.
THANK YOU TO CENTER STERN -- FOR
ALL OF THIS WORK -- MISSING
CHESTER LOCAL POLICE FIRE HI
REQUIRE HIGH MORE LOCKED.
RIGHT MOORLACH HI HAILEY.
IT'S BURKE -- TADO [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
WIENER.
HI WIENER AYE.
THANK YOU JOHN WHAT IS A
BIPARTISAN FIST BUMP ED
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR STERN.
SPEAKING OF MISTER MOORE LOCKED.
IT IS A VICE CHAIR WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE SB --
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THIS IS
REGARDING.
THE OPEN FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
COMMISSION.
IN PREPARING FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS IN A MACHINE READABLE
FORMAT.
LOOK THIS MAY NOT BE.
THE SEXIEST ISSUE OF THE YEAR
BUT WHAT I SAY.
IT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ONE BUT
TO BE ABLE TO STREAMLINE -- FOR
THOSE WHO ARE DOING THE FINANCES
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE VICE CHAIR FOR DOING THIS
DEEP DIVE.
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AS A
VICE CHAIR OF THE FOR SURE SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I GUESS
IF I WERE TO GO BACK -- TO THE
MOVIE -- THE GRADUATED SINCE THE
WORD IS PLASTICS THAT'S THE
FUTURE OF PLASTIC THIS SORT OF
THIS IS SORT OF A THE FUTURE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT SO.
I APPRECIATEYOUR ASSISTANCE IN
THE COMMITTEES ASSISTANCE ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
I X. B. R. L..
IN LINE.
XBRL WHICH IS AN OPEN STANDARD
THAT ENABLES A SINGLE DOCUMENT
TO PROVIDE BOTH HUMAN READABLE
AND STRUCTURED MACHINE READABLE
DATA.
IT'S CONSIDERED ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONS TO THE
MODERN ACCOUNTING PROCESS.
IT'S OPEN TECHNOLOGY
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO APPLY
COMPUTER READABLE TAGS AND
CODING TO BUSINESS DATA IT'S AN
INTERNATIONAL STANDARD DEVELOPED
BY THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
XBRL INTERNATIONAL INC -- AND IT
IS A WORLDWIDE STANDARD IT HAS
BEEN USED IN BRITAIN FOR
BUSINESS INCOME TAX AND FINANCE
REPORTING SINCE APRIL.
TWENTY ELEVEN THE MAIN BENEFIT
IS THAT THE FORMAT IS DESIGNED
TO AUTOMATE THE PROCESSING OF
COMPLEX ACCOUNTING INFORMATION.
ALLOWING FOR EASY AND STRESS
FREE ONLINE SUBMISSION.
CONVERSION SOFTWARE IS AVAILABLE
AND ALLOWS FOR EASY IMPORTING
FROM ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS.
MIGRATING CALIFORNIA'S
MUNICIPALITIES TO I. X. B. R. L.
IS THE GOAL.
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT ESTABLISHES
A COMMITTEE TO REVIEW THIS
INITIATIVE DETERMINE ITS
FEASIBILITY AND COST AND PROVIDE
A WORKABLE IMPLEMENTATION
SCHEDULE.
I EXPERIMENTS ARE READY UTILIZED
BY THE SECURITIES AND EXCHANGE
COMMISSION FOR ITS SIX THOUSAND
PUBLICLY TRADED CORPORATE
CORPORATE.
QUARTERLY FILING REQUIREMENTS
AND BY THE FDIC IS EIGHT
THOUSAND QUARTERLY REPORTERS.
XBRL CONVERSION IS SIMILAR TO
THE EVOLUTION OF FILM TO DIGITAL
CAMERAS.
IT WILL REPLACE OLDER PAPER
BASED PDF REPORTS WITH MORE
USEFUL MORE EFFECTIVE AND MORE
ACCURATE DIGITAL VERSIONS.
COLLEAGUES I XBRL IS BEING
UTILIZED AROUND THE GLOBE AND IS
THE FUTURE FOR MUNICIPAL
REPORTING.
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT STARTS THE
DIFFICULT JOURNEY OF CHANGE
WHICH IS THE BIG.
DILEMMA HERE IS LIKE THIS IS A
CHANGE. TO A FORMAT THAT WILL
SAVE TIME AND COST WITH MANY
SAYING.
WHY DON'T WE DO THIS SOONER?
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE AND I ON SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT AND I DO HAVE WITNESSES NO
I'M I'M VERY GRATEFUL AND I JUST
WANT TO CHECK IN MR BUT YOU'RE
YOU'RE GONNA BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEE MINUTES CORRECT.
ACT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- IN AGAIN IT'S
MORE LIKE YOU COMING FROM THE
POSITION THEY DID PRIOR TO BEING
IN THE SENATE -- AND FOR ALL THE
WORK HE DID.
THERE ARE VERY FEW THAT ARE
WORKING ON EFFICIENCIES WITHIN
THE INTERNAL SYSTEM I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTENSE FOCUS ON THAT.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK
ON SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT WOULD
LIKE TO RETURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
FIRST LASSEN ORGANIZATION IN YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH.
ARE GOOD MORNING CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WIRE.
AND MEMBERS -- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY THOUGHTS
ABOUT SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT MY
NAME IS MARK JOFFE AND I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST THE REASON
FOUNDATION.
BEFORE BECOMING A POLICY ANALYST
I HOW THE RIGHT A MANAGER ROLES
IN THE FEEL THE CREDIT RISK
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY TO
INVESTMENT BANKS AND MOODY'S
ANALYTICS. SIX YEARS AGO THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE
COMMISSIONED MYSELF IN A CO
AUTHOR TO STUDY THE FEASIBILITY
OF CREATING A QUANTITATIVE MODEL
PROCESSING CALIFORNIA CITY
CREDIT RISK.
WE WERE HIRED IN THE AFTERMATH
OF A STRING OF CHAPTER NINE
BANKRUPTCY ISN'T BONTA FAULTS BY
CITIES SUCH AS STOCKTON SAN
BERNADINO. ONE GOAL OF THIS
INVESTIGATION WITH THE TERM AND
WHETHER THE STATE COULD CREATE
AN EARLY WARNING SYSTEM FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FISCAL
DISTRESS.
OUR CLIENTS THE CITY ARE GASES
TO CONSIDER USING THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S CITY'S ANNUAL.
REPORT DATA FOR THIS PURPOSE
WHEN I REVIEW THE DATE I FOUND
LARGE DISCREPANCIES WITH WHAT IT
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS PREPARED BY
THE CITY'S.
THESE FINANCE REPORTS KNOWN AS
CAPPERS ARE PREPARED TO SATISFY
MUNICIPAL BOND MARKET DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS AND FEDERAL
SINGLE-AUDIT REQUIREMENTS ARE
PUBLISHED
EXCLUSIVELY IN PDF FORMAT.
SO RATHER THAN USE THE CITY'S
ANNUAL REPORT DATA WE UNDERTOOK
THE DOT THE DAUNTING TASK.
OF LOCATING KAFIRS IN HAND
ENTERING THEIR DATA INTO A
SPREADSHEET.
IT WAS THEN THAT I REALIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE REFORM
PROPOSED IN SB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT IF IT WAS
POSSIBLE TO AUTOMATICALLY LOW
DATA FROM KAFIRS INTO FINANCIAL
MODELS WOULD BE MUCH EASIER TO
EFFECTIVELY MONITOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FISCAL HEALTH.
THE SORT OF MY THIS SORT OF
MONITORING IS USEFUL FOR
MUNICIPAL BOND ANALYSIS AS WELL
STATE OVERSIGHT.
IN THE ABSENCE OF TIMELY HIGH
QUALITY FINANCIAL DATA.
MUNICIPAL BOND INVESTORS ARE
COMPELLED TO RELY AND CREDIT
RATING AGENCIES AND OR THEIR OWN
BIASES WHEN ASSESSING CREDIT
RISK.
ACADEMIC RESEARCH FINDS A RATING
AGENCIES ARE HARSHER AN ANALYSIS
OF MUSICAL CREDIT.
THEN OF CORPORATE OR ASSET
BACKED CREDIT.
MEANWHILE THE TRICKLE OF HIGH
PROFILE MEUSEL BANKRUPTCIES SUCH
AS THOSE IN DETROIT IMPORTER
RICO.
REINFORCED LARGELY UNFOUNDED
FEARS THAT MOST MUNICIPALITIES
ARE NOT CREDIT WORTHY
POTENTIALLY RAISING THE COST OF
CAPITAL FOR CRUCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
SO THERE IS NO SUBSTITUTE FOR
HARD ACCURATE NUMBERS.
INVESTORS AND CORPORATE
SECURITIES HAVE NEARLY REAL TIME
ACCESS TO ENSURE FINANCIAL
STATEMENT DATA.
BECAUSE THE FCC HAS MANDATED
THAT ANNUAL AND QUARTERLY
REPORTS BE DELIVERED IN MACHINE
READABLE FORM.
NO ONE IN THE CORPORATE
SECURITIES MARKET IS HAND
ENTERING BALANCE SHEET INCOME
STATEMENT DATA FROM PD OPS.
NOR SOULD ANYONE IN THE
MUNICIPAL BOND MARKET.
RETURNING TO THE ISSUE OF STATE
OVERSIGHT MUCH HAS CHANGED SINCE
OUR TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
PROJECT BUT THE CORE PROBLEM
REMAINS.
AT THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE THE CITY'S ANNUAL REPORT
HAS REPLACED BY THE VERY MODERN
BY THE NUMBERS WEBSITE.
STATE LAW WAS ALSO MODIFIED TO
GIVE CITIES WERE TRYING TO ENTER
THEIR FINANCIAL DATA THE
COMPLETED CALPERS COULD BE
CONSULTED DURING THE SCO
SUBMISSION PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY DISCREPANCIES
BETWEEN BY THE NUMBERS AND
CAFFERTY REMAIN FURTHER BY THE
NUMBERS IS ONLY AVAILABLE ON A
DELAYED BASIS.
STATE LAW REQUIRES SCO TO
PUBLISH THE DATA SIXTEEN MONTHS
AFTER THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR.
BUT MANY GOVERNMENT FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS ARE AVAILABLE WITHIN
JUST SIX MONTHS OF HE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR.
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT OFFERS A
MODERN SOLUTION TO THE CHALLENGE
OF MONITORING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEALTH IF THEY'RE NOT ONLY
CITIES COUNTIES.
BUT VARIOUS CATEGORIES OF
SPECIAL PURPOSE GOVERNMENTS AS
WELL AS WELL TO ALLOW THE STATE
ORDERED OUR OTHER STATE AGENCIES
POLICY RESEARCHERS AND CONCERNED
CITIZENS MORE QUICKLY IDENTIFY
RISK GOVERNMENTS.
PERMITTING INTERVENTIONS IN MY
PREVENT THE LOSS OF VITAL
COMMUNITY SERVICES THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS.
CAN YOU MANY OF TWO MINUTES IF
YOU SENATORS YOURSELF AN
ORGANIZATION WE APPRECIATE BEING
COMMITTED TODAY THANK YOU FOR
HANGING WITH US ALL DAY.
ABSOLUTELY -- THANK CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE -- I'M
MICHELLE SAVAGE I'M WITH THE
NONPROFIT STANDARDS ORGANIZATION
CALLED X. B. R. L. U. S. WHICH
STANDS FOR EXTENSIBLE BUSINESS
REPORTING LANGUAGE -- WE HAVE
BUILT IN SUPPORT OPEN DATA
STANDARDS AND WE BUILD STANDARDS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE SECURITIES
EXCHANGE COMMISSION WE BUILD
STANDARDS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY FOR SOLAR FINANCING.
AND WE'REWORKING ON ON OTHER
IMPLEMENTATIONS.
WE BELIEVE THAT ACCURATE TIMELY
AUTOMATED UNAMBIGUOUS STATE IT
IS NECESSARY NECESSARY FOR
GOVERNMENTS CITY POLICY. FOR
SECURITIES ANALYST MAKING
INVESTMENTS.
EVER CITIZENS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THEIR TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT.
AND THE ONE METHOD IT TO ENSURE
THE AVAILABILITY OF HIGH QUALITY
TIME WE DID IT IS STANDARDS.
DATA STANDARDS ARE A LONG TERM
SOLUTION.
THEY REDUCE DATA COLLECTION AND
ANALYSIS COSTS THE INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR REPORTING ENTITIES.
AND THEY LET GOVERNMENTS RESPOND
RAPIDLY TO CHANGE.
WE SUPPORT SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
BECAUSE WILL HELP THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ESTABLISH A BETTER
DATA COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AN INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE LONG
TERM.
WELL THE BENEFITS THE
STANDARDIZATION OUTWEIGH THE
COSTS WE KNOW THE COST IS A
CONCERN PARTICULAR WHEN IT COMES
TO GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS.
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT CALLS FOR
THE CREATION OF AN EXTRA REAL
TAXONOMY WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A
DIGITAL DICTIONARY OF TERMS.
THIS TAXONOMY CAN GROW AND
CHANGE OVER TIME BUT THE
CREATION OF THE TAXONOMY IS A
ONE TIME COST IT'S AN
INVESTMENT.
SUPPORT AND MAINTENANCE OF THE
TAXONOMY CAN BE HANDLED BY
BUSINESS MANAGERS WITHIN THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE SIGNIFICAN I. T.
--
INVOLVEMENT.
AND A VOLUNTEER ACTUALLY WAS
WORKING GROUP HAS ALREADY BEEN
HARD AT WORK DEVELOPING A SET OF
DATA STANDARDS REPRESENT THE CAP
FOR THE CONSOLIDATED ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT.
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTRIBUTE THIS
TO THE TO THE COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE ACTUAL STANDARD IS NAMED IN
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT BECAUSE IT
HAS CERTAIN CHARACTERISTICS THAT
MAKE IT APPROPRIATE FOR THIS
PURPOSE.
FIRST IS WIDELY USED I WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THE SENATOR --
ADDRESS THAT.
AS USED BY HUNDRED REGULATORS
AROUND THE WORLD SIX IN SIXTY
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES OVER TEN
MILLION COMPANIES USE THE
EXTERNAL STANDARD ME THIRTY
SECONDS -- IS A FREE OPEN
STANDARD THERE NO LICENSING --
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH IT IT IS
SOFTWARE AGNOSTIC IT IS NOT
SOFTWARE IS SIMPLY A STAND THAT
WORKS WITH MANY DIFFERENT TEXAS
OFFERS EVEN ONES THAT THAT --
PUBLIC AGENCIES WORKING WITH
TODAY.
IT'S DESIGNED TO WORK WITH
FINANCIAL DATA IT HANDLES THE
COMPLEXITIES OF FINANCIAL DATA.
AND IT ADAPTS TO CHANGE IT
CHANGES WITH REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THE CHANGES WITH
TECHNOLOGY IT DOESN'T LEAVE US
IN A STAGNANT SITUATION.
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTS WORLDWIDE
ADOPT STANDARDS BECAUSE THEY
WORK.
THE SEC IS A NEW RULINGS EVERY
WEEK BRINGING IN NEW TYPES OF
REPORTING ENTITIES USE EXPIRY
ALL.
THE FBI STE THE FDIC PROGRAM
THAT WAS MENTIONED THAT BANKS
ARE USING HAS RESULTED IN
TREMENDOUS EFFICIENCIES FOR THE
BANKING SYSTEM.
AND FINALLY THERE WAS A PROGRAM
IN AUSTRALIA THAT REQUIRES A IS
DATA STANDARDS FOR GOVERNMENT
AND BUSINESS IS HEREBY FORMAT.
AND THAT PROGRAM IS RESULTING
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS EVERY YEAR.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT I THINK IT'S A WIN
FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS AND MAKING IT
OPEN AND AVAILABLE TO ALL IS
WELL WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT.
AND I REALLY MEAN IS THANK YOU
BOTH FOR BEING HERE AT NO THEY
BOTH YOU'RE BUSY WE APOLOGIZE
THAT IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY.
FUND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH INTERESTING
WE'D LIKE TO BE TO OPEN IT UP TO
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
SO YOUR FIRST LASSEN
ORGANIZATION GOOD AFTERNOON HI
YES CASEY O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR STATE TREASURER
FIONA.
MA WE'VE OFFERED OUR OFFICES
TECHNICAL RESOURCES TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO GOING FORWARD
AND AS ONE CPA TO ANOTHER
TREASURE THANKS AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK YOU.
THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR.
DICKSON WRIGHT I'M WITH CHARITY
ESOURCE CONNECTION AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN I MEAN YOU'RE DISTRICT
AND I'M IN THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH X. P. R. O. EXPANDING
TAXONOMY FOR BUSINESS USE.
AND THE TRANSPARENCY WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPORTANT AND
WHILE NOT DIRECTLY AND WITH
MUNICIPAL BONDING A LOT OF THE
PROJECTS IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL BE RELYING ON BY THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY FOR THAT --
EXPERIMENT PORTING SO IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT TO RIDE A THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US AS WELL SIR.
ALL RIGHT THIS IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE.
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME?
HEARING SEEN.
NINE IS THERE ANYONE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE THE BILL CAN YOU PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSED.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
TO BE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE WILL
ALSO GLADLY ACCEPT A MOTION --
REMOVE THIS BILL.
NOT ALL IT WANTS LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN -- CENTER WIENER
CENTER TITLE ALL RIGHT TO CENTER
WIENER IS READY TO ROLL -- SO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR THIS
IS A DO PASSED THE GOVERNMENT
ORGAN.
GOVERNOR OR ADDITION COMMITTEE.
AT THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN
INTO THE GOVERNOR ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE AT THE APPROPRIATE
HEARING.
CENTER MORE LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE IN SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
NOW WE HAVE A BELIEF BLOCKCHAIN
TO SENATOR HERTZBERG.
ALL RIGHT HEY THERE YOU GO.
BUT THE SECURITIES INDUSTRY WENT
THROUGH A SIMILAR CONVERSION
MANY YEARS AGO WAS CALLED EDGAR.
AND SO YOU KNOW THE COMMUNITIES
OF AVAILABLE OR HAS ALREADY
EXPERIENCED SOME IMPROVEMENTS
WITH WITH TECHNOLOGICAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
INFORMATION.
IT'S A IT'S LIKE A TAG IT'S IT'S
A SEARCH CAPABILITIES SO IF YOU
WANTED TO START DOING SOME
RESEARCH.
IN YUTH IS OUR KING AND KEY
WORDS AND BOOM THOSE THOSE THOSE
--
NUMBERS WILL COME UP FOR YOU AS
OPPOSED TO FLIPPING THROUGH PAGE
BY PAGE ON A PDF ON YOUR
COMPUTER SCREEN.
WHAT'S ALSO NICE IS THAT YOU
ENTER THE DATA NCE AND THEN
THAT DATA CAN PROPAGATE ALL
OTHER FORMS.
SO THAT'S WHY THE COUNTRY OF
AUSTRALIA IS RECEIVING A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR THERE'S JUST SO
MUCH OF FISH AND SEE IN THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
I WANT TO THANK THE STATE
TREASURER BEYOND.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT YOUNG
AMMASH GIVES ME.
STILL FIGHTING SOME ALLERGY OR
SO GOOD -- AND SHE HAS -- TO MY
GOOD FRIEND TIM SCHAFER ON ON ON
STAFF AND HE'S BEEN A REAL --
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORTERS WELL AND
THAT'S WHY WE WENT THERE WE HAVE
A TREASURE UNDER COMMITTEE.
I THINK THE CREDIT RATING
AGENCIES WILL BE REALLY EXCITED.
I KNOW THE INTERNET THEY'RE NOT
THAT THE NATIONAL COMMUNITY UP
ON BY AGREE NEWS OR LOOKING AT
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THIS BILL.
AND WITH THAT KIND OF IN TWOS WE
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND JONATHAN'S GREAT WORK AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I PUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A VERY
GRATEFUL THAT ARE MORE LIKE
ABSOLUTELY MISS PETERSON IS A
FANTASTIC A GRATEFUL THAT HE'S
ON BOARD WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER WINNER THIS IS A DO PASS
A COVER ORGANIZATION.
AND THEN MISS BE TAKEN IN THE
APPROPRIATE COMMITTEE GOVERNOR
ORGANIZATION -- AT THE NEXT
AVAILABLE HEARING NGUYEN THIS
BILL IS UP.
I THINK JUST A ROLL CALL PLEASE
REQUIRE HIGH WHY I'M MORE LOCK
MORE LIKE AYE BELL HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG RICARDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
WIENER WIENER HIGH. FIVE FIVE
EIGHT ZERO THIS BILL IS STILL ON
HOLDEN KEEP THIS OPEN AND ADD IT
MEMBERS ON AT THE PERFECT TIME.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A QUICK BREAK
FOR TWO MINUTES -- QUICK RECESS
FOR TWO MINUTES AND WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU JIM WE WELCOME YOU
BACK.
AND WE'RE GONNA KEEP SAYING IT
TO THE VERY AND WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU OF FOR THE PATIENTS OF
ALL OF YOU BEEN HANGING WITH US
ALL DAY -- WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE PRESENTING.
ITEM NMBER ELEVEN AS BEFORE.
THIRTY EIGHT WE'RE GONNA ASK --
SERGEANTS OR IS IT THANK YOU
SERGEANTS FOR THE FANTASTIC WORK
TODAY'S WELL IF WE CAN GET.
CENTER ABOUT -- OVER THE
COMMITTEES WE WILL HAVE ONE BILL
LEFT NUMBER NEED TO BE AN ADD ON
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SP
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT CENTER
HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- TO TO YOUR
TEAM FOR ALL OF THE WORK ON THIS
BILL.
PLEASE SIR.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
APOLOGIZE THAT WAS EARLIER TODAY
IN THE COMMITTEE A LOT OF
CRAZIES ONE OF THOSE DAYS A LOT
OF STUFF GOING ON SO.
I'M SO SORRY FOR THAT AND NOT
LISTENING TO THE OTHER BILLS THE
THE I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
DISCUSSION AMONG THE SPONSOR AND
SHERMAN WITH RESPECT -- TO
AGREED UPON -- AMENDMENT --
WHICH WE CAN READ INTO THE
RECORD.
OF IT BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING HERE YOU KNOW IS IS
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE -- ABOUT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND THE MEAL
MY OPENING POINT I THINK IT
MAKES THE THE REASON WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY ON THIS MEASURE IS AN
ERROR MADE OF CAUTION.
IT'S MUCH LESS COSTLY THAN AIR
MADE BECAUSE OF PRICE -- WE HAVE
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS FOR E. R.
WHERE LIVES ARE LOST IN A MATTER
OF SECONDS AND GOVERNMENT
PROVIDES -- CONSTRUCTS AROUND
STAFFING AND RESPONSE TIME FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES IN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS TO PROTECT LIVES.
CURRENTLY SOME LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN DELEGATE THE LOCAL
EMERGENCY SERVICES DISPATCHER
THIRTY TO PRIVATE ENTITIES OFTEN
WITH DIRE CONSEQUENCES -- WE'VE
LEARNED IN MY WITNESSES WHAT'S
IT WILL SHARE WITH YOU IN A
MOMENT THAT THAT A PUBLIC ENTITY
BUT WHETHER THAT BE A GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYER A PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS THAT IS BEST SUITED.
TO THE ONE IN CHARGE OF DECIDING
WHO OR WHAT AND SKI IS SET TO AN
EMERGENCY SEE.
SO IT IS A QUESTION OF WHETHER
THE PERSON ARRIVES ON THE SCENE
OF AN EMERGENCY WILL DO THEIR
BEST.
JOB OF THEY POSSIBLY CAN THE
QUESTION IS WHETHER THAT PERSON
EVER GETS A CALL TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE IN A TIMELY MANNER SO
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT WITH RESPECT TO RESPONSE
TIMES IS REALLY CONTROLLED BY
THE GOVERNMENT AND ITS ONLY
CONTRACTED OUT WHEN IS
CONTRACTED OUT THROUGH FIRE
OFFICIALS THROUGH THE GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT LARGER DYNAMIC IN WITH
THAT.
DO YOU WANT TO GO FIRST OR IS
SHE FOR THE FIRST.
OKAY.
CHIEF WE LOOKING BACK TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE FOR ALL YOUR WORK SIR
AND AGAIN WANT TO APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THE DELAY YOU'VE BEEN WITH
US FOR FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
IS.
FOR SO -- THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU'VE TO MINISTRY.
THE CHAIR HAND OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS MIKE
MCLAUGHLIN I'M THE FIRE CHIEF OF
HIS IN THIS FIRE DEPARTMENT IN
ELK GROVE AND I'M HERE TODAY'S
OF LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION -- AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS BILL YOU YOU MAY
HEAR ARGUMENTS THIS IS ABOUT
MEDICAL CONTROL.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT MEDICAL
CONTROL OUR PARAMEDICS ARE
LICENSED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY MEET THE
TRAINING MANDATES AND STANDARDS
IDENTIFIED BY THE COUNTIES IN
THE LOCAL LANCES.
AND WE FOLLOW ALL OF ESTABLISH
LOCAL PROTOCOLS PUT IN PLACE BY
THE OLYMPUS.
AS BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT IS ABOUT
THE HOME RULE LOCAL CONTROL AND
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY -- IT'S
FALLS IN THE LINES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE SERVICE
WITHIN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES.
I'M HERE TODAY AS A MAJOR
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BIG
SMALL RULE VOLUNTEER CAREER
COMBINATION ORGANIZATIONS.
THERE'S MANY MODELS OUT THERE IN
TERMS OF HOW.
WE WORK TOGETHER MOST OF WHICH
ARE PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
AND THEY WORK VERY VERY WELL.
THE DYNAMIC WE'RE TRYING TO
AVOID WHEN THE LAMPS CONTRACT
OUT DISPATCH SERVICES AND
DICTATE WHICH CALLS LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN AND CANNOT RESPOND
TO IS REALLY THE CORE OF THE
MATTER THAT WE'RE BRINGING
BEFORE YOU TODAY FOR
CONSIDERATION.
AN EXAMPLE THAT I'D LIKE TO GIVE
YOU AN FOR THE SAKE OF A MOTION
IDEA MESSES LET ME MOVE AWAY
FROM ME A MESS AND LET'S USE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS AN EXAMPLE.
A CRIME IS COMMITTED IN ONE OF
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN THE
CITY A RESIDENT CZ EMERGENCY
CALLS.
911- THAT CALL IS ULTIMATELY
TRANSFERRED TO A PRIVATE
SECURITY DISPATCH CENTER.
AND BECAUSE OF DIRECTION BEING
GIVEN FROM A MIDDLE MANAGER
WITHIN THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
THE LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT IS
NOT EVEN DISPATCHER NOTIFIED OF
EMERGENCY WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY.
AND PRIVATE RESOURCES ARE
DISPATCHED INSTEAD OF IT.
THIS SEEMS PREPOSTEROUS IN IN
NATURE BECAUSE IT WOULD NEVER
HAPPEN IN ANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
YET IT HAPPENS EVERY DAY WHEN IT
RELATES TO EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES IN RENDERING CARE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES -- TO MOVE MOVE
THIS CASE FORWARD AND TO BRING
IT BACK AND HOW THIS IS REALLY
AFFECTING US EACH AND EVERY DAY
WE HAVE TWO OF OUR CHIEFS HERE
TO GIVE YOU EXAMPLES.
AND TELL YOU WHY THIS MODEL CAN
BE HARMFUL TO LIFE AND SAFETY OF
OUR RESIDENTS.
CHIEF THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THE CANDY
THAT KEPT US GOING THIS MORNING
HOWEVER WAS THAT SO MICHAEL ARE
KEY IS FIRE CHIEF MONTEREY
COUNTY REGIONAL I'M ALSO HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF.
OF THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THE ONE THING A JEEP
ACOSTA AND HIT THE TERM MEDICAL
CONTROL AND WE NEED TO REITERATE
THAT.
THIS BILL IS NOT TO DIMINISH THE
MEDICAL CONTROL.
IN OUR COUNTY IN ALL COUNTIES IN
IN CALIFORNIA WE WORK UNDER
MEDICAL CONTROL OUR PARAMEDICS
WORK UNDER THAT PHYSICIANS
LICENSE. TO BUY OUR NARCOTICS
UNDER -- THE D. E. A. -- THE
PROTOCOLS THAT HERE SHE WRITES
--
WE FOLLOW.
SENATOR A WINNER MADE A COMMENT
EARLIER IT'S CENTER COPIERS BILL
ON A SEQUEL.
WHAT MEDICAL CONTROL NOW HAS
HAPPENED?
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS IT'S LIKE
THE TERM SYKORA.
ANYTIME IN THE FIRE SERVICE
WANTS TO PROMOTE SOMETHING IN
EMS OR CAN GO TO THIS TYPE OF
CALL AS MEDICAL RELATED.
WE HEAR FROM MEDICAL DIRECTORS
THAT YOU CAN'T DO THAT AND THE
INTENT OF MEDICAL CONTROL NOW WE
HAVE FIFTY EIGHT VERSIONS OF
WHAT THAT INTENT IS.
WE DON'T EVEN GET A SEAT AT THE
TABLE.
WHEN IT COMES TO DISPATCHING
PROTOCOLS WE HAVE A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW IN MONTEREY
COUNTY?
THAT ONE OUT WE HAD NO PUBLIC
INPUT IT WILL NOW TELL MY FIRE
DISTRICT THAT WE CANNOT GO TO
CERTAIN CALLS IN MY
JURISDICTION.
AND WE'RE REAL COUNTY.
AS YOU KNOW IN REAL COUNTIES WE
HAVE THIRTY MINUTE RESPONSE
TIMES WE REQUIRE -- RANCHERS AND
FARMERS IN THE STATE HOMES TO
PUT IN OUR FIRE DEPARTMENT KNOX
KY.
WE HAVE TO GO THERE AND OPEN UP
THE GATES OF THE ANIMALS CAN GET
IN UNDER THIS CURRENT ARE OF P.
IN MONTEREY COUNTY THEY DON'T
WANT TO GO AND THE PRIVATE. FOR
PROFIT AMBULANCE WILL GO.
UP BECAUSE THEY HAVE A TREATMENT
AND NON TRANSPORT FEE WE HAVE
GREAT RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WE'VE HAD FOUR
DIFFERENT AMBULANCE COMPANIES
OVER MY THIRTY TWO YEARS.
WE WORK WELL EVERY DAY.
WE DON'T WANT THIS BILL TO
DIMINISH THAT I KNOW US SENATE
REQUIRE I MEAN YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
THE LEGENDARY SYSTEM I'VE
REFERRED TO THAT SYSTEM FOR
YEARS -- AS A A COMPONENT THAT
WE WISH WE COULD HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE INTERPRETATION OF MEDICAL
TROLL ARM AREA IS SEEN YOU CAN'T
DO THAT.
AND SO AGAIN IT'S BECOME THE SEA
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HEAR MEDICAL
CONTROL TODAY.
WITH OPPOSITION JUST REMEMBER
WHAT THE ORIGINAL TENNESSEE CO
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING IT BE USED
TODAY.
WE ISSUE BURKE PERMITS
RESIDENTIAL AG BURN PERMITS
WE'VE HAD PEOPLE SAY WORSE OUR
SEQUIN ELSE SO YOU CAN SEE THAT
YOU KNOW IF PEOPLE DON'T WANT
BACKYARD BURNING.
YOU KNOW NOW THEY CHALLENGES ON
THAT SAME THING WITH MEDICAL
CONTROL.
AND WE NEED THIS BILL TO HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE.
IS THE FINAL IT HAS TO COME TO
US WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE EMS
STAKEHOLDERS BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WE IT'S NOT A TWO WAY
CONVERSATION WE'RE TOLD.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHIEF GOOD
AFTERNOON THANKS FOR BEING YES.
WHAT WITH THE THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU -- CHAIR AND
AND AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND I'M GONNA BE
BRIEF I LEFT MY SCRIPT BACK --
IN THE BACK OF THE ROOM BECAUSE
I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY FOR
EVERYONE -- TRACY CALIFORNIA
RANDALL BRADLEY THIS IS ACTUALLY
MY FOURTH COUNTY HAD BEEN A FIRE
CHIEF AND ACTUALLY RAN -- EMS
PROGRAMS AS FAR AS A LS OF FIRE
--
BASED PROGRAMS AND AND FOR
DIFFERENT COUNTIES NOW AND I WAS
I I WAS EXTREMELY SURPRISED WHEN
I READ IN SOME LOOKING COUNTY TO
FIND OUT THAT.
ON THE LOCAL EMS AGENCY --
PREVENTED THAT TRACY FIRE
DEPARTMENT RESPONDED TO A
MEDICAL EMERGENCIES WITH OUR
JURISDICTIONAL BOUNDARIES ON
DISCOUNTED TO THE THAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
WE HAVE SEVERAL CALLS HAVE BEEN
DOCUMENTED WHERE.
FIREFIGHTER PARAMEDICS WERE
AVAILABLE NEAR AN INCIDENT ANY
THE PEOPLE SUFFERED NEEDLESSLY
ARC FOR THEY DIDN'T SURVIVE YOU
CAN MAKE THE ARGUMENT THEY WOULD
HAVE SURVIVED ANYWAY BUT WE WILL
NEVER KNOW NOW BECAUSE THE FIRE
--
PARAMEDICS DID NOT RESPOND A LOT
OF THIS IS REALLY BASED UPON --
THE EMS AGENCIES WANT TO RISK
YOU KNOW WANT TO CONTROL THE
SYSTEM THAT IS REALLY DRIVEN BY.
PRIVATE AMBULANCES AND THEIR
AVAILABILITY AND AND CONCERNS
THAT WE WOULD CANCEL PRIVATE
AMBULANCES BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE A GOOD CAME NEXT
AND WE HAVE LOTS OF PEOPLE WITH
WITH WITH WITH WITH INSURANCE --
I THINK THAT IT IS INHERENT FOR
FIRE CHIEFS TO DETERMINE HOW
MANY FIRE STATIONS BASED UPON
THEIR THEIR CITY COUNCIL OR
THEIR BOARDS -- SUPPORT CAN FOR
THEM FOR THE FIRE CHIEFS TO
DETERMINE WHAT TYPES OF CALLS
HOW WE RESPOND IN WHAT MANNER WE
RESPOND.
WE SHOULD WORK WITH ARE YOU
MESSAGE AND SEES TO ENSURE THAT
WE WE HAVE THE PREDICTABLE AND
DEFENDABLE SYSTEM BUT IT SHOULD
NOT BE DRIVEN FROM MY COUNTY
AGENCY DETERMINE.
HOW WAS CITY RESPONSE TO MEDICAL
EMERGENCIES I THINK CHIEF
MCLAUGHLIN'S EXAMPLE OF
UTILIZING LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
WOULD NEVER BE ACCEPTABLE FOR
SHERIFF TO DETERMINE IF A POLICE
CHIEF RESPONDED TO AN EMERGENCY
OR NOT?
BUT FOR SOME REASON -- THERE'S
AN OVER REACH FOR EMS AGENCIES
AND AND THIS LEGISLATION WILL
WILL ADDRESS THAT OVER REACH.
WE WE WANT TO STAY OUT OF COURT
AND WE WOULD -- LIKE -- TO GET
THIS DONE LEGISLATIVELY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHIEF.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY THEM ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS I WAS JUST LETTING
UNIFORMS BEFORE BEAUTY TESTIFY.
AND SO I HAD.
ANYWAY I THINK THE COMMITTEE'S
INDULGENCE YOUR STAFF HAS WORKED
TIRELESSLY ON THIS MATTER AS THE
CHIEF MENTIONED YOU HAVE A MODEL
SYSTEM IN YOUR COUNTY WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK. TO IDENTIFY
WHY THAT HAS FOUND SUCCESS AND
MAKE IT A MODEL FOR OTHER
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS
SIMPLY ABOUT THE A TAMI OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MANAGE.
THEIR PUBLIC SAFETY RESOURCES AS
THEY'RE TEXTING COMMUNITY
EXPECTS AND DEMANDS.
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
I THINK IT'S BEEN A VERY
GRATEFUL FOR ALL YOUR WORK AS
WELL ALWAYS ON SO MANY ISSUES
WITH LIKE THAT OPEN UP TO THOSE
WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE THIS
TIME LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO PLEASE ADVANCE.
WE'RE GONNA DO A LAST CALL FOR
SUPPORT WE'RE NOT GONNA BRING IT
--
FORWARD FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME.
THE INTERNET.
BERMAN WELCOME US SENATOR PER
DAY FIVE IT'S COMING BACK.
WE'RE GONNA WELCOME. TO
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WORKER HAVE YET? TO
THE CHAIRS TO MY LEFT.
GERMAN WE WELCOME YOU.
WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY WHICH WOULD
BE FIVE MINUTES.
WE'VE ONE SECONDARY WHICH WOULD
BE TWO MINUTES.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE OUR PRIMARY
WITNESS -- IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WELCOME SIR IF YOU
COULD JUST PULL THAT MICROPHONE
CLOSE YOU HIT THE BUTTON OR WILL
HIT THE RED LIGHT.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR SOME LASSEN
ORGANIZATION I DON'T THINK THE
CHAIR IN THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE UPRIGHT ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR KARL SCHULZE I
AM A PROFESSOR OF EMERGENCY
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AND THE SERVICE THE EMS
MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR ORANGE
COUNTY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE EMS
MEDICAL DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
IF SB FOUR THIRTY THIS PAST IT
WILL CREATE A SUBSTANTIAL RISK
TO PATIENT CARE.
ELIMINATES THE UTHORITY OF LUMP
SUM MEDICAL DIRECTORS TO MANDATE
APPROPRIATE AND EFFECTIVE
MEDICAL DISPATCH POLICIES AND
RESTRICTS THE COUNTIES FROM.
UTILIZING THE BST COMBINATION
OF PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
DISPATCHES.
THAT BEST SERVE THEIR
CONSTITUENTS.
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF AS BEFORE
THIRTY EIGHT WHIMS AS WILL LOSE
CONTROL OF THE INITIAL DELIVERY
OF PRE HOSPITAL MEDICAL CARE
PROVIDED COUNTY RESIDENTS.
MEDICAL DISPATCH WHICH IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE EMS
SYSTEM WILL SKATE MEDICAL
REVIEW.
ERRORS MADE BY PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHER AGENCIES WILL NOT BE
SUBJECT TO LIMIT THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OVERSIGHT OVER
MEDIATION.
POSITION OVERSIGHT OF CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT MEDICAL INSTRUCTIONS
BY EMERGENCY MEDICINE MEDICAL
DISPATCHERS WILL BE LOST.
AS EMS STANDARDS OF CARE
INVOLVED AND IMPROVE IT WILL NOT
BE POSSIBLE TO ENSURE THAT THE
DISPATCH STANDARDS KEEP PACE.
SINCE SLIM SOME MEDICAL INPUT
WILL BE PROHIBITED.
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
THREATEN INTEGRATED SYSTEM
STATUS MANAGEMENT IT REPLACES
THE LAMPS IS PLANNING AN
OVERSIGHT OF MEDICAL CALLED
PROCESSING AND MEDICAL RESOURCE
DEPLOYMENT.
WITH THE DISCRETION OF THE
INDIVIDUAL PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES.
AS SUCH THE ASSURANCE THAT THE
CLOSEST AMBULANCE RESPONSE FROM
MEDICAL EMERGENCY WILL BE LOST.
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT BY
EXEMPTING PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
FROM MEDICAL CONTROL OF THE LET.
MEDICAL CONTROL OF THE LIMB SOME
MEDICAL DIRECTOR WOULD ALLOW
THESE AGENCIES SUCH AS THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT. TO DEPLOY AND
REDEPLOY ITS RESOURCES AS IT
SEES FIT EVEN IF IT MEANT RE
DIRECTING THE RESOURCE ALREADY
ASSIGNED TO OR ACTIVELY TREATING
A PATIENT.
THE IMPACT OF SECTION SEVENTEEN
NINETY EIGHT DOT EIGHT AS
WRITTEN IS SO BROAD THAT IT
WOULD IN ESSENCE REMOVE THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE THAT ENSURES
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES AND
PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL.
AS WELL AS PRIVATE AGENCIES ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO PUBLIC A TO
A MEDICAL OVERSIGHT.
IN SUMMARY SB FORTY EIGHT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY COMPROMISE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HEALTH BY PROMOTING.
MEETING LIMB SOME MEDICAL
DIRECTORS FROM THE PLANNING
OVERSIGHT OF MEDICAL CALL
PROCESSING MEDICAL DISPATCH AND
MEDICAL RESOURCE UTILIZATION.
IN ADDITION THE BILL TIES THE
HANDS OF COUNTY ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND PREVENTS THEM FROM
IMPLEMENTING THE MOST EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE INTEGRATED EMS
SYSTEM.
USING A COMBINATION OF PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE [inaudible]
PROVIDERS.
AS AN EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN IN THE
E. ARE TRYING TO SAVE THE
PATIENT CARDIAC ARREST.
THE MEMBERS OF THE OUR TEAM
WORKED WITH ME AND SERVED UNDER
MY MEDICAL DIRECTION.
IF TEAM MEMBERS WERE PERMITTED
TO FUNCTION INDEPENDENTLY
WITHOUT MY MEDICAL OVERSIGHT AND
PURSE PURSUE INTERVENTIONS NOT
SUPPORTED OR DIRECTED BY SOUND
POSITION CONTROL.
THE PATIENT WOULD SUFFER
SIGNIFICANT HARM.
THIS IS THE EXACT SITUATION
CREATED BY SB.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR.
THIRD THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES IF YOU DON'T
MIND YOU MISTER FIRST LAST YEAR
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU FOR
HANGING WITH US TODAY AND DO
APOLOGIZE HAS BEEN.
SUCH A LATE AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MISTER MY NAME IS DAN BURCH I'M
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATOR FOR SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AND I CURRENTLY SERVE ON
THE STADIUM AS COMMISSION OF IN
THE PAST YEAR THE COMMISSION AS
WELL.
AND I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING
THE EMERGING MEDICAL SERVICES
ADMINISTERS SO SHE CAN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
THE LESSONS WE LEARNED IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES NINETEEN
SEVENTIES TAUGHT US THAT A
SYSTEMS APPROACH TO MEDICINE. TO
THE DELIVERY OF HEALTHCARE
IMPROVE PATIENT OUTCOMES.
THE LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE THESE
BENEFITS IN THE IN THESE LESSONS
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY WHEN IT
PASSED THE EMS SYSTEM ACT.
WITH THE INTENT OF CREATING A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM FOR DELIVERY OF
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES.
NINETEEN EIGHTY CALIFORNIA'S
HODGE PODGE PATCHWORK FOR THE
LIVERY OF EMERGENCY MEDICINE
PREHOSPITAL CARE WAS REPLACED
WITH A FRAMEWORK TO FOSTER
INCREASE STATEWIDE INTEGRATED
SYSTEMS. FOR THE UNIVERSAL
DELIVERY OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES TO ALL OF OUR CITIZENS.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN THE M.
S. RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION IN THE
PREEMINENT ROLE OF THE PHYSICIAN
MEDICAL DIRECTOR IN PLANNING
IMPLEMENTING AND EVALUATING.
EMS SYSTEMS OF CARE.
WE DO NOT DOUBT THE SINCERITY OF
THE SUPPORTERS OF SP FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT THE BELIEVE IT IS IN THEIR
BEST INTEREST TO ACT
INDEPENDENTLY OF THE M. AS
MEDICAL ACTOR.
AND OUTSIDE OF THE EMS SYSTEM.
HOWEVER NOT WITHSTANDING THE
SINCERE BELIEFS WE KNOW FROM THE
MEDICAL AND SCIENTIFIC
LITERATURE.
IN THE EXPERIENCE OF THE PAST
THIRTY NINE YEARS THAT EXISTING
SYSTEM. FOR THE IN AGREE FOR
INTEGRATED DELIVERY I'M OF EM US
IS BEST FOR PATIENT OUTCOMES.
MEDICINE RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF SPECIALIZATION.
WE HAVE SPECIALIZED HOSPITALS TO
CARE FOR CALLING PATIENTS
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN BETTER
PATIENT OUTCOMES.
THE SAME IS TRUE FOR SPECIALIZED
DMS DISPATCH CENTERS.
FICTION OUTCOMES IMPROVED BY
USING A SYSTEMS APPROACH TO CARE
THAT RECOGNIZE SPECIALIZED
CENTERS WHERE THEY PROVIDE
TRAUMA CARE OR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
DISPATCH.
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT WOULD ALLOW
EXISTING INTEGRATED SYSTEMS THAT
WORK VERY EFFECTIVELY AND SONOMA
SAN JOAQUIN FRESNO COUNTY IN
OTHERS. TO BECOME BALKANIZED AT
THE DISCRETION OF LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES.
CURRENTLY WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
EIGHTEEN AT CENTERS THAT WOULD
BE AFFECTED BY SB FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT STATEWIDE THAT FORM EITHER
THAT ARE EITHER OPERATED
PRIVATELY OR IN A PRIVATE
PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU -- THROUGH TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL.
WE'D LIKE TO GET OUT WELCOME ANY
ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO PLEASE
COME FOR THIS MICROPHONE.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
FIRST AND LAST IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION WE'RE LOOKING FOR
OPPOSITION THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M FERRE MCDADE TING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ARE
REPRESENTING A CALIFORNIA'S
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS BETSEY ARMSTRONG
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
KELLY BROOK CENTER THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
WORLD CAN YOU REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
COUNTIES OF SAN JOAQUIN AND
STANISLAUS ALL AND ALL IN
OPPOSITION.
BAKER.
FISHERMEN MEMBERS PAUL YOU ARE
WE HAVE THE FRESNO COUNTY FOR SU
RISES SYSTEM THIS WORKING JUST
FINE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WE'D LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FOR THIS TIME THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
LAST CALL.
PLEASE SIR WELCOME.
RIGHT AT TRUSTS ARE IN LEGAL
CALIFORNIA'S HE'S ACTUALLY A
TEST -- INSTEAD IN SUPPORT OF
BILL -- SUPPORTING THE CONCEPT
CERTAINLY WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
DO -- WITH THE BILL TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO ENSURE THAT CITIES ARE
ABLE -- TO THESE ARE ABLE -- TO
YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT THAT THE
PLANNING O THEIR RESOURCES --
THAT THEY CAN CONTROL THAT ARE
MOVING FORWARD AND SO WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
RIPPING SO FORTH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR
COMING UP.
ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME.
FOR ALL RIGHT THIS BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE WERE PASSING OUT
--
THE AMENDMENT.
BY THAT WILL BE TAKEN IT ISN'T
SO THAT EVERYONE HAS IT -- IT
WOULD FOCUS ON JP EIGHTIES.
THAT HAVE.
BOUGHT FIRE AGENCIES.
DEPARTMENTS OR DISTRICTS ALREADY
AT THE TABLE.
OF THE JPA.
I IN THAT IT ALSO STATES THAT IT
THE CONSENSUS ANY RENT
RENEGOTIATION OR ADOPTION.
OF A FUTURE AGREEMENT SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT FIVE THE
COMMITTEE HAS THE AGREED UPON
AMENDMENT.
WE DO APOLOGIZE IF THERE'S BEEN
SOME BACK AND FORTH AND WHAT
THIS AMENDMENT ESSENTIALLY
FOCUSES ON ON SIMILAR TYPE.
OF GPAS THAT WOULD BE.
DEVELOPED IN THIS BILL -- IN ONE
OF THE EXAMPLES OF THAT WOULD BE
CINEMA COUNTY WHERE YOU ALREADY
HAVE A FIRE CHIEFS.
AT THE TABLE ALONG WITH ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL.
SO WOULD LIKE TO BETTER OPEN UP
FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND QUESTIONS
FOR SENATOR HERTZBERG WE ALSO
WOULD ACCEPT A MOTION AT THIS
TIME [inaudible]
CENTER CHANNEL.
YES SIR JUST KIND OF WANT TO GET
A LITTLE BIT MORE -- INFORMATION
FOR REALLY WANTED TO EXPRESS IT
SO I REPRESENT AT TWENTY THREE
CITIES AND SENATE DISTRICT
FOURTEEN SOME OF THEM DON'T HAVE
A DISPATCH MY CITY THE CITY
WHERE I WHERE I COME FROM
DOESN'T HAVE A DISPATCH.
SO -- YOU KNOW IT IT WE STRUGGLE
FINANCIALLY TO BE ABLE. TO TO TO
HAVE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
THAT THE THE RESOURCES TO HAVE
THE SYSTEM THERE AND SO I THINK
THAT -- TODAY I WILL BE ABLE TO
GO AHEAD AND AND SUPPORT YOUR
BOOK AND CONCEPT BUT EIGHT I
WOULD LIKE I WOULD LOVE TO BE.
PART OF THE DISCUSSION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS REALLY WANT.
BUT FOR THOSE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE ONES.
THAT I COME FROM -- IT IT'S A
LITTLE BIT IT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE COMPLICATED SO WOULD LOVE
TO BE PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR REJECT RETURN THIS IS
ONE OF THE PLEASE -- THROUGH THE
CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER TADO
EIGHT WE HEAR YOUR YEAR OF
ASSERTIONS AND CERTAINLY I THINK
THAT THIS IS WHY WE LIKE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS INVOLVED IN THESE
DECISION MAKING SO YOUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
RECEIVE A RESPONSE AND IT IS NOT
BASED ON ANY OTHER.
A DEMOGRAPHIC OR ECONOMIC ISSUE
IN YOUR COUNTY SO WE WILL
ENDEAVOR TO WORK WITH YOU --
DIRECTLY TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL IS WORKABLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY AND THAT YOU'RE PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS CAN HAVE A ROLE
IN MAKING THOSE [inaudible]
RESPONSE DECISION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
CENTER.
PLEASE CENTER NIELSEN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS IT WILL GO TO CENTER
ABOUT.
IN GENERAL I HAVE NOT SUPPORTED
SUCH BILLS.
TODAY I AM GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL NUMBER ONE I RESPECT THE
DIRECTION.
AND I CERTAINLY RESPECT
[inaudible]
THE AUTHOR.
AND I WOULD ALSO THINK THAT
THERE'S MERIT IN PROMOTING SOME
DALOGUE.
AND I'M ONE WHO IS DEL PROBABLY
IS MEANT MANDATE MUCH WITH
THESE.
SITUATIONS AS ANYBODY AROUND
HERE [inaudible]
AND I REMEMBER ONE NIGHT WHEN I
WAS GOING TO BE SENDING AWARDS
TO A BUNCH OF EMS DISPATCHERS
AND AND THERE WAS A OF SERGEANT.
FROM THE POLICE THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT CAME UP SAID YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE LOSING YOUR CROWD
HERE.
CENTER THERE'S A BEEN A FOURTEEN
CAR PILEUP ON INTERSTATE FIVE
AND THEY'RE ALL EVEN.
THE END OF THAT.
THAT'S NOT HEALTH INCREDIBLE
THAT IS THAT THESE PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEIN HONORED FOR WHAT
THEY'VE DONE OUR RESPONSE.
A HUGE CRISIS AND HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS NOW.
I THINK THAT THE THE FOLKS WHO
OF WHAT THE TESTIFIED TO IN IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S SOME MERIT IN
THEIR ARGUMENTS AND I WITH.
VOTE IN BOTH TRADITIONS SUCH
PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE.
LET'S HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
DISCUSSION AND AS MS BOMB HAS
INDICATED.
OUR DESIRE I KNOW THAT
CERTAINLY.
MISSED HERTZBERG NOBODY IS
BETTER AROUND HERE WE GO SHE'D.
SO I WILL BE AVAILABLE TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR NIELSEN
THANK YOU BRIAN THAT PERSPECTIVE
AND FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK AS WELL
SIR.
THE DEAN AND SENATE -- THAT'S GO
TO SENATOR ABOUT -- I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL I I WANTED TO
TELL YOU THOUGH I WANT TO SEE.
WORK ON GETTING THE COUNTIES IN
THE CITIES.
CLOSER TOGETHER ON THIS IN TERMS
OF THE HEALTH CARE.
AND THERE'S SO. ONE REASON WHY I
THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL. TO GET
TO GO IN THIS DIRECTION IS IT.
WE TRIED THE BOTH WAYS AND WIRE
AND SAN JOSE.
AND WE HAD PROBLEMS WITH --
PRIVATE CONTRACTING THE MLS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A BIG CITY WE
HAVE A DIFFERENT KIND OF
POPULATION -- MULTICULTURAL
POPULATION AND WE FOUND THAT --
OF THE FIRE DEPARTMENT HAD.
A BETTER TRAIN FORCE TO DEAL
WITH THAT KIND OF POPULATION.
THEN THE EMS OF SYSTEMS.
SO IT AND ALSO -- THE MEDICAL
STAFF AT THE HOSPITALS ARE USED
TO DEAL WITH THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
SO THE RELATIONSHIP IS GOOD --
AND IS STRONGER AND AND AND AND
THE BOTTOM LINE WHAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE RESPONSE TIME RIGHT.
SO THE RESPONSE TIMES TURNED OUT
TO BE BETTER.
SO SO THE PUBLIC WANTS BETTER
RESPONSE TIME.
WE HAD WE HAD A CONTRACTOR THAT
CONSISTENTLY WAS PENALIZED FOR
NOT MEETING THE STANDARDS
RESPONSE TIME.
THAT'S LIKE NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SO YOU HAVE TO YOU YOU KNOW THE
THE SYSTEM THAT YOU'RE.
YOU KNOW THIS THIS CONCEPT IS.
WHERE WE HAVE EVOLVED?
TO IN TERMS OF OUR OUR
COMMUNITY.
SO I JUST -- THAT'S BUT I THINK
YOU HAVE TO WORK ON GETTING THE
HOSPITALS.
AND THE EMERGENCY -- TRAUMA
CENTERS.
TIGHTER WITH EMS SYSTEMS.
THAT THE PROBABLY BE A
SUGGESTION ON THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER.
I WILL VOTE FOR THE BILL TODAY
CLOSE YES CENTERS FOR PLEASE.
I JUST WANTED TO IN IT'S JUST
IT'S BY I FIND IT QUITE
ENLIGHTENING THE TO SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE.
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
EMERGING MEDICAL SERVICE A. G.
PROVIDE A MEMO WITH THE COURT
CASE -- THAT ONE POINT BUT THE
THING IS PROBATIVE IS A NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT SUPREME COURT CASE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT CASE
VALLEY MEDICAL TRANSPORT.
AT PAGE SEVEN SIXTY ONE AND I
THINK THE QUOTE INFORMS THE
REASON FOR THIS MEASURE.
THE LEGISLATURE APPEARS TO HAVE
ASSUMED IN DRAFTING SECTION --
SEVENTY NINE SEVENTY NINETY
SEVEN POINT TWO OH ONE THAT
SITES THAT CITY HIS ME THE
CITIES AND FAR DISTRICTS HAVE
INTEREST IN MAINTAINING CALL THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES.
THAT ARE NOT FUNDAMENTALLY
ADVERSE TO COUNTY INTEREST IN
THE SAME.
AND THAT THERE FOR AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN THESE PUBLIC ENTITIES
BOTH POSSIBLE AND DESIRABLE.
IF THAT ASSUMPTIONS PROVED IT IS
PROVEN HISTORICALLY TO BE
INCORRECT THE DISTRICT OTHER
SIMILARLY SITUATED PUBLIC
ENTITIES MUST RESORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE NOT THE COURTS TO
AMEND THE EMS ACT.
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL.
PASSED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OULD LIKE TO
GO TO SEE IF WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR WITH A MOTION BY.
SENATOR WIENER.
THIS IS A TO PASS TO HEALTH
COMMITTEE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR THAT CONVERSATION -- FROM
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISSING CHESTER CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
REQUIRED BY WHERE I MORE LOCK.
BELL BILL AYE HERTZBERG FINAL
REGARD HER CONDO.
CONDO AYE NIELSEN.
INSTEAD AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THOSE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKING IN --
IN HEALTH COMMITTEE IN HEALTH
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
SIX SO.
THAT IS A SIX ZERO WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP THAT.
ROLE OPEN TO BE ABLE TO ADD THE
VICE CHAIR ON LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN AS MUCH AS YOU ALL
WANT TO BE A STAY IN COMMITTEE.
FOR ANOTHER FOUR HOURS WE ARE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
BELL THIS IS OUR LAST AND FINAL
BELL THE BILL FOR THE BELL.
THIS IS SB.
NINE WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR HERTZBERG LOOK
AT THAT.
PLACE YOU DON'T WE'RE GONNA BE
CALLING UP THE TREASURES STAFF
HAS BEEN HERE SINCE SIX AM.
AND LA AND THEIR AGO
[inaudible]
SO.
WE HAVE.
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
AND I DO BELIEVE IF I COULD HOLD
THIS HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AS
WELL A VERY SHORT.
ALL RIGHT SO ON THE CONDITION OF
A SHORT PRESENTATION WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR SO.
HAVE A VERY SHORT PRISON ALL
RIGHT THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT -- TURN
OVER MY WITH HEY THERE YOU GO
ALRIGHT NICE JOB. TO THE TEAM
FROM THE TREASURER'S OFFICE BOOK
JOHNSON WHO ABOUT SUCH AS A FEW
ON A Mà -- CHAIR THE CAFETERIA
PLEASE COMMITTEE LIKE TO THINK
SO IN THE BILL FOR LISA WAS BORN
ISSUE -- FOR BROWSING GOING FOR
TOP PRIORITIES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OF YOUR TIME I HAVE AT THE THE
DOOR TO DISTRICT THAT THE
DIRECTOR. FOR TO GET WHO HAS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
SO MUCH WHEN WE OPEN UP FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR
MISSIVE ENDS IS READY TO ROLL
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DMV AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
BROWN IS HERE TYRONE BUCKLEY A
WE HAVE A HOUSING CALIFORNIA
ALSO SPORT THANK YOU MISTER
BUCKLEY.
MARINO LINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT IS
FIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS
FOR HANGING.
BUT I COULD DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER THOSE -- FORMER MAYBE IN
OPPOSITION.
YOUR MEANS STRIKING DISTANCE THE
CENTRE BELL SO WATCH OUT -- ALL
RIGHT A THERE WE GO.
KAREN SEEN ON THAT'S EVER GOING
TO BRING IT BACK WE DO HAVE A
MOTION -- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT -- SOONER WE WOULD LIKE TO
OPINE ON THIS IS A HOUSING BILL
[inaudible]
I'M GETTING -- DON'T WORRY IT'S
ALREADY HAPPENED SIR -- ALL
RIGHT I'M GETTING BIG -- A BIG
GROUP HUG A CENTER AND WE ARE
NOT.
ALL RIGHT SO THEY'RE APPROPRIATE
--
SO -- WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR -- MISTER BILL WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH IS
LANCASTER RECALL PLEASE REQUIRE
I REQUIRE I'M MORE LOCK.
OUT.
I HERTZBERG.
I DON'T I NIELSEN. SIX ZERO OR
NOT SURE WHERE THE VICE CHAIR IS
EVER GOING TO GO FIND A RIGHT
NOW.
GLAZER JIM IF YOU CAN GIVE US
TWO MINUTES THANK YOU TO THE
TREASURES TEAM THEY REALLY HAVE
BEEN HERE ALL DAY SO VERY
GRATEFUL -- THEY'RE NICE JOB
NICE.
TO GO TEAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER BALLOT
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THAT CAN YOU
GIVE US TWO MINUTES WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO HUNT DOWN THE VICE CHAIR.
AND WE'RE GONNA GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER TO BE A TO DO OPEN UP
THE ROLE [inaudible]
THEY'RE GOOD.
GOES TO SENATOR HERTZBERG
EVERYONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS YOUR EVERY
MEETING ABOUT THE RICARDO LARA
LARA WARREN AND THERE WE GO IT
GOES -- TO CENTER HERTZBERG.
HEY THAT'S RIGHT YEAH I LIKE
THAT ACTUALLY WILL GET A LITTLE
STATUE.
ALL RIGHT I LIKE IT ACTUALLY I
THINK IT COULD BE A TIGHT TODAY.
I KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
ALL RIGHT HEY THERE WE GO.
HE'S.
STILL PRESIDENT AND HEALTH TO
USE ALL RIGHT YEAH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WIENER IN
ALL SINCERITY
AGAIN I JUST WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK YOU.
TO BY THE GOVERNMENT FIGHT TEAM
FOR ALL THEIR WORK TODAY THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF HEAVY LIFT ON
ANTON.
DAYS I JUST WANT TO POINT HIM
OUT AS WELL BUT THE ENTIRE TEAM
THANK YOU SO MUCH BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S BEEN A LOT.
AND WE ONLY HAVE THIRTY ONE
BILLS.
ON THE TWENTY FOURTH SO BE VERY
EXCITING.
LAYS IT DOWN WE'RE GONNA START
WITH ITEM SIXTEEN WHICH IS ON
CONSENT ITEMS SIXTEEN ON
CONSENT.
THIS HAS A DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS IT CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A FIVE ZERO VOTE MISSING
CHESTER.
HERTZBERG BOB HERTZBERG I HER
CONDO.
GENERAL BY AT AND HAIR THAT BILL
IS THAT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
WE'RE NOW MOVING FORWARD AND
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THIRTEEN DO
PASSES THE MANAGER PREPARATIONS
CURRENTLY HAS A FIVE YEAR ABOUT
MISSING CHESTER HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HER CONDO.
HELLO I SAID.
BUT SEVEN ZERO WOULD LIKE TO HIT
A PAS BUT HERE REAL QUICK TO SEE
IF.
I CENTER BILL NEED TO ADD ON TO
ANY ITEMS OR CAN WE LET HIM GO.
CAN YOU GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS.
HE HAS FORTY EIGHT AND ON TO
YEAH.
THE INVENTOR SCATTERED.
PLACING JENNISON ON ITEM NUMBER
TWO THAT'S A SEVEN ZERO VOTE THE
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB FIFTEEN DO PASSED TO
HOUSING COMMITTEE CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A THREE ONE VOTE MISS
LANCASTER.
FIRST.
HERTZBERG AYE HER TITLE.
YOUR TITLE I YOU HAVE.
TO A FIVE ONE FIVE ONE VOTE.
WE HAVE ANY OF CITIZENS RESIDE
YEAH YEAH NIELSEN.
LOADING OKAY SO WE'RE CLOSER.
THE GERMAN THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB FORTY EIGHT
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE THIS IS A DO PASSED IN
BERMAN EQUALITY MISSING
LANCASTER.
MARK BELL.
BELL AYE HERTZBERG FIRST FOR A
GUY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I YOU HAVE A SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO VOTE WITH ONE
ABSTENTION OF BELIEVE.
WORK SERVICE WELL I SOME IS A
SIX YEAR VOTE WE'RE KEEPING THE
ROLE OPEN.
MEMBERS WHO WE'RE GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE THIS IS A NEW PASTOR
PREPARATION JUST LANCASTER
HERTZBERG.
RIGHT HERTZBERG GUY HOTARU.
RICARDO I SEVEN SEVEN ZERO VOTE
THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB ONE EIGHTY TWO
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ONE
VOTE.
DO PASSED THE RULES THE NAME IS
WE TAKE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE
THE SAME CHESTER HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG GUY HER TITLE RICARDO
I SIX ONE SIX ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SP ONE EIGHTY NINE DO PASS
AS AMENDED DESCENT
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A FIVE YEAR OLD MISSING CHESTER.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE FURTADO
HER TITLE I SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE
CLOSE NUMBER WHEN I WENT ON TO
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB.
THREE OH NINE THIS IS A DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SUIT. TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A FIVE ZERO VOTE MISSING CHESTER
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI RICARDO.
RICARDO I SAID. SEVEN ZERO VOTE
THAT BILL IS AT WORK.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM SB
ADAM TEN SB THREE THIRTY DO
PASSED A HOUSING COMMITTEE THOSE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKING IN
HOUSING.
AT THE NEXT HEARING KERN VOTE IS
TO SEE TWO ZERO ISN'T JUST A
ROLL CALL WARLOCK.
BELL BELL I HERTZBERG.
REFER GUY HER TITLE.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I DO HAVE A SIX ZERO
MORE OF HIS OWN INTENT HERE ALL
RIGHT SIX ZERO WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN FOR I
SENATOR.
MORLOCK WITHOUT ANY MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN IS BEFORE
THIRTY EIGHT CURRENTLY.
JUST MISSING MORE OKAY WE'RE
GONNA SKIP THAT BECAUSE
DISMISSING THE VICE CHAIR --
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE YOU ALL VOTED
ON ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR ONE MISSING
CHESTER.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE HER
TITLE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible] FIVE ONE
EVERYBODY [inaudible]
ELLA [inaudible]
IT'S UP.
ALL RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT TO
WEAR CLOTHES IN THE ROLE.
YEAH ALL RIGHT MEMBERS ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT IT
IS CURRENTLY EIGHT TO TO VOTE
THIS IS A DO PASSED THE BANKING
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS MISLAID
JESTER WIRE.
HERTZBERG FIRST REGARD RICARDO
FOR TITLE I TO FOR TO VOTE DID
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE. FOR NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB FIVE THIRTY
TO DO PASSED A HOUSING COMMITTEE
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE TWO
VOTE MISSING CHESTER HERTZBERG.
FOR FOR A GUIDE HER TITLE.
THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TO VOTE --
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
MISS LANCASTER FELL.
I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NINE SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN SB SIX
EIGHTY ONE TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENTLY JOYS A
FOUR ZERO VOTE MISS LANCHESTER
FELL.
I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I SEVEN SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS THAT WERE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND FIND FINALLY THE GERMAN A
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR DO PASSED WITH BERMAN
QUALITY.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ONE VOTE
MISSING CHESTER HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE HER CONDO.
I HAVE A SIX LOOK AT THAT THE
BILL IS OUT SIX ONE FOUR CLOSE
IN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALL THE WORKERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GREAT JOB DO
APOLOGIZE ABOUT HOW LONG IT
WENT.
THANKS TO THE ENTIRE GOVERNMENT
BY TEAM.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE HEARING
OPEN UNTIL THE VICE CHAIR.
HEY THERE YOU GO EXACTLY IS
GOING.
TO GOING
.
TO IS WINTERS IS GONNA START
THROWING CHAIR IN A SECOND SO --
PROBLEM BACK WHERE IT WAS LIKE
JUST YOUR THE VICE CHAIR IS IN
TROUBLE.
RIGHT WAS LANCASTER [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO BE --
THE CENTERS ARE BELIEVE WE'RE
FOR BILLS THAT WERE -- A LOWER A
THIRTY THIRTY EIGHT HELLO CLASS
[inaudible]
HI -- IS SUCH A GOOD TEACHER.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S ONLY FOUR BILLS YET OKAY
SO WE JUST PULLED THOSE.
WHAT IS A GEMINI IS BACK THANKS
FOR YOUR PATIENCE STRAIGHT UP
FROM ORANGE COUNTY?
WE ARE GONNA BE TAKING ACTION --
MISTER SENATOR ON ITEM NUMBER
ONE FOR TEN AND ELEVEN ONE FOUR
TEN AND ELEVEN THOSE ARE THE
AREAS THAT WE NEED TO ADD YOUR
VOTE ON OR NOT.
WE LIKE THE ROAD VANCE AND ITEM
NUMBER ONE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
SIX ZERO VOTE.
THIS IS THE DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS MISSING CHESTER.
MORE LOCTITE Là TYSON. SEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT WE ARE
CLOSING THE ROLE.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR DO PASSED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN
IN ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO IS
LANCASTER FORELOCK.
NO BUT THAT IS GOING TO BE A SIX
ZERO FINAL VOTE FOR CLOSER ROLE
THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB THREE THIRTY THIS
IS A DO PASSED THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN IN HOUSING.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
MISSING JESTER MORLOCK.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A FINAL VOTE
OF SIX ZERO SIX ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT -- IMPLAUSIBLE
FINALLY ON ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN IS
BEFORE THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS A DO
PASSED TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
MISSING CHESTER FORELOCK.
MOORLACH NO THAT IS GOING TO BE
A SIX ONE VOTE WE ARE CLOSE THE
ROLE THAT BILLS OUTLAYS IN
GENERAL. TEN HOURS IN FORTY TWO
MINUTES LATER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
GOVERNED BY TEAM FOR ALL THE
WORK.
WE ARE GRATEFUL WE WILL BE BACK
WITH THIRTY ONE BILLS ON APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH THIRTY ONE BILLS
IN APRIL TWENTY FOURTH.
HELP YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL SPRING
BREAK -- INDUSTRY MORE.
TALK TO HERE IN A WEEK